WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
HEARING DUE TO THE ONGOING COVER
NINETEEN SAFETY CONSIDERATIONS
WE ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM SO YOU'RE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE
A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
IN PERSON. WE HAVE TWENTY TWO
BILLS TODAY ON OUR AGENDA. THREE
OF THEM ARE ON CONSENT WE HAVE A
ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX UP UNTIL ONE
O'CLOCK SO WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
GET THROUGH ALL THESE BILLS BY
ONE O'CLOCK. AT WHICH TIME IF WE
ARE NOT THROUGH WITH OUR GENDER
WE WILL RECESS BRIEFLY AND MOVED
A HEARING ROOM ACROSS THE HALL
ROOM ONE TWENTY SEVEN. WE'RE
ASKING AUTHORS TO GIVE SYNCING
TO PRESENTATIONS EACH BILL KIND
OF TWO MAIN WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND TO IN OPPOSITION. EACH MAY
WHEN THIS GETS TWO MINUTES EACH.
FOR TOTAL FOUR MINUTES O EACH
SIDE WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
PRIMARY WITNESSES TO APPEAR IN
PERSON BUT WE'LL MAKE EXCEPTIONS
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS. PLEASE
BE ADVISED THAT FOR ALL OTHER
WITNESSES CALLING INTO REGISTER
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION ON THE BILL
WE ASK THAT YOU SAY ONLY YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. IF YOU SAY MORE THE
OPERATOR WILL CUT YOU OFF. IF
YOU ARE UNABLE TO GET THROUGH ON
THE PHONE PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY. TO THE
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE THIS WILL BECOME PART OF
THE OFFICIAL RECORD OF THE BILL.
WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR
FOLKS OUT HERE IN THE ROOM WE
CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
PLEASE EXIT THE ROOM IF YOU'RE
DONE TESTIFYING. AND NO LONGER
NEED TO BE TO REMAIN IN THE
HEARING ROOM. FOR FOLKS DIALING
IN. I WILL BE USING A- MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WIN THIS CONTEST TO FIND A
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN IN THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE ONE TWO SIX.
YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO
DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF YOUR BILL
IS TESTIFYING. IN THE BEGINNING
OF THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON. BE PLACED
IN THE QUEUE BASED ON. WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A BILL. IF
YOU WERE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
TELEVISION AT YOUR SITE YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST. AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WHAT IS PROVIDING THIS TO MONEY
FOR. AGAINST YOUR PAIN ON A LOT.
ONE NEEDS YOU YOURSELF. AND YOUR
CALL BONTA. I ALSO WANT TO.
ACCEPTING TESTIMONY THROUGH THE-
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE MAY
NEED TO LIMIT HOW LONG THE PHONE
LINES ARE OPEN BRIDGE BILL AS WE
ARE ON A TIGHT HEARING SCHEDULE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
UNDERSTANDING. AND WITH THAT
LET'S TAKE ROLE. WICKS HERE HERE
SEYARTO. YOU'RE THERE TO HEAR
CARILLO. CARILLO HERE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL HERE KALRA. COLOR HERE
KILEY QUIRK-SILVA. QUIRK-SILVA
HERE WARD. HAVE A CARMEN WE HAVE
A QUORUM GREAT IN THE FIRST BILL
BE AB TWENTY ELEVEN.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GET STARTED
HERE WITH AB TWENTY ELEVEN. THIS
WEEK'S WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU A MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND MR VICE
CHAIR FOR PRESIDING WHILE I
PRESENT THIS BILL. I'M HERE TO
TALK ABOUT AB TWENTY ELEVEN THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN HIGH ROAD
JOBS ACT THE BILL SPONSORED BY
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
AND SUPPORTED BY A WIDE ARRAY OF
SOCIAL JUSTICE ORGANIZATION
BUSINESS GROUPS UNION
CONTRACTORS ENVIRONMENTALISTS
HOUSING DEVELOPERS CIVIC GROUPS
AND FAITH BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
BEFORE I TELL YOU ABOUT THE
DETAILS OF THE BILL I WANT TO
TELL YOU WHY I THINK IT'S SO
IMPORTANT. WE HAVE A HOUSING
CRISIS THAT IS OUT OF CONTROL.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
ARE SLEEPING ON THE STREET. 80%
OF LOW INCOME TENANTS CAN ONLY
PAY THE RENT IF THEY SACRIFICE
OTHER BASIC BASIC NECESSITIES
LIKE FOOD. EDUCATION HEALTH
CARE. THE MEDIAN PRICE OF BUYING
A HOME IN CALIFORNIA IS NOW OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
MEETING THE AMERICAN DREAM OF
HOME OWNERSHIP IS ONLY AVAILABLE
TO THE RICHEST CALIFORNIANS.
POLLING CONTINUOUSLY SHOWS THAT
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS ARE
CALIFORNIA'S TOP TWO CONCERNS.
AT THE SAME TIME WE NEED TO
BUILD OUR CONSTRUCTION WORK
FORCE BACK IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES EIGHTIES AND NINETIES
WE REGULARLY BUILT MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND UNITS PER YEAR. BACK
THEN THOSE WERE HIGH WAGE JOBS
THAT WERE INCREDIBLE PATHWAY TO
A MIDDLE CLASS LIFE. NOW WE
REGULARLY BUILD FEWER THAN ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND UNITS YEAR
UNLESS YOU WERE FORTUNATE ENOUGH
TO BE WORKING ON A PUBLIC WORK
OR UNIONIZED CONSTRUCTION JOB
IT'S LIKELY OR WORKING IN LOW
WAGES AND POTENTIALLY
EXPLOITATIVE CONDITIONS. FINALLY
WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT HOW THIS
RELATES TO CLIMATE CHANGE AS THE
MOTHER OF TWO YOUNG DAUGHTERS
I'M TERRIFIED OF WHAT THE FUTURE
HOLDS FOR THEM. I NEED TO BE
ABLE TO LOOK THEM IN THE EYE AND
TELL THEM AS SOMEONE WHO IS IN A
POSITION OF LEADERSHIP THAT IS
ABLE TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE THAT I
DID EVERYTHING WITHIN MY POWER
WHEN THEY WERE STILL TIME TO DO
SO. AND AS THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE WHAT I CAN PRODUCE
BOLD LETTERS BLOOD RELATION
SAYING NECESSARY BUT
UNCOMFORTABLE UNCOMFORTABLE
CONVERSATIONS TO PROMOTE THE
HOUSING OF THE FUTURE HOW HOUSES
NEAR JOB IN TRANSPORTATION THAT
ALLOW US TO SLASH OUR CARBON
EMISSIONS. I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. THIS BILL
AIMS TO ADDRESS ALL OF THESE
PROBLEMS FOR MAKING IT MUCH
EASIER TO BUILD HOUSING AT SCALE
AND CLIMATE FRIENDLY FRIENDLY
LOCATIONS. USING HIGHER LABOR
STANDARDS THAT PROTECT AND
UPLIFT OUR EXISTING WORKERS
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY. GROWING A
WHOLE NEW GENERATION OF HIGHLY
TRAINED WOMEN AND MEN. HOW WILL
WE DO THAT. BY MAKING AFFORDABLE
AND MIXED INCOME MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING. A USE BY RIGHT IN AREAS
THAT ARE APPROPRIATE FOR. THING
BUT WHERE IT IS. DIFFICULT OR
IMPOSSIBLE TO BUILD. BY BEING BY
RIGHT DEVELOPERS CAN MOVE
FORWARD WITHOUT THIS IS.
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF RED TAPE
THAT INCREASES COSTS AND KILLS
MANY VIABLE PROJECTS. WERE
TAKING THE COST SAVINGS. OF
ALLOWING HOUSING BY RIGHT AND
GIVING IT BACK IN THE FORM OF
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND
BETTER PAY FOR CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS. 5100% AFFORDABLE
PROJECTS BRINGING DOWN THE COST
MEAN. MAKE OUR PUBLIC MONEY GO
FAR. FOR ALL OF THE PROJECTS
THAT WE'RE REQUIRING THAT 15% OF
THE UNITS WOULD NEED TO BE
AFFORDABLE. TO LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS OR 30% MODERATE
INCOME FOR HOMEOWNERSHIP. THIS
REQUIREMENT COULD RESULT IN AN
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF NEW
AFFORDABLE UNITS WITHOUT
REQUIRING PUBLIC SUBS. AS FOR
WHERE THE HOUSING CAN GO IT
WOULD NEED TO BE LOCATED IN
AREAS THAT CURRENTLY ALLOW FOR
RETAIL OFFICE BUILDING AND
PARKING LOTS. FURTHER MORE MIXED
INCOME HOUSING WOULD BE LIMITED
TO COMMERCIAL CORRIDORS
BASICALLY THOSE STREETS THAT IN
THE MOST CITIES ARE LINED WITH
STRIP RETAIL LOTS OF PARKING.
THE PERFECT PLACE TO ALLOW A LOT
MORE TO ALLOW A LOT MORE HOUSING
. BECAUSE THE SITES NEED TO
ALLOW FOR COMMERCIAL USE WE ARE
DIRECTING NEW HOUSING AWAY FROM
SINGLE FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS. AND
THIS BILL ALLOWS FOR MIXED USE
PROVIDING OPTIONS FOR RETAIL ON
THE GROUND GROUND FLOOR FOR MORE
VIBRANT WALKABLE NEIGHBORHOODS.
PROJECTS WOULD NEED TO MEET
OBJECTIVE DESIGN STANDARDS TO
EITHER ESTABLISHED BY THE BILL
OR BY THE LOCAL CITY OR COUNTY.
FINALLY I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
LABOR STANDARDS IN THIS BILL
THAT ARE DESIGNED TO CREATE TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF HIGHROAD HIGHLY
PAID. CONSTRUCTION JOBS. ALL
WORKERS WOULD BE PAID THE
PREVAILING WAGE ENABLING ARE
HARD WORKING MEN AND WOMEN TO
LEAVE MIDDLE CLASS LIFE. ALL
WORKERS WILL BE PROTECTED FROM
WAGE THEFT BY THE STRONGEST
ENFORCEMENT STANDARD. ON RECORD.
ONLY IF THE PROJECT IS FIFTY OR
MORE UNITS THEY WERE. BRING A
PER. THE I GREW UP IN A RACE TO
LOOK PEOPLE. WE PUT ASIDE LISTS
ALTHOUGH. TWENTY ELEVEN IS A
BILL BUT OUR HOUSING CRISIS BOLD
ACTION WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO KEEP HOUSING OUR
HOMELESS KEEP TENANTS IN PLACE
TO KEEP PROPERTY OWNERS FROM FOR
CLOSING BUT THE ONLY WAY OUT OF
THIS CRISIS IS TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS A FUNCTIONING MARKET
PLACE WHERE HOUSING IS A BUNCH
AFFORDABLE PEOPLE K. OPTION
ABOUT TO HAVE WORK WITH A RANGE
OF ALL. BACKGROUNDS THERE WILL
PRO. THIS UP UPPING IT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND UPLIFTING WORKERS WHO
BUILD THESE UNITS. WITH ME HERE
TO TESTIFY AS RAY PEARL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
AND J. BRADSHAW EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS AND I
WOULD LIKE TO ALSO ALLOW MY JOIN
AUTHOR MISTER GRAYSON TO. MARCH
AS WELL. MISTER RAISING GOOD
THANK YOU VICE CHAIR. THERE WAS
A AT THE END OF SESSION LAST
YEAR THAT A AND ASSEMBLY HOUSING
WORKING GROUP WAS PUT TOGETHER
ASSEMBLED IN THE FALL OF LAST
YEAR THAT HOUSING WORKING GROUP
MYSELF ALONG WITH TWENTY SEVEN
OF MY COLLEAGUES- THROUGHOUT
THAT TOUR- WOULD IT RANGE FROM
CHEAP GO ALL THE WAY TO SAN
DIEGO OVER TWENTY TWO NIGHTS ON
THE ROAD. WE FOURNETTE THE LIST.
AND WE DID AND- YEAH HERE WE DID
AND THERE WERE A LOT A LOT OF-
MEETINGS WHERE HOUSING OBVIOUSLY
IT WAS THE CENTER AND CORPS OF
DISCUSSION BUT A LOT OF EVIDENCE
ALSO THROUGH SIGHT SEEING WAS
WITNESSED AND THERE WAS A VERY
CLEAR MESSAGE THAT RESONATED
FROM THAT HOUSING WORKING GROUP
TOUR AND IT IS THIS THAT OUR
HOUSING AND AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
IS UNDENIABLY DIRE. AND THE
CALIFORNIA AVERAGES FEWER THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW UNITS PER
YEAR AND OUR STATE HAS NEVER IN
ANY YEAR PRODUCED MORE THAN
TWENTY THOUSAND NEW AFFORDABLE
HOMES THE LACK OF SUPPLY IN NEW
DEVELOPMENT HAS PUSHED HOME
OWNERSHIP FURTHER OUT OF REACH
WORKING FAMILIES AND BECAUSE THE
MEDIAN PRICE OF SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES TO SOAR B. EIGHT HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS. IS AN EX MORE IN ORDER
TO SOME KEEP WITH THE DEMAND
WHICH IS NOT REALLY ENOUGH TO
ADDRESS TE CRISIS WE NEED TO
BUILD ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND NEW HOUSING UNITS A
YEAR INCLUDING EIGHTY THOUSAND
UNITS. AFFORDABLE TO LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WE ARE FAR
PASSED THE TIME APPROPRIATE TO
TAKE ACTION ON THIS CRISIS BUT
THE NEXT BEST TIME IS RIGHT NOW.
BY JOINING AB TWENTY ELEVEN AS A
JOINT AUTHORS THANK YOU TO- THE
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS I
HOPE TO BE A PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO GET. MORE OF THE
HOUSES OR HOMES OUR COMMUNITIES
NEED BUILT ESPECIALLY ON
UNDERLIES CURRENT COMMERCIALLY
ZONED LANDS AND ALONG TRANSIT
CORRIDORS AND AT THE SAME TIME.
I AM COMMITTED TO HAVING THE
NEEDS OF CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
VALUED AND HEARD BECAUSE OUR
HOUSING SHOULD OUR HOUSING GOALS
SHOULD. BE A- AFTER. OF OUR
HARDWORKING UNION WORKERS AND MY
INVOLVEMENT AS A JOINT AUTHORS
IT DOES ALLOW ME THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO BE INVOLVED IN
THE SOLUTION THAT CEATES NEW
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES WHILE
PROTECTING WORKER OPPORTUNITIES.
BOTH OF WHICH ARE ABSOLUTELY
EAST CENTRAL TO THE WELL BEING
OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND
FUTURE THANK YOU. YOU MISTER
GRAYSON WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF AB
TWENTY ELEVEN WHICH MANY WOULD
LIKE TO GO FIRST YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS RUSHER GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS RAY PEARL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM.
CHC IS A NONPARTISAN ADVOCATE
FOR THE PRODUCTION AND
PRESERVATION OF HOUSING
AFFORDABLE TO LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME CALIFORNIANS AND
COMMITTED TO THE GOAL THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIA HAVE A SAFE PLACE TO
CALL HOME. DESPITE THE
LEGISLATURE'S DEMONSTRATED
COMMITMENT TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
FACE A SHORTFALL OVER ONE
MILLION HOMES AFFORDABLE TO THE
STATE'S LOWEST INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS CHC HAS WORKED CLOSELY
WITH MEMBERS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO TRY TO DEVELOP
SOLUTIONS THAT MATCH THE SCALE
OF OUR STATE'S HOUSING
CHALLENGES. WE HAVE REPEATEDLY
COMMITTED TO FINDING.
COLLABORATIVE SOLUTIONS THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND ACCESS TO
WELL PAYING JOBS FOR WORKERS ALL
OVER THE STATE WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME INCREASING HOUSING
PRODUCTION FOR CALIFORNIANS MOST
VULNERABLE. IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE NOTED TO
CRITICAL ISSUES FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROVIDERS. ONE WE
BELIEVE THAT DEVELOPMENTS
RECEIVING NEW LAND USE BENEFITS
SHOULD CREATE STEADY WELL PAYING
JOBS AND HELP BUILD THE MIDDLE
CLASS CONSTRUCTION WORK FORCE
THAT EVERY COMMUNITY NEEDS. WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT PROJECTS
CANNOT MOVE FORWARD IF
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ARE NOT
AVAILABLE A REAL AND GROWING
CHALLENGE IN MANY PARTS OF THE
STATE. IN OUR VIEW AB TWENTY
ELEVEN FINALLY STRIKES THE RIGHT
BALANCE AND FOR THAT REASON I AM
HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY AS A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. AB TWENTY ELEVEN
PAIRS THE ABILITY TO BUILD
HOUSING ON UNDER UTILIZED
COMMERCIAL SITES WITH STRONG
LABOR STANDARDS THAT ENSURE ALL
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS EARN
PREVAILING WAGES. AND EARNED
HEALTH BENEFITS. THE BILL ALSO
INCLUDES DOUBLE OFF RAMPS THEY
GIVES WORKERS IN STATE APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THE
FIRST SHOT AT THESE JOBS. THIS
BILL ALSO HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
OPEN THOUSANDS OF NEW SITES TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND TO
RAPIDLY ACCELERATE HOUSING
PRODUCTIONS. AT ALL INCOME
LEVELS. FOR THESE REASONS I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY AND WE ARE
PROUD TO STAND. WITH ALL OF YOU
TO HELP SOLVE THE STATE'S
HOUSING CRISIS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS TWO MINUTES
PLEASE. HI GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN- GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JAY BRADLEY
ON THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND STRONG.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS
UNION REPRESENTING TWENTY TWO
LOCAL UNIONS HARD WORKING MEN
AND WOMEN THROUGHOUT OUR GREAT
STATE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. I
WANT TO HEAR TO TALK ABOUT YOUR
THE STATS DISTRICTS THEY AFFECT
OUR MEMBERSHIP IN WORKERS ACROSS
THE BOARD- WE'RE LOOKING WITH A
SHORTFALL TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
HOUSING UNITS NEEDED. ON THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY. I
WANNA SHARE WITH YOU THE
POSITION THE CARPENTERS UNION AS
WE ARE HERE TO GET TO WORK WE
ARE HERE TO BUILD. MUCH NEEDED
HOUSING- LOOKING AT THE WORK
FORCE ISSUES- NOT ONLY WITH THIS
WOULD BE A TREMENDOUS PLATFORM
FOR OUR CURRENT MEMBERSHIP. TO
GET OUT THERE ENCOURAGE
APPRENTICESHIP BUT ALSO TO RAISE
STANDARDS FOR ALL CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS. IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CURRENTLY ONE THIRD OF ALL
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS. WORKING IN
HOUSING ARE BELOW THE POVERTY
LINE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ANOTHER 25% UNDERNEATH THAT ARE
ON PUBLIC ASSISTANCE JUST TO GET
BY. THIS IS A SITUATION WHICH IS
UNTENABLE. I CANNOT STAND. SO
FOR WORKING FOLKS WORKING CLASS
PEOPLE. THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
THE DOUBLE HIT OF THE LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND A BROKEN
SYSTEM OF DELIVERY. I HAS ALSO
CREATED SITUATION CONSTRUCTION
ACROSS THE BOARD. IN HOUSING THE
HOUSE WERE TALK ABOUT BUILDING
NOW WHERE IT'S BUILT THE POVERTY
RATES CASH PAY AND LABOR
VIOLATIONS SO WE'RE HERE TO
SUPPORT THIS TO BUILD QUALITY
HOUSING IN AN EFFICIENT MANNER
BUT ALSO TO RAISE ALL WORKERS.
ARE CURRENT MEMBERS AND ALSO TO
BRING NEW FOLKS IN TO GET THOSE
RIGHTS ON THE JOB. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT THAT AND BRING
SOLUTIONS TO THESE TWO MAJOR
PROBLEMS WE ARE FACED ROOTED IN
HOUSING. STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR. SO AT THIS TIME
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO AND I WANT
EVERYBODY PAY ATTENTION WE'RE
GONNA SEPARATE WE'RE THE FIRST
PEOPLE ARE GONNA BE PEOPLE AND
IN. SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE. SO
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM THAT ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE YOU MAY
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME THE ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE FROM. AND YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE MEASURE AND- PLEASE
LIMITED TO THAT SO WE CAN GET
EVERYBODY I'M SURE THERE'S A LOT
OF PEOPLE WISH TO SPEAK. SO SIR
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS PETE
RODRIGUEZ EXECUTIVE SECRETARY
TREASURER. OF THE SOUTHWEST
REGIONAL COUNCIL OF CARPENTERS
WE REPRESENT FIFTY EIGHT
THOUSAND MEMBERS. ARE WE WANT TO
BUILD AND WE'RE READY TO BUILD
TODAY AND WE LOOK- AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR SUPPORT-
NO ANYWHERE ELSE ON BEHALF OF
GREEN LINING INSTITUTE WITH A
SUPPORTING CONCEPT POSITION
REALLY APPRECIATED DIALOGUE WITH
TERROR COMMITTEE STAFF AND LOVE
TO MOVE TO A SUPPORT POSITION
EVENTUALLY- AND WANT TO HAVE
THOSE ONGOING DISCUSSIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE YES MORE
SPEAKERS FROM THE HALLWAY SIR
ARE YOU COMING UP TO SPEED. GO
AHEAD. DAM BRADEN I'M- DR ALL
LAUGHTER LOCAL NINE ONE OH NINE
I'M HERE IN IN SUPPORT OF THIS
AND THE OUR LOCAL REPRESENTS TWO
THOUSAND MEMBERS RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND THAT THE OUR
LOCALS IN SUPPORT OF THIS AS
WELL THANK YOU. RIGHT SPEAKERS
AS YOU'RE COMING UP TO THE MIKE
JUST IN CASE YOU DIDN'T HEAR
WHERE YOU WOULD LIKE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION THAT YOU
REPRESENT IF YOU DO REPRESENTING
AN ORGANIZATION. AND JUST YOUR
SIMPLE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
DANNY CURTAIN CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE OF CARPENTERS STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL THANK YOU
FOR THE HEARING THANK YOU SYMON.
THANK YOU. A ROOM DÍAS OF THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION OR
THE CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
NEVADA MERRIMAN MID PENN HOUSING
IN STRONG SUPPORT. NEVER CALLED
WITH A CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. MERIEL
NJ CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL HOUSING FINANCE AGENCIES
VERY STRONG SUPPORT. MORNING
COREY SMITH WITH A HOUSING
ACTION COALITION IN SUPPORT.
GERMANICA HOME TO HAVE A
CALIFORNIA BE IS STRONG SUPPORT
. MORNING MARKETS DAHLE THE ON
BEHALF OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN CHAIR TODD BLOOM STEIN
FOR THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING SOME UNION
EMPLOYERS IN SUPPORT. OUR STAIRS
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. SCINTIGRAPHY ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ALONG
POVERTY REALLY SAID ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL ENSURING THAT IT
CENTERS EQUITY THANKS. RYAN
ADDRESSED ON BEHALF OF THEIR
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION SUPPORTING
CONCEPT LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR'S. CARE A
PRACTICE BUSINESS AGENT LOCAL
TWENTY TWO CARPENTERS UNION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. JASON
MARTINEZ I'M WITH LOCAL SEVEN OH
ONE IN THE FRESNO AREA AND I AM
ALSO A VETERAN AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS. TWENTY MINUTES
SOUTHWEST CARPENTERS OUT OF
MONTEREY PARK LOCAL TWO ONE
THREE. ALL THE MEMBERS I
REPRESENT A STRONG SUPPORT AB
TWENTY ELEVEN THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE IS ROBBIE LA
LOCAL SEVEN THIRTEEN ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORTED
WE STRONGLY SUPPORTED. THEY
RIVAS DRIVE ALL THE OTHERS LOCAL
AT NINETY THREE FRESNO CORRIDOR
NINETY NINE QUARTER ALL THE
MEMBERS DOWN THERE 1100% SUPPORT
THIS BILL. GOOD MORNING SAM
WILLIAMS CARPER'S LOCAL FOUR
ZERO FIVE SANTA CLARA SAN BENITO
COUNTIES WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. MORNING COMMITTEE
EDWARD EVANS ON BEHALF OF-
CARPENTERS LOCAL TWO SEVENTEEN
AND SIXTEEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MEMBERS WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS KYLE
PATTERSON FROM THE SOUTHWEST
REGIONAL COUNCIL OF CARPENTERS
LOCAL NINE OH NINE SAMBAR DINO
CALIFORNIA. AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ALL MY NAME IS
CHRIS PUBLICITY I'M A PROUD
MEMBER AND FEEL REPRESENTED WITH
PAULA DRIVERS LOCAL THIRTY FOUR
ALAMEDA COUNTY- WE REPRESENT NOT
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FOUR HEAVY
HIGHWAY WE REPRESENT BRIDGE
WHARF KANNST- DOCK BUILDERS AND
COMMERCIAL DIVERS AND NOW WE'RE
PROUD TO OR IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY ELEVEN THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING EVERYBODY I WAS TÍNH DS
DRIVE A LOT THERE'S LOCAL SIXTY
EIGHT AL SENIOR AGENT AND I'M
HERE REPRESENTING THE- THREE
HAND AT THREE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED MEMBERS. THEY'RE ASKING
FOR YOUR POOR I BELIEVE IT'S
TIME. TO BUILD INTO REAL WET
APPRENTICESHIP THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. NAME ORGANIZATION
IN JUST YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME'S MARIA
CORONADO SELFLESS REGIONAL
COUNCIL OF CARPENTERS BURBANK
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OVER SIX
THOUSAND MEMBERS LOCAL ONE
THREE. STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS AT THAT EVENT TRUMP FROM THE
SOUTHWEST REGIONAL COUNCIL OF
CARPENTERS LOCAL ETAL FIVE.
OUTCOME REAL CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING DAMON COLOR
WITH NOR CAL CARPENTERS UNION
SENIOR AGENT OF GOVERNORS LOCAL
THIRTY FIVE AND SEVEN FIFTY ONE
PROBABLY REPRESENTING ABOUT
NINETEEN HUNDRED MEMBERS BETWEEN
THOSE TWO LOCALS COVERING. THE
WHOLE NORTH COAST- WE PROUDLY
STAND IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS GET OUT OF THE ROOM- I
REPRESENT THE LOCAL TWENTY
THIRTY SIX WERE- FORTY SIX SCOTT
COUNTY CIRCUIT WHY DON'T
CALIFORNIA. A HEARING SUPPORT
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
TWENTY ELEVEN THANK YOU. THE
MORNING COMMUNITY- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DOUG CHESHIRE
I'M FEEL REPRESENTED FOR
CARPENTERS LOCAL FIVE OH FIVE
AND SIX OH FIVE IN MONTEREY
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY. I'M HERE THIS
MORNING TO ASK FOR YOUR STRONG
SUPPORT THANKS VERYMUCH. GOOD
MORNING MY ALSO SIMILAR FOR THE
SOUTHWEST REGIONAL COUNCIL OF
CARPENTERS. CALIFORNIA WITH YOUR
LOCAL SEVEN TWENTY ONE MY STRONG
SUPPORT. AB TWENTY ELEVEN THANK
YOU SO MUCH. GOOD MORNING MARIO
SANTA CRUZ PRESIDENT OF LOCAL
ONE OH TWO MILLERITES
REPRESENTING SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
MEMBERS IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I ASKED FOR A STRONG SUPPORTER
OF AB TWENTY ELEVEN THANK YOU.
SAN FROM- SILMAR CALIFORNIA
LOCAL SIX SIX ONE FROM THE
SOUTHWEST REGIONAL COUNCIL OF
CARPENTERS- REPRESENTING OVER
FORTY FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS IN
THAT AREA AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RICH GOMEZ AND WITH SOUTHWEST
REGIONAL COUNCIL OF CARPENTERS.
LOCAL SEVEN ONE FOUR ORANGE
COUNTY REPRESENTING OUR MEMBERS.
ARE FORTY EIGHT HUNDRED MEMBERS
WERE- STRONGLY SUPPORTED THIS
BILL THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE THE NAME IS RAY LAWSON.
OF SOUTH WITH REGIONAL COUNCIL
CARPENTERS ALSO FROM LOCAL FIVE
SIX TWO IN THE BEAUTIFUL CITY OF
LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA. AND WE
ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL ALSO THANK. MORNING
COMMITTEE MANAGER JIM MORSE
FILLED REPRESENTED OUT OF COPPER
DOES LOCAL ONE FIFTY TWO
REPRESENTING STANISLAUS SAN
JOAQUIN MERCED MARIPOSA AND
WOLLEMI COUNTY AND ONE STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN THANK YOU. RIGHT NANCE
SOUTHWEST REGIONAL COUNCIL OF
CARPENTERS LOCAL SIX SIX ONE
TURNING YOUR MODEM COUNTIES
STRONGLY SUPPORTING THIS BILL
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS NITIN JOINS US IN A FEW
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE COMPANY'S
UNION HOW DO IN SACRAMENTO LOCAL
FORTY SIX WE REPRESENT TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED MEMBERS. AND IN THIS
AREA WE COVER SACRAMENTO COUNTY
YOU'LL COUNTY COLUSA YUBA SUTTER
- ELDORADO AND WESTONARIA-
PLACID AND WE WERE IN IN FULL
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY ELEVEN
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU MY NAME IS JOANNE
BACH. CARPER'S LOCAL SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY NINE I'M A FIELD
REPRESENTATIVE. I REPRESENT-
SIERRA EASTERN PLASTER EASTERN
ELDORADO NEVADA AND AN ALPINE
COUNTIES- WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ELEVEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR WICKS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RICK SALINAS WITH THE NOR CAL
CARPENTERS UNION AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ELEVEN.
THIS BILL ADVANCES THE STATE'S
HOWEVER OLD SIR YEAH JUST JUST
YOUR NAME DON'T UNIVERSALLY
NORTH HELICOPTERS UNION
REPRESENTING ABOUT. TWO HUNDRED
PLUS CARPENTERS OUT IN THE ROOM
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR COOPERATION I APPRECIATE
THAT AND NOW THANK YOU TO ALL
THE SPEAKERS YOU GUYS DO A GREAT
- NAME ORGANIZATION AND- YOUR
SUPPORT- AT THIS TIME WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS GO TO THE EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR FOR THOSE THAT ARE
IN SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL. AND
AGAIN NAME ORGANIZATION IN YOUR
SUPPORT THAT WAY WE CAN GET
EVERYBODY IN. SO AT T. OPERATOR
IF YOU CAN OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES. FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MR. THANK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS FOR THOSE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL PER THE
INSTRUCTIONS OF THE CHAIR.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE WILL GO TO LINE
FORTY TWO. PARDON ME JUST A
MOMENT. I'M FORTY TO YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. YEP GOOD MORNING OF
THE TH OF OPETH AMON TOLD WITHIN
A COULD STRONG SUPPORT. LINE
TWENTY LINE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOING TO MOVE ON THE LINE
THIRTY ONE. GOOD MORNING
VICTORIA ROME WITH NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AN RTC
SUPPORTING CONCEPT THANK YOU.
BEIN. SIXTY TWO. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AT THE OF CRANK
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE ALL
HOME AND AT THE AT HOME IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. LINE. FORTY THREE.
JACKYL TEN GEHRY CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER IN SUPPORT. FINE SIXTY
FIVE. YEAH THE NAME ARE YOU
KNOWN ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
COURT THANK YOU. LINE. EIGHTY
TWO. I NEED YOU TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LINE SEVENTY SIX. BOB
NAYLOR REPRESENTING FIELD SAID
COMPANY OWNED BY HOWARD AHMANSON
JUNIOR A PRO HOUSING. ONCE
OPPOSED IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
LINE NINE. MICHAEL A WHISPER IN
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE EIGHTY FOUR
. THE WIND ENERGY NOT MILLION BE
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE. SEVENTY
EIGHT. THE TECHNICAL COUNTY WITH
STANDING ARE YOU BEING
CALIFORNIA BE CONSTRUCTED FOR.
LINE. NINETY GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TRICKY STEVEN
ON BEHALF OF THE CONSTRUCTION
EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE THIRTY SIX
. FIVE DOUBLE BLUNDER ON BEHALF
OF THE IN THE REPORT AB TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY NINE. GOOD MORNING MR
VICE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROGER
DICKINSON PERCENT LIKE WELL
FORMERLY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. LINE NINETY BILL. DAVID
FEINBERG REPRESENT A RP IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. BUYING FORTY ONE. PAUL BIG
MORE CALIFORNIA MEET IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE SIXTY THREE IN
EVEN YEAH I I'M SORRY CALL ON
THE WRONG ONE. HELLO HAD.
MISMANAGING TERMS OF HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT FOR BOARD HOUSING
DEVELOPER HIGHLY CAL AGENT
ATTEMPT CO STRONG SUPPORT. LINE. FOURTEEN MY NAME IS FRANK
MARTINEZ I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF DEFENDANT CALIFORNIA
PHYSICIAN ON TOP OF IT M. AT
LEAST POLITICAL. LINE EIGHTY.
MACINNES CENTER COUNTY STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE. THIRTY TWO.
REBECCA THE ROUTINE CALIFORNIA
YIMBY STRONG SUPPORT. LINE.
NINETY SIX. NOW BISHOP
CARPENTERS LOCAL WANTED TO. IN
SUPPORT. WHY NOT. THIRTY THREE.
THE PROPOSAL ON BEHALF OF
ABUNDANT HOUSING LA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. A LINE. SIXTY ONE. HE
WILL GO TO LOCAL PPG WE OPPOSE.
LINE. SIXTY SIX. SIXTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. WELL TO MOVE
ON TO LINE SIX. HI I'M RICK
WILLIAMS BEAR THE THIRTIETH
DEMOCRAT AND A RETIRED CARPENTER
URGING STRONG SUPPORT. LINE
SEVENTY HILL. WHY WELL RENTER
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA FROM SUPPORT
. LINE EIGHTY THREE. I NEED THE
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
JEFF MADE A MOVE ON FROM. GO
AHEAD. I'M NOT MADE OF CALLING
AT THE PORT. LINE. SEVENTY FIVE.
MY NAME IS LISA DANCE I LIVE IN
FREMONT AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
. LINE EIGHTEEN. GOOD MORNING MR
LANDRY HONEST CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BUILDER STRONG SUPPORT
. LINE. NINETY NINE. BUTWHERE
WOULD BE THE ENVY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. AND AGAIN FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL ONLY AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE GO TO
LINE TWENTY SEVEN. ASSEMBLY
SIMON FROM NEW A HOME IN SUPPORT. AND ONCE AGAIN- IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO. WHINE WHINE ONE OH SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS CHAD BOJO ON THE COUNCIL
REPRESENTATIVE WITH THE LOS
ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCILS
REPRESENT REPRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS TO OUR FORTY EIGHT
AFFILIATES I'M IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO ZERO ONE
ONE SIX IS FOR SUPPORT LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN AGAIN THIS IS FOR
SUPPORT ONLY. ONE SEVENTY SEVEN.
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. LINE SEVENTY FOUR. I
MADE A CALL WITH THE COUNCIL OF
INFILL BUILDERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINED. ONE OH FIVE. HI
THIS IS MARVIN NORMAN ALL
RESIDENTS NUMBER DENOTES FONG
SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND NOW WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS GO TO THE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL SO I
BELIEVE WE HAVE SOME PRIMARY
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO COME UP.
AND PRESENT. OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
EACH. YOU COME ON UP TO THE
TABLE HERE. EITHER ONE OF YOU
WHOEVER WANTS TO GO FIRST YOU
MAY BEGIN. THE MORNING CHERO XMM
BIRDS OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ERIN LEHANE
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
NEARLY HALF A MILLION SKILLED IN
IN CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS INCLUDING SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND BUILDING TRADES
APPRENTICES. IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. TO AB TWENTY ELEVEN
AS MOST OF YOU KNOW THESTATE
BUILDING TRADES HAVE BEEN
CLOSELY INVOLVED IN HOUSING
LEGISLATION FOR YEARS. IT
IMPACTS OUR MEMBERS AS WORKERS
ARE MEMBERS WHO NEED HOUSING AND
OUR MEMBERS WHO LIVE IN
VIRTUALLY EVERY COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS LEGISLATION IN
THIS BILL ALSO IMPACTS THAT
THOUSANDS OF CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS WE DO NOT FORMALLY
REPRESENT. BUT THE WE HAVE A
MORAL OBLIGATION TO PROTECT.
LAST JUNE THE BERKELEY LABOR
CENTER PUT OUT A STUDY THAT
DOCUMENTED THE RAMPANT
MISTREATMENT OF CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS IN RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION. INCLUDING THE
PRACTICE OF UNDER THE TABLE PAY
LACK OF WORKERS COMP AND THE
NEARLY MAJORITY OF WHOM REQUIRE
STATE FAMILY ASSISTANCE IN ORDER
TO SURVIVE. INCLUDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. MEANWHILE PROFITEERING
DEVELOPERS ARE MAKING BILLIONS
OFF OF EXPLOITING A VERY REAL
HOUSING CRISIS PROFITS THAT THIS
BILL MAKES NO ATTEMPT TO LIMIT.
AB TWENTY ELEVEN IS NOT GOING TO
MATERIALLY ADDRESS THE HOMELESS
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS
THIS BILL RESULT IN A FURTHER
GENTRIFICATION OF WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES FOR PROFIT FOR
MOSTLY MARKET RATE DEVELOPMENT
AND WILL EMBOLDEN THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY THE PAYS
WORKERS LESSEN LEGAL WAGES AND
PROFITS ON A BUSINESS MODEL THAT
DOES NOT WANT WORKERS WHO ARE
AWARE. OF THEIR LEGAL RIGHTS ON
JOB SITES WERE TRAINED IN THE
ACTUAL TRADE THEY ARE EXPECTED
TO EXECUTE. THERE'S A LOT WRONG
WITH THIS BILL THAT WE HAVE SET
FORTH IN OUR LETTER. BEYOND THE
GENTRIFICATION FOR PROFIT
BUSINESS MODEL THIS BILL IS
PROMOTING THIS BILL CLAIMS TO
HAVE LABOR STANDARDS IT MIGHT AS
WELL BE WRITTEN IN INVISIBLE INK
IS ABLE DISAPPEAR BEFORE THE
FIRST WORKER LACE UP THEIR
BOOTS. WHETHER THIS IS
INTENTIONAL OR NOT IT'S AN
INTERESTING QUESTION AND DEPENDS
ON WHO IS ACTUALLY. IN THE
CURTAIN OF THIS BILL. THE BY THE
WAY WAS PITCHED YEARS AGO TO US.
BY THE FOR PROFIT DEVELOPERS WHO
HAVE BEEN CIRCLING SHARKS FOR
HEY. AND THERE'S CHUM IN THE
WATER. THIS BILL IS AN AFFRONT
TO OUR MEMBERSHIP IN THE LOCAL
BUILDING TRADES THAT HAVE BEEN
WORKING TO ENCOURAGE REAL
SOLUTIONS TO THE HOUSING CRISIS.
SOLUTIONS GEARED TO BUILDING
ACTUAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND
NOT PUT THE CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
BUILDING IT INTO THE QUEUE FOR
THE VERY HOUSING THEY'RE
BUILDING. SEVERAL OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS RESULTED IN BILLS
THAT THIS EXAMPLE EIGHT
INEXPLICABLY REFUSED TO BRING TO
A FLOOR VOTE. LAST SESSION EVEN
THOUGH IF IT HAD THIS HOUSING
WOULD LIKELY BE UNDERWAY. BUT
AGAIN THE SHARKS ARE CIRCLING
AND THE HOLD UP IN THE ASSEMBY
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH HOUSING
THE VULNERABLE IT HAS TO DO WITH
A BUSINESS MODEL THAT DOESN'T
QUESTION MILLIONS IN DEPTH
DEVELOPER PROFITS AND IS
THREATENED BY A WORK FORCE THAT
KNOWS ITS TRADE. ITS RIGHTS AND
IT'S WORTH. YESTERDAY AT THE
RALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL ONE
OF THE PROPONENTS SAID THAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS BUILDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THAT THEY CAN THEN LIVE
IN. AND THAT'S EXACTLY THE
PROBLEM. TRICKS PEOPLE SHOULD
NOT NEED AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THEY SHOULD BE PAID AND TREATED
COMMENSURATE WITH THEIR TRADE
AND THEIR TRAINING. AND EARNED A
PATH INTO THE MIDDLE CLASS NOT
EXACTLY WHY ON BEHALF OF OUR
NEARLY HALF A MILLION MEMBERS WE
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO. ON AB
TWENTY ELEVEN. YOU THE THIRD
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- EDUARDO
MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF THE ONE
POINT TWO MILLION MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
ELEVEN- AS MY SISTER FROM THE
BUILDING TRADES JUST MENTIONED
WE BELIEVE THE LABOR PROTECTIONS
IN THIS BILL ARE ILLUSORY THE
LACK OF A REQUIREMENT FOR
CONTRACTOR TO SUPPORT
APPRENTICESHIP BY UTILIZING A
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
MEANS CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
WORKERS WHO WERE DEEMED
ESSENTIAL THROUGHOUT THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC ARE ONCE AGAIN
LEFT OUT OF THE EQUATION. WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE NEED TO BUILD
MORE HOUSING NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
DISPUTES THE NATURE OF THE
CRISIS WE FIND OURSELVES IN YOU
WILL DISPUTE THE NEED TO BUILD
MORE HOUSING FOR ALL INCOME
LEVELS HOWEVER WE MUST REJECT
THE FALSE CHOICE THAT AB TWENTY
ELEVEN PRESENTS TO YOU TODAY
THAT THE ONLY WAY TO SOLVE THE
THIS CRISIS IS ON THE BACKS OF
BLUE COLLAR CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
TO THE BENEFIT OF BILLIONAIRE
CORPORATE HOUSING DEVELOPERS WHO
STAND TO BENEFIT FROM THIS
GENEROUS BY RIGHT APPROVAL
PROCESS A FORBIDDEN THIS BILL.
WE ADDRESS STRONGLY TO THE
PROVISIONS CONTAINED IN AB
TWENTY ELEVEN WE MUST ALSO
OBJECT TO THE PROCESS. WE BECAME
AWARE OF THIS BILL A FEW DAYS
BEFORE ITS INTRODUCTION AND WERE
PROVIDED LANGUAGE FROM A SOURCE
OTHER THAN THE AUTHOR OR HEARST.
WE KNOW WE ALL KNOW WE ALL KNOW
WHEN MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
INCLUDING THE AUTHOR ARE WELL
AWARE OF OUR INSISTENCE OF A
REQUIREMENT. THAT THE WORK FORCE
BE SKILLED AND TRAINED AND YET
WE'VE HAD REALLY VERY LITTLE-
DIALOGUE WITH THE AUTHOR ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WE DON'T DENY THE
EXISTENCE OF A HOUSING CRISIS
AND WE WANT TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION. BUT AS WE'VE DONE IN
THE PAST WE WILL SPEAK OUT
AGAINST PROPOSALS DEVELOPED ON
THE BACKS OF WORKING PEOPLE. THE
TWELVE HUNDRED AFFILIATES OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
STAND IN STRONG SOLIDARITY WITH
THE STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTIONS
CAGE TRADES COUNCIL. AND ASK YOU
FOR YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GONNA GO TO. PEOPLE IN THE ROOM-
THAT THAT WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE JUST STATE
YOUR NAME. THE ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT. YOUR OPPOSED TO THE
BILL. KEEFE DONE DISTRICT
COUNCIL IRON WORKERS IN
OPPOSITION PERFECT. NEXT WEEK A
PLEASE. HEY ROB STOKE
REPRESENTING SHEET METAL WORKERS
LOCAL ONE OH FOUR AND WE STAND
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL BUT
ARE ENCOURAGED THAT THE AUTHOR
IS OPEN TO BRINGING ALL THE
PARTIES TOGETHER FOR REAL
SOLUTION. GOOD MORNING DANNY
BERNARDINI NAPA'S ON A BUILDING
TRADES I STAND WITH THE STATE
TRADES IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ANDREAS KLUBER
ALAMEDA COUNTY BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL WE STAND IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. GOOD MORNING JASON
LINDSAY PRESIDENT BUSINESS AGENT
OF IRONWORKERS LOCAL THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT WE STAND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
FOURTEEN A CAREER LOCAL SIXTEEN
INSULATORS AND WE STAND
TOGETHER. WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA STATE BILL INTEREST
IN A POSITION. GOOD MORNING
MAGGIE LOCAL TWO TWO EIGHT
DOLLARS AND PIPETTORS WE STAND
WITH STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSE THIS BILL. GOOD MORNING
TRI ARNTZEN REPRESENTATIVE FOR
THE IRON WORKERS OF CALIFORNIA-
IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING FRIEDMAN DAVIS
IRON WORKERS LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN
AND I STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL. MARK THE BILL HE TO
FROST IS SLURS LOCAL SIXTEEN
DELEGATE TO ALAMEDA AND CONTRA
COSTA BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. HELLO MY
NAME IS LORENZO TWO ONE IS WITH
DARKER IS ONE EIGHTEEN. MAR
FOURTH PEER PRINTERS. I STAND
WITH THE STATE BUILDING AND
OPPOSED. AND IT'S BEEN CROCHET
I'M A SECOND PERIOD APPRENTICE
WITH LOCAL ONE EIGHTY NINE
WORKERS AND I STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES AND OPPOSE THIS
BILL. GOOD MORNING KEN MILLER
IRONWORKERS LOCAL THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT I STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES AND OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. MORNING MY
NAME'S CLAY MORSE IRONWORKERS
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT AND I'M
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. GOOD
MORNING ANTHONY THIS USE OF
BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE FOR
LOCAL SIXTEEN HEAT AND FROST
INSULATORS AND ME TO. CURTIS
MEGAN IBEW FIFTH YOUR ROVINCE-
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. NATHAN
WELCOMING IBEW LOCAL THREE FORTY
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. THE MAJOR TO
ASSIST LOCAL THREE FORTY I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. I'M MICHELLE
STOFFEL OF IBEW LOCAL THREE
FORTY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BOB WILLIAMS FORTY ONE YEAR IBEW
MEMBER RETIRED. HI STAND WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES. GOOD
AFTERNOON ON MACEY STEELMAN
RETIRED FIFTY TWO YEARS IBEW
OFFICE BUSINESS MANAGER LOCAL
THREE FORTY ARE SERVED ON THE
STATE BUILDING TRADING SECOND
ABOARD FOR OVER TEN YEARS AND I
SUPPORT THE STATE KNOWING TRADE
POSITION. I JOHN HERSHEY
ADJOURNMENT MEMBER OF UNITED
ASSOCIATION OF PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL FOUR FOUR
SEVEN HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND- WE
STAND OPPOSED THANK YOU. MMHM IT
OR SEND OF ALL IBEW LOCAL THREE
FORTY- FIFTY APPRENTICE I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. ELEVEN THANK OF IVY
THEY'LL BE THREE FORTY AND I
OPPOSE WILL. ARMORED THIS
KIRKPATRICK LOCAL THREE FORTY
FIVE. AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JAMES MORE PRENTICE IBEW LOCAL
THREE FORTY AYE PO THIS BILL.
SPENCER HAS IBEW THREE FORTY-
APPRENTICE I OPPOSE THIS. CHANTE
LOCAL THREE FORTY AYE OPPOSED.
I'M SCOTT RANDY HOOK A THREE
FORTY FIFTY APPRENTICE AND I
OPPOSED TO. BRENDAN NELSON IBEW
LOCAL THREE FORTY APPRENTICESHIP
INSTRUCTOR AND I OPPOSE. MANY
PINERA MONTEREY SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES AB TWENTY ELEVEN WE
OPPOSE WITH STATE BUILDING
TRADES. KEVIN FOR OUR SECOND
ZERO BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. JEFFERIES
BOILERMAKERS INTERNATIONAL
STANDING IN OPPOSITION OF- AB
TWENTY ELEVEN THINGS THE BILL TO
TRACE. GOOD MORNING CHUCK
LEONARD PLUMBERS AND STEAM
FITTERS LOCAL THREE FORTY TWO
POLITICAL REPRESENTATIVE AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
RIGHT I BELIEVE THAT IS THE END
OF THE PEOPLE IN THE ROOM OR IN
THE HALLWAY SO- WE ARE GOING TO
GO TO THE EIGHTEEN T. PHONE
LINES FOR PEOPLE THAT AREIN
OPPOSITION ONLY. TO AB. TWO OH
ONE ONE. EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR GO
AHEAD AND- START THE PROCESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AGAIN
THIS IS FOR ONLY THOSE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. WE'RE GONNA START WITH
WINE NINETY SEVEN. THANK YOU%
THIS IS JOHN COURTS ON BEHALF OF
YOU A LOCAL THIRTY EIGHT
PLUMBERS AND STEAM FITTERS IN
SAN FRANCISCO WOULD JOIN IN THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSING THIS BILL THANKS. LINE
FIFTY ONE. JOHN DORY I'D LOCAL
SIX IN OPPOSITION SCHLINE
SEVENTY THREE. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN KILEY SHALL BE CALLING
ON THE HAPPENED- MY GOING PARK
MISSION YEAH HELLO AND MOHANPUR
AND HOPING THANK YOU. LINE
TWENTY. HI GREG HARDY RECORD IN
YOUR YOU DAHLE THEY CONSTRUCT
LOCAL AND ARE OPPOSED THE BILL.
A LINE A- SHOULD MORE ROB NOTAR
QUALITY DIRECTOR WITH THE
ANGELES COUNTY FIRE OF
REPRESENTING A HUNDRED THOUSAND
UNION MEMBERS CALLING IN
OPPOSITION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
OF LABOR. BY NINETY ONE. YEAH MY
NAME IS JEFF HUNTER LOCK WITH
THE HUMBOLDT DEL NORD BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES WE STAND
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. LINE. SEVENTY HELLO THIS IS JACOB
DON'T QUALIFY WITH THE I. B. E.
W. LOCAL ELEVEN LOS ANGELES AND
WE STAND IN OPPOSITION WE STAND
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES ON
THERE. AB TWENTY LEVEL. LINE ONE
TWELVE. MORNING MR SHARE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FALCONS ON THE
UP THE CITY APPARENT IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY
. CHRIS LONG GLORIA BUSINESS
AGENT IBEW LOCAL IN OPPOSITION.
WHY NOT. ONE FIFTEEN. ONE ONE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
MORNING KAREN MEMBERS JAMES
THEREAFTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL BELIEVERS WE ARE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
LINE. FIFTY THREE. THE MORNING
DANNY RIGHT BUSINESS MANAGER FOR
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS
REPRESENTING SIX HUNDRED AND
THIRTY PLUMBERS AND PIPE MEMBERS
IN THE FRESNO MADERA KINGS AND
TULARE COUNTIES AND WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. LINE.
FORTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING
GRETCHEN NEWSOM ON BEHALF OF
IBEW LOCAL FIVE SIX NINE THREE
SIX HUNDRED UNION ELECTRICIANS
GOING TO CARROLL COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION- AS AMENDED. ONE
FORTY SIX. GOOD MORNING ON A
WHEELCHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
RICK SMILED SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT COUNCIL OF LABORERS
NUMBER HAVE OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
PLUS CONSTRUCTION CRAFT LABORERS
WE STAND IN OPPOSITION OF. AB.
TWENTY ELEVEN THIRTY. LINE FORTY
EIGHT. THE MORNING BILL PRESS
KNOWING TRADE COUNCIL SALMON IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WHICH WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK YOU
LINE THIRTEEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
BENITO ROBINSON WITH LABOUR'S
DISTRICT COUNCIL IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY ELEVEN. THANK
YOU LINE ELEVEN. GOOD MORNING-
THIS IS YOUR TOMORROW EXCELLENT
FROM NORTHERN. PLEASE STAND WITH
BUILDING IN A- OF BABY TWENTY
LEFT THANK YOU. LINE. NINETY
EIGHT. WHY NINETY EIGHT. HELLO
YES YES MY NAME GOOD MORNING MY
NAME'S JOHN HENRY LOPEZ ON WITH
THE PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS
LOCAL TO FORCE THE- AND- WHAT
WE- STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY
SIX. ONE SIXTY SIX OR ONE NOW
OPEN. IN A MOVE ON THE LINE
THIRTY FIVE. IF I WANTED TO
CHECK CONDUCTOR YOU MAY LOOK ONE
FIVE NINE PROMISES DEEP THERE'S
HOT COSTA COUNTY WE STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
WITH BOTH OF. THANK YOU. WHY
SIXTY BREGOLI. IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS. LINE. ONE OH FOUR. MY NAME
IS DR DAVID SOON BUSINESS RAPPER
LOCAL THIRTEEN NINE NINE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA APPEAR
NATIONAL UNION PAIRS KNOWLEDGE
TRADES WE STAND WAS THE BILLING
TRAYS TO STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL AB
TWO ABOUT THEIR LEVEL OF THANK
YOU. LINE. FIFTY EIGHT. RECALL
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. LINE. TWENTY FOUR. YOU CAN
DOLLARS SENTENCES BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
AFL-CIO IN OPPOSITION OF. TWENTY
ONE. WHY EIGHTY. THE MORNING
GOES WAY UP HERE WILL YOU ABLE
SEVERAL NIGHTS WE CAN WITH THE
STATE BUILDING BUT THE BUILD SB
TWO ELEVEN THANK YOU. LINE.
SIXTY ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINES
NOW OPEN. GOING TO MOVE ON TO
LINE FORTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS RODNEY COBLE'S I'M WITH
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PIPE
TRADES- WITH ITS THIRTEEN
AFFILIATED LOCAL UNIONS NEARLY
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND MEMBERS WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BELYING. NINETEEN LINE NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. I'D BE
LOCAL FIVE NINETY FIVE AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE IT I MUST ADMIT
THANK YOU. LINE. ONE TWENTY. HI
THIS IS DAVE GONZALEZ. I LIVE IN
COLUSA COUNTY I STAND IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU HAVE IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO WE'RE GOING TO GO ON TO
BLIND. SIXTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS NATALIE HIGLEY I'M
REPRESENTING THE MEMBERS OF IBEW
LOCAL FIVE FIVE ONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. WHY
FIFTY NINE. FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN- DOUG MENJADI I B.
E. W. FOUR FOUR ONE ORANGE
COUNTY REPRESENTING TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED MEMBERS WE OPPOSE THEM
LESS AMENDED THANK YOU. LINE AT
ONE. GOOD MORNING THIS IS MORE
PRONE OF CALIFORNIA STATE
BUILDING TREATS WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS. THANK YOU FINE. ONE
OH NINE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JOE SHE CARE NICK I'M A RESIDENT
OF GLENN COUNTY I AM A STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO ZERO ONE
ONE. THANK YOU. BY. NINETY FOUR.
GOOD MORNING RENDON LEVIN BERG
YOU A LOCAL TWO FOUR SIX FRESNO
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS UNION
WE STAND WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL. LINE. FIFTY GOOD
MORNING RENEE COULD MARTINEZ
CALLING ON BEHALF OF TWENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND MEMBERS OF IBEW
LOCAL TWELVE FORTY FIVE IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED THANK
YOU. LEVINE AT WHAT. GOOD
MORNING MORTON RODRIGUEZ I
WORKERS LOCAL FOUR THIRTY THREE
LOS ANGELES WE STAND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. LINE ONE TWENTY THREE
. GOOD MORNING THIS IS CLINT
SMITH THE BUSINESS MANAGER THE
RIVERS AND WATER PURPOSE LOCAL
THIRTY SIX IN LOS ANGELES WE
STAND WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO GOING TO GO TO LINE SIXTY
ONE. ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. LINE FORTY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JASON BUSINESS
MANAGER OF IBEW LOCAL FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN REPRESENTING OVER FOURTEEN
HUNDRED MEMBERS AND SALMON TO DO
YOU KNOW ANYONE MODEL COUNTY. WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY TELL. I
NEEDED TO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. AND MOVE ON TO LINE TWENTY.
MARK CURRY PLUMBERS LOCAL FOR
SIX SEVEN AND APPRENTICESHIP
TRAINING CENTER IN SAN MATEO
COUNTY AND COMMISSIONER ON THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP COUNCIL
THE APPRENTICE AND SKILL DURING
LEVEL WORKERS I REPRESENT STAND
WITH CALIFORNIA BUILDING TRADES
WORKERS AND ADAMANTLY OPPOSE AB
TWENTY ELEVEN. LINE SIXTY BUCKS. ONE SIXTY SIX TO ONE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO YES SIR PLEASE GO.
HELLO GOOD MORNING THIS IS ONE
CALDERON AND ALLIED TRADES AND
SEMISOLID DIRTY IN THE POCONO
POSITION OF AB TWO ELEVEN ON THE
COMMENDED. WHY. TWENTY ONE. HI
THIS IS MARK BUEHRLE WITH IBEW
LOCAL FOUR TO EIGHT WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL UNLESS AMENDED. LINE.
SEVENTEEN THIS IS RACHEL
SHOEMAKER IBEW LOCAL THREE OH
TWO REPRESENTING OVER FOURTEEN
HUNDRED ELECTRICAL WORKERS AND
CONTRA COTA COUNTY WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
LINE SIXTY ONE. HE WILL BE
LIVING WITH YOU A PIPEFITTERS
LOCAL PPD LOS ANGELES WE'VE BEEN
. ANYTHING WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY ELEVEN. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY FIVE. ALOHA COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS MITCHELL THAT'LL
WITH THE DISTRICT COUNCIL IRON
WORKERS WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRIP IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
LINE. EIGHTY TWO. MY NEEDED TO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S THERE KATHY OF
THE PLUMBERS LOCAL LOCAL FOR SIX
SEVEN TRAINING CENTER IN SAN
MATEO COUNTY THE APPRENTICES AND
SKILL DURING THE WORKERS ARE
PRESENT ADAMANTLY OPPOSED AB TWO
ELEVEN BECAUSE IT LACKS
CALIFORNIA SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE REQUIREMENTS THANK YOU
. LINE ONE TWENTY SIX- WHY ONE
TWENTY SECURE LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THIS IS JOHN MACK IN SECOND WITH
IBEW LOCAL FIVE FIVE ONE WE
STAND WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION. TWENTY ELEVEN.
MISTER CHAIR THERE WAS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY WHICH
SPEAK. ALL RIGHT YOU VERY MUCH
AND I THINK ALL THE SPEECH AND-
PEOPLE GIVING TESTIMONY FOR
THEIR COOPERATION- SO THAT WE
CAN GET EVERYBODY'S VOICE IS
HEARD. SO I'M GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AT THIS
TIME I'M GONNA START WITH MR
GABRIEL OVER THERE. MISTER
CARILLO. YEAH I THINK YOU- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO-
I'M GONNA HAVE TO RUN ON A
SECOND AGO PRESENT
APPROPRIATIONS BUT I AM. GOING
TO BE ENTHUSIASTICALLY
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
JOINT AUTHORS FOR BRING IT
FORWARD- IT JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT CAN OFTEN TIMES BE
DIFFICULT TO WADE INTO
COMPLICATED SUBJECTS AND THIS IS
CERTAINLY IS ONE BYTE- THIS IS
ALSO ONE OF THE MOST PERSISTENT
AND IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY
CHALLENGES FACING US HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- IT IS AN
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE TO RESOLVE.
AN ISSUE THAT WE ARE ALL HEARING
ABOUT IN OUR DISTRICT IN EVERY
CORNER OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THANK- PRINTERS
AND THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS FOR COMING TO THE
TABLE. I KNOW THE COMPROMISE IS
AN EASY. I KNOW THE
CONVERSATIONS AREN'T ALWAYS
EASY- BUT I WAS EXTREMELY MOVED
BY THE CONVERSATIONS THAT I HAD
WITH MY LOCAL CARPENTERS WHO
CAME TO MY OFFICE YESTERDAY.
BOTH ABOUT. HOW PASSIONATELY
THEY FEEL ABOUT LABOR STANDARDS
TO PROTECT WORKING PEOPLE. AND
SOME OF THEM SHAREDSTORIES
ABOUT FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE NON
UNION CARPENTERS WHO HAD BEEN.
INJURED AND THEN AND ABUSED AND
ABSOLUTELY- EXPLOITED. AND HOW
PASSIONATELY THEY FELT ABOUT THE
LABOR STANDARDS INCLUDED IN THIS
BILL- AND ALSO ABOUT THE HOUSING
CRISIS. I TALKED TO FOLKS WHO
GREW UP IN MY COMMUNITY. WHO CAN
NO LONGER AFFORD TO LIVE THERE.
BECAUSE WE HAVE AN OUT OF
CONTROL HOUSING CRISIS THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO GREW UP IN MY
COMMUNITY. WHO WANT TO CONTINUE
TO LIVE IN MY COMMUNITY. AND YOU
CAN NO LONGER AFFORD TO DO SO.
AND I REALLY REALLY HOPE. THAT
CONVERSATIONS WILL CONTINUE-
FROM MY VANTAGE POINT A LITTLE
BIT BACK. I THINK IF WE ZOOM OUT
THERE IS A REAL OPPORTUNITY HERE
FOR A WIN WIN. RIGHT WE CAN
CREATE. GOOD PAYING UNION JOBS
WITH. LABOR PROTECTIONS. THAT
DESPERATELY NEED. AND WE CAN
ALSO MAKE REAL PROGRESS ON OUR
HOUSING CRISIS AND I. WAS
ENCOURAGED TO HEAR SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT THERE IS MORE
OPPORTUNITY MORE ROOM FOR
CONVERSATION I KNOW WE HAVE-
WONDERFUL PEOPLE AT ALL SIDES OF
THE TABLE- PEOPLE WHO CARE ABOUT
THESE ISSUES DEEPLY WHO CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT PROTECTING WORKERS
IN ALL TO CARE ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY. AND I'M REALLY
REALLY HOPEFUL THAT WITH YOU YOU
CONVERSATIONS. WE CAN GET TO THE
PLACE WE NEED TO BE BECAUSE- WE
HAVE TO WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. IT THIS IS THIS IS THE
MOST PERSISTENT. THANK ALSO.
FACED IT'S NOT AN WE CAN WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO MAKE TO NOT
MAKE PROGRESS ON THIS ISSUE
TODAY IT IS TIME FOR EVERYBODY
TO FIND A WAY TO GET TO YES I
WANT TO AGAIN APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR- AND THE STAKEHOLDERS FOR
STARTING THIS CONVERSATION I
KNOW THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
MORE CONVERSATIONS- BUT I AM
VERY ENTHUSIASTICALLY GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND I'M
REALLY REALLY HOPEFUL THAT
EVERYBODY'S GONNA FIND  WAY TO
GET TO YES BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. OUR WORKERS ARE
RESIDENTS PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING
CRUSHED BY AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
THAT'S WHAT THEY DESERVE AND SO
WITH THAT I LOOK FOR TO VOTING
FOR THE BILL THANK YOU MISTER
YOU. THANK YOU. CHAIR AND I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AS WELL FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
HOUSING HOMELESSNESS THE BIGGEST
ISSUE THAT WE FACE AND ALSO.
MISTER GRAYSON FOR BEING HERE AS
A AS A JOINT AUTHORS. AND REALLY
TO BOTH THE SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT EVERYONE IS AT
THE TABLE. I'M PART OF THE
HOUSING WORKING GROUP THAT TOOK
A TOUR ACROSS. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IT JUST.
CONTINUES TO BE THE- ISSUE. OF
THAT BASE AFFORDABILITY. EVEN
FOR WORKERS EVEN FOR THE FOLKS
ACTUALLY BUILDING THE HOMES
AFFORDABILITY IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IS A PRIORITY IN A
SHOULD BE A PART OF THE
CONVERSATION ESPECIALLY. AS WE
MANAGED TO DEAL WITH ISSUES
RELATED TO CLIMATE CHANGE
CHANNEL SO MANY FOLKS. I LIVE IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES I
REPRESENT THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. FOLKS ARE MOVING OUT
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT BUT
YET AS LOS ANGELES CONTINUES TO
BUILD. FOLKS ARE MOVING OUT AND
THEN HAVING TO DRIVE IN TWO
HOURS TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS WORK
EVEN IF IT IS. LOCAL HIGHER. AND
SO IT'S ALL CONNECTED. BUT GEN.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO HEAR. MORE
ABOUT THE IMPACT TO MECHANICAL.
A CONSTRUCTION WORK FORCE AND IF
IT'S OKAY I'D LIKE TO MAYBE HEAR
FROM MR WATCH WHO I SEE IN THE
AUDIENCE. TO SHARE US
SPECIFICALLY. HOW THE MECHANICAL
TRADES ARE IMPACTED- AND HIS
POSITION ON THE BILL. OKAY SIR
CAN YOU. SUM IT UP IN. A
REASONABLE AMOUNT OF TIME. I'LL
DO MY BEST THANK YOU- SCOTT
WHAT'S YOUR BEHALF THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PATRIOTS COUNCIL THE WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL SHEET METAL
WORKERS COLLECTIVELY
REPRESENTING ABOUT A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA. PRISON
THEM FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS PRIOR
TO THAT I SERVED AS A PRINCIPAL
CONSULTANT TO THE SENATE HOUSING
COMMITTEE SO I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN HOUSING IN THIS BUILDING FOR
QUITE SOME TIME- OUR UNIONS
ABSOLUTELY RESPECT. THE PASSION
THAT THE TWO AUTHORS HAVE
BROUGHT TO THIS ISSUE. WE DON'T
DOUBT. I DON'T DOUBT IN MY
CLAYSTONE QUESTION THEIR
SINCERITY. IN WANTING TO ADDRESS
THE WORKFORCE ISSUES. BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO SAME
TIME FOR THE COMMITTEE TO
UNDERSTAND WHY ALL THOSE WORKERS
MANY OF WHICH ARE MY MEMBERS WHO
CALLED IN OR APPEARED TODAY FELT
SO PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
THE PROBLEM WITH BY RIGHT. IS
THAT IT TAKES AWAY THE MOST
FUNDAMENTAL DEMOCRATIC PRINCIPLE
FOR WHICH THIS COUNTRY IN THIS
LEGISLATURE WERE FOUNDED WHICH
IS THE RIGHT FOR EVERY CITIZEN
UNION COMMUNITY GROUP
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS TO
SEEK INPUT TO PETITION THEIR
GOVERNMENT AND TO SEEK REDRESS
ON THEIR ISSUES B. THEM SMALLER
BE THEY LARGE AND BY RIGHT
COMPLETELY SILENCES THAT VOICE.
IMAGINE IF WE HAD A PROCESS
WHEREBY. WE DEEM SOME ISSUE SO
SIGNIFICANT. THE WE DECIDED TO
BY PASS LEGISLATURE. AND WE JUST
SAID NO THE LEGISLATURE DOESN'T
GET A VOTE ON THIS IT'S TOO
IMPORTANT WE'LL JUST LET THE
GOVERNOR DECIDE. I THINK. THIS
INSTITUTION WOULD STAND UP AND
SCREAM. HAVING SAID THAT. WE
THINK THAT THIS IS AN ISSUE
WHERE. THERE CAN BE A MEETING OF
THE MINDS. THERE WE GET THE
RIGHT PEOPLE TO THE ROOM AND
HAVE- A MORE ROBUST DISCUSSION
AND PERHAPS. WAS ALLOWED WITH
THE INTRODUCTION OF THIS
PARTICULAR MEASURE. AND I THINK
THAT WE CAN GET TO A PLACE I'M
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN GET TO A
PLACE. SO MY HOPE ON BEHALF OF
MY CLIENTS WOULD BE THAT. IF
THIS BILL WERE TO MOVE OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY THAT IT
WERE TO GO TO- A PLACE WHERE WE
COULD HAVE THAT DISCUSSION
RATHER THAN YOU KNOW HAVING A
BACK UP AGAINST A WALL WITH
HAVING A BABY SCHEDULED IT
APPROPRIATIONS IN A WEEK AND
THEN ON TO THE FLOOR WORD THOSE
TYPES OF DISCUSSIONS BECOME MORE
TO- AND- YOU KNOW WE'VE WORKED
ON LOT OF TOUGH. WITH THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL IN THE
PAST AND WE'VE YOU KNOW WE'VE
GOTTEN TOO GOOD PLACE. A AND- IT
SO THAT'S WHAT THAT MY CLIENTS
WOULD HOPE WOULD HAPPEN TODAY-
BECAUSE THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE. BUT YOU CAN'T
UNDERESTIMATE. WHAT YOU'E DOING
WHEN YOU TAKE AWAY THE RIGHT.
FOR ALL THESE FOLKS TO BE ABLE
TO GO BEFORE THERE'S LOCAL CITY
COUNCIL. IT RAISES ISSUES AND-
HAVE THEIR VOICES HEARD. IN
WAGES IN OUR WAY WE IN WAGES AND
WAGE PACKAGES ARE NOT THE ONLY
ISSUE. THAT- WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN HAVE SO. I HOPE THAT YOU
QUESTINS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COOPER SIR. THANK YOU MISTER
WATSON THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OR
FOR THE INDULGENCE- BUT CHAIR
WORKS BASED ON. THE COMMENTS
MADE- AND IN PARTICULAR COMMENTS
MADE BY THE OPPOSITION AND IN
PARTICULAR- MISTER WHICH IT IS
IT DOES APPEAR THERE ARE. SOME
WILLINGNESS TO BE ABLE TO COME
TO THE TABLE FOR SOME SOLUTIONS-
CURIOUS IF WITH THAT YOU WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THE BILL
TO MOVE THE BILL TO ROUTE TO
RULES COMMITTEE FOR ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS- I APPRECIATE THE
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS HERE MISS
CARILLO AND ALSO APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS BY MR WATCH IN TERMS OF
WHERE HIS. HIS UNION I AM-
WILLING TO MOVE THE BILL TO
RULES- TEMPORARILY THOUGH AND TO
ALLOW FOR MORE CONVERSATIONS
WITH OUR LABOR PARTNERS- WITH
MISTER WELCH WITH THE TRADES AND
OTHERS- ALONG WITH MY SPONSORS
OF COURSE- C. H. C. AND THE
CARPENTERS. IF WE CAN REACH A
COMPROMISE ON ON LABOR STANDARDS
I'M ALL ABOUT IT I WANT TO HAVE
MORE ENGAGE CONVERSATIONS BUT
I'LL SAY I'M ONLY GOING TO AGREE
TO THIS- IF MY BILL IS ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD IN THE TIME. IN THE
TIME LINE ALLOWED TO BE HEARD IN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE PRIOR
TO FISCAL COMMITTEE DEADLINE IN
THE BILL KEEPS MOVING FORWARD.
ON THE REGULAR CALENDAR AND GETS
OUT OF PRISON TIME TO GO OVER
THE SENATE. WITH THOSE
STIPULATIONS- I'M COMFORTABLE
WITH THE MOTION THAT YOU
SUGGESTED I WELCOME I'M
OPPOSITION INTO THE
CONVERSATION- IF WE MOVE THE
BILL IF IT PASSES OUT OF
COMMITTEE INTO ROLES- IN AN ACT
OF GOOD FAITH TO REALLY TRY TO
SEE IF WE CAN REACH SOME OTHER
COMPROMISE LANGUAGE HERE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT. THERE'S A LOT
WILLINGNESS TO COME TO THETABLE
COLLAB AND IMPORTANTLY TO SEEK
SOLUTIONS AND NOT JUST SAY NO NO
NO BUT ACTUALLY FIND A
RESOLUTION FOR THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE TO MAKE
THE MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL INTO
THE COMMITTEE OF RULES. OKAY SO
WHERE A MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL
INTO THE COMMITTEE RULES. SO
IT'S DO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
RULES. OKAY TO HAVE A SECOND. WE
HAVE A SECOND BY WARD RIGHT THIS
QUIRK-SILVA HE WONDERED COMMENT. THERE'S A LOT TO SAY AND WE'VE
HEARD A LOT AND- AS SO MANY OF
YOU KNOW THAT. ALL OF US WHO SIT
HERE ON HOUSING COMMITTEE I HAVE
SPENT HOURS LOOKING AT VARIOUS
PIECES OF LEGISLATION ALL WITH
THE HOPES TO TRY TO SOLVE THIS
HOUSING CRISIS. AND WE HAVE DONE
A LOT OF WORK IN THIS AREA BUT
WE STILL HAVEN'T MOVED FORWARD
ON THE GOAL TO GET PRODUCTION
AND THIS HAS ELUDED US- AND IT'S
NOT JUST CALIFORNIA TODAY ON NPR
THERE WAS A OF. A REPORT ABOUT
ACROSS. I'M ACTUALLY THE UNITED
STATES AND HOW MUCH ATTAINING A
SOME TYPE OF HOMEOWNERSHIP. IS
BECOMING. NOT THE AMERICAN DREAM
BECAUSE THERE HAVE NOT BEEN
ENOUGH UNITS BUILT THIS ISN'T
ONLY ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IT'S ALSO ABOUT THE MIDDLE CLASS
HOUSING AS WE KNOW THERE ARE
MANY PEOPLE READY TO MOVE FROM
UP RENTALS INTO. HOUSING AND
SOME WHO MOVED IN WITH THEIR
PARENTS DURING THE PANDEMIC NOW
HALF. THE READ THIS IS TO PUT A
DOWN PAYMENT BUT AT EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS EVEN WITH THOSE
RESOURCES THAT THEY MAY HAVE
SAVED THERE AREN'T THE UNITS
AVAILABLE. THIS JUST HAPPENED
TODAY THIS MORNING MY TO ON NINE
YEAR OLD SON- CALLED ANY WANTED
ADVICE- IT BECAUSE HE IS LOOKING
FOR A RENTAL. AND THERE WERE TWO
CHOICES BOTH FOR A TWO BEDROOM
AT THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED NOW IN
ORANGE COUNTY. AND HIS QUESTION
WAS YOU KNOW WHICH ONE DID I
THINK WOULD BE BETTER AND SO
THINGS LIKE PARKING THINGS LIKE
ACCESS TO PARKING ALL OF THESE
BUT THIS IS. ONE PERSON LOOK IN
WHAT WE WOULD HAVE SAID LAST
YEAR WAS A TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR UNIT. SO IN ONE YEAR
THOSE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
UNITS HAVE NOW GONE UP TO THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED IN SOME LOCATIONS-
BUT IT IS. KIND OF HEART
WRENCHING TO SEE A FRIEND FIGHT
BECAUSE THIS THE TRADES AND THE
CARPENTERS ARE OFTEN ON THE
SAME- TEAM AND I THINK THAT- BUT
MOVING THIS TO. RULES COULD GIVE
A LITTLE BIT OF TIME FOR PEOPLE
TO COME TO THE TABLE I WOULD SAY
THOUGH AND IN. MANY WAYS. PEOPLE
DON'T LIKE BY RIGHT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HATE BY RIGHT-
NIMBIS HATE BY RIGHT MANY PEOPLE
HATE BY RIGHT BUT WHY WOULD THE
STATE TAKE THIS STEP IS THE
QUESTION WHY WOULD THERE BE A
BILL TO PUSH HOUSING TO A POINT
WHERE IT IS AT BY RIGHT AND IT
SIMPLY BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
BUILDING WE HAVE NOT BEEN
BUILDING AND THERE HAVE BEEN
MANY MANY MANY MANY PRODUCTION
BILLS THAT GET STUCK EVEN IF
THEY GET OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND THEY GET OFF THE FLOOR. THEY
GET KILLED IN APPROPRIATIONS AND
IT'S HAPPENED OVER AD OVER AND
OVER SO WHEN SOME OF OUR FRIENDS
WHETHER IT BE FROM THE TRADES OR
IN CARPENTERS SAY YOU KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON WE HAVE BEEN
PUSHED TO SAY YES SOMETIMES TWO
BILLS THAT WOULD PUT US IN A
FRIEND FIGHT AND I BELIEVE ME
IT'S THE LAST THING WE WANT TO
OR I SHOULD SPEAK FOR MYSELF
WANT TO DO IS TO BE IN THE
MIDDLE- A FIGHT. WE KNOW WHAT
THE STAKES ARE WE KNOW WHAT THEY
ARE TO US PERSONALLY BUT I
CANNOT STAND BY AND NOT SAY YES
TO HOUSING PRODUCTION FOR ME
IT'S A MORAL DECISION WHEN WE
SEE AND PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION WHICH IS
TO CONNECT HOMELESSNESS TO
HOUSING. IT THERE IS A DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP TO HOMELESSNESS AND
HOUSING AND FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO
DON'T WANT TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION I'M SORRY BUT THE
TRUTH IS THAT IF WE DON'T HAVE
PLACES FOR PEOPLE TO MOVE INTO
FOR THAT ARE ON THE STREETS.
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
WHICH MEANS HOUSING PRODUCTION
THEY'RE GOING TO STAY THERE WE
CANNOT HAVE PEOPLE LIVING THREE
AND FOUR YEARS IN SHELTERS. AND
THAT'S WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING
THOSE SHELTERS WERE BUILT FOR
SIX MONTHS MAYBE A YEAR NOW WE
HAVE NO PLACE TO MOVE THEM SO. I
WANT TO SEE MORE PROGRESS WITH
THE TRADES IN THE CALL CENTER SO
I WILL SUPPORT AND INITIATIVE I
PRAY LITERALLY PRAY- THAT SOME
PROGRESS CAN BE MADE. IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS SO THAT WE COULD
HAVE A TEAM APPROACH HERE BUT
THE ULTIMATE GOAL IS WE HAVE TO
BUILD AND WE HAVE TO BUILD WITH
URGENCY AND WE HAVE TO BUILD.
FASTER BECAUSE WE CANNOT ALLOW
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE. THANK
YOU. MR WARD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS FOR WORKING SO HARD ON
BRINGING FORM- AND BRING
FORWARD- THE TEMPLATE MODEL I
THINK HERE FOR MAYBE HOW WE CAN
PROCEED FORWARD ON A NUMBER OF
HOUSING RELATED QUESTIONS NOW-
AND INTO THE FUTURE- LEVERS AT
ISSUES ASIDE I REALLY WANT TO
COMMEND YOU FOR FOCUSING ON
COMMERCIAL OFFICE UP PARKING AND
OTHER UNDER UTILIZED SPACES THAT
WE KNOW ARE TRANSFORMING NOW
LITERALLY IN THIS DECADE IN THIS
MOMENT ON THAT WE NEED TO THINK
MORE CREATIVELY ABOUT HOW TO
OFFER DENSITY OUR- THESE IN
PLACES THAT ARE PEOPLE ALREADY
ARE THAT THAT THE DEVELOPMENT
ALREADY IS AND HOW WE ARE.
REIMAGINING OUR ART AND OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS IN A CONSTRUCTIVE-WAY SO I THINK THIS IS A REALLY
GOOD PLACE I KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING HOLDS LEADERS TRY TO
TACKLE BEFORE AS WELL- BUT FROM
A PLANNING PERSPECTIVE I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR FOCUSING ON THAT
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO OFFER A
LARGE CAPACITY OF OPPORTUNITY
SITES ON THAT THAT REALLY WILL
CATALYZE A LOT OF HOUSING THAT
OF COURSE WE NEED IN FOR
FOCUSING AND TRACKING THIS ON
THE NEED FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AS WELL SO YOU KNOW WHAT DOES
STANDARDS AND OF COURSE THEN-
THE BEGINNINGS OF WORK TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE ELEVATING LABOR
STANDS AS WELL AS JUST
INCREDIBLY COMMENDABLE- FOR
BRINGING. TOGETHER THIS. ON ON
ALL. THIS TO THE POINT YOU KNOW.
I AGREE AND I WANT TO THANK
THOSE AT ALL. HAVE INCOME- TO
DATE FOR WRITTEN YOU KNOW BEING
ABLE TO ELEVATE PREVAILING WAGE
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS WANTED. FOR A
VERY LONG TIME- BECAUSE OUR
WORKERS DESERVE IT. AND BE ABLE
TO START TO PUT IN HEALTHCARE
AND- APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS
AND A LOT OF OTHER LABOR. NEEDS
THAT ARE IN HERE IS- YOU KNOW
LEAPS AND- NONE. LEAPS IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. I'M WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THAT RIGHT
AND YOUR DOUBLE BEING IN THE
DETAILS I AGREE WITH YOU CHAIR
WICKS- THAT. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS ISN'T I'M STUCK
SO HAPPY TO SUPPORT. IT GOING
FOR THE RULES AS WELL- BUT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY
IS ARE COMING TO THE TABLE THAT
THEY ARE WORKING ON THESE
ISSUES- BECAUSE- ANOTHER YEARS
DELAY IS NOT- ACCEPTABLE- MINE
YOU. HAVE IN HERE IF WE ARE.
ENTERING THIS **** FURTHER
NEGOTIATION AND CONVERSATIONS- I
DO HAVE A CONCERN WITH THE
SEPARABILITY CLAUSE. AND THAT IF
WE ARE. CONNECTING UP A LOT OF
THESE STANDARDS TOGETHER THIS
NEGOTIATION- I I'M DEEPLY-CONCERNED THAT- WHETHER IT'S
THROUGH HEALTH CARE OR THE NEED
TO HAVE A- STAND. ON SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT ARE BUILT IN HERE-
MONEY- SUBSEQUENTLY FALL OUT AND
NOT LEAVE SOMETHING. WHEN IT'S
IMPLEMENTED- THAT IS NOT
BENEFITING THE WORKERS- IT IT
UNDERCUTS THE NEGOTIATIONS THAT
WE ALL SINCERELY. TRYING TO
NEGOTIATE SO I HOPE THAT I CAN
GET ON THE TABLE AS YOU ARE
WORKING THROUGH THAT THE
TECHNICAL DETAIL MATTERS. THE
SECOND ISSUE FOR ME. THE
PROFESSION SO SCREENS THAT ARE
GOING INTO THE EVENTUAL
CONSTRUCTION OF THESE UNITS THAT
WE THINK ABOUT. YOU KNOW SOME OF
THOSE THAT REALLY REQUIRED YOU
JUST SKILLED THE SORT. THE
PROFESSIONAL- EXPERTISE TO BE
ABLE TO GET RIGHT WE DON'T WANT
TO DELIVER. HOUSING PRODUCT
THAT- IN THAT IS GOING TO. BE
PERFORMED BY SUBSTANDARD WORK ON
THAT MAKE SURE ESPECIALLY WHERE
HEALTH INS AND ESPECIALLY SAFETY
YOUR CONCERN. ON THAT FOR THE
EVENTUAL OWNERS TENANTS- BUT
THAT IS CONSIDERED AN OF COURSE-
FOR THE LEVER THAT IS PERFORMED
THAT THAT WORKER STANDARDS AS
WELL- ARE UPHELD SO THAT- PEOPLE
. ARE NOT PERFORMING IN- ON-
JOBSITES WITH SUBSTANDARD
CONDITIONS AS WELL. A LOT- YOU
KNOW ABOVE DETAILED WORK ON BUT
I THINK THAT YOU WILL HAVE A PUT
SO MUCH TOGETHER. AS AN AREA OF
FOCUS THAT IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR TREATMENT.
LET'S GET TO THAT AGREEMENT THIS
YEAR- AND I'M REALLY HAPPY TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS MOVING
FORWARD. THANK YOU. MISTER KALRA
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU MATT CHAIR- FOR ALL
YOUR WORK ON THIS LOOK YOU KNOW-
I A REPRESENTS SAN JOSE THE
CAPITAL SILICON VALLEY- IT. A
SUPER MILLIONAIRE IS AS SOMEONE
THAT HAS A NET WORTH WERE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS. SAN JOSE HAS
MORE SUPER MILLION HIGHER
DENSITIES MILLIONAIRES THAN ANY
OTHER PLACE IN THE WORLD. AND
YET IN THE WHAT ONE OF THE
WEALTHIEST CITIES ONE OF THE IN
THE WEALTHIEST REGION THE
WEALTHIEST STATE. THE WEALTHIEST
NATION ON EARTH THERE ARE
THOUSANDS LIVING ON THE STREETS-
THERE ARE MANY MORE THOUSANDS.
THERE ARE VERGE OF. BEING
DISPLAY- THE THEIR HOME. LOSING
THEIR APART. JUST JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO. AND THREE OF THREE
WEEKS AGO OR SO. I WAS WALKING
AROUND- THIS LARGE OTHERWISE OF
WHAT USED TO BE AN EMPTY LOT
HUGE FIELD NEAR THE AIRPORT THE
NOW HAS HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
LIVING THERE- IN THEIR CARS AND
RV'S. AND THE REALITY IS THAT
INACTION IS NOT AN DIFFERENCE IS
CRUELTY- THAT BEING SAID. WE
ALSO HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S
A CIRCULAR ISSUE. THAT WHEN
WORKERS ARE TREATED WELL THEY
ARE NOT PAID WELL WHEN THERE'S A
WAGE THEFT WHEN- THEIR
SUBSTANDARD WORKING CONDITIONS
DOES THE SAME WORKERS- THAT
SUFFER FROM LACK OF HOUSING THAT
SUFFER FROM A LACK OF
AFFORDABILITY. THE SILICON
VALLEY- IS A IS A AS GOOD OF AN
EXAMPLE OR AS BAD OF AN EXAMPLE
OF THERE'S DEFINITELY A GOOD
THING. AS ANYWHERE ELSE. AND BUT
YOU SEE WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE.
WRONG LABOR STANDARDS IS WHAT
YOU SEE IS ALEVE WHEN SHE WAS
THAT WAS WHAT WAS HAPPENING WITH
THE SILVERY TOWERS WHICH
NICKNAME SLAVERY TOWERS WHERE
DEVELOPERS ARE SEEN THE
DEVELOPERS THE MILLIONS OF
SUBJECTS SUBSIDIES WERE YET THE
WORKERS THEY FOUND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SLAVE LABOR WORKERS
WERE KEPT CAPTIVE IN WAREHOUSES
. YOU FIND- THE ONE SOUTH PARK
PRO CUTS IF YOU DOLLARS TAXPAYER
. IF THERE'S ANY ANALYST.
ATTEMPT YOU TO SHOW CONSTRUCTION
BECAUSE THEY WENT TURN SUB
STANDARD LAID- ALMOST HOUSING
FOR. WITH PROJECT TURNKEY I WAS
ACTUALLY THERE HOME WITH AND- IT
WAS OPEN THE GOVERNOR WAS THERE
. MAYOR AND OTHER DIGNITARIES
FIND OUT LATER. THAT ALTHOUGH IT
WAS A PROJECT LED MILLION
DOLLARS A STATE AND CITY
FUNDING. THAT HAZARDOUS
CONDITIONS ARE MET PAGE STUFF
THERE BECAUSE THERE WASN'T
ENOUGH ACCOUNTABILITY. OF ALL IS
HAPPENING ON THAT SIDE. AND SO-
I MENTION ALL THIS BECAUSE I
WANT EVERYONE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT. THAT THESE ARE. NOT
COMPETING INTERESTS- THESE ARE
MORAL ISSUES THAT ARE OF EQUAL
IMPORTANCE AND SHOULD BE OF
EQUAL IMPORTANCE TO EVERYONE.
ABOUT HAVING HOUSING HAVE HAVING
PEOPLE WITH THE DIGNITY OF
HOUSING HAVING PEOPLE THE
DIGNITY OF- OF WORK AND WORKER
PROTECTIONS IN THE END OF A
LIVING WAGE AND. AND THAT WHEN
JURISDICTIONS SPECIALLY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS I DON'T CARE AS
MUCH ABOUT THAT- THE BY PRODUCT
IS- LABOR TRAFFICKING THE BY
PRODUCT IS SUB STANDARD
CONSTRUCTION. AND SO- I BELIEVE
THAT WE NEED TO FIND. A WAY. TO
RECOGNIZE OUR COMMONALITIES ARE
THE THINGS THAT WE CARRY ON AND
FIND A WAY- THE TO THE BEST
EXTENT POSSIBLE- UP TO FORTY
COME TOGETHER ON THOSE AREAS
WHERE- THERE'S- BEEN
DISAGREEMENT. I DON'T CARE HOW
LONG THE DISAGREEMENTS BEEN
THERE- I THINK THAT IT'S OUR
OBLIGATION TO TRY TO RESOLVE IT
RIGHT AND THE BEST WE CAN- AND
YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT IN TALKING
WITH SOME OF THE OPPOSITION AND-
CONCERNS WHETHER THERE'S ENOUGH
FOR THE STRONG ENOUGH
APPRENTICESHIP LANGUAGE OR
ACCOUNTABILITY STRUCTURE THEIR
SENSE. I AGREE WITH SOME OF THAT
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT IF WE JUST
GIVE UP LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MY
UNFORTUNATELY MY CITIES AN
EXAMPLE WHAT HAPPENS YOU JUST
LEAVE IT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THAT ARE JUST IN A MAD RUSH TO
BUILD. AND THEY GIVE ALL THESE
OF THIS MONEY AWAY TO DEVELOPERS
TO BUILD- AND THE END RESULT IS
ALWAYS PLEASANT IN FACT THAT'S
WHY DID A BILL WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES A FEW YEARS BACK TO
DEFINED MINIMUS TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE GETTING PUBLIC SUBSIDIES-
THAT THAT WE HAVE BETTER
STANDARDS AND PREVAILING WAGE
WHAT HAVE YOU- AND SO. YOU KNOW
. ALTHOUGH I HAVE OF STRUGGLED.
WITH THIS BECAUSE OF THOSE BOTH
NOBLE AND RIGHTEOUS COMPETING
INTERESTS. BUT WHAT I HAVEN'T
STRUGGLED WITH IS MY BELIEF. IN
THIS IS THIRTY THE AUTHOR- OF.
NOT ONLY UNDERSTANDING THE
URGENCY. OF OUR- OUR HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY AND HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS THAT- BUT I WITH A
BECAUSE I USED TO SAY OURS ABOUT
THE MOST IN THE BAY AREA BUT
REALLY IT'S NOT EVERYWHERE IN
OUR STATE- MAYBE SOME DEGREES.
BUT I THINK YOU CAN. BUT
EVERYWHERE. I'M. AND I'M
ENCOURAGED BY CONVERSATIONS THAT
THAT HAVE BEEN HAPPENING OF
LATE- WHETHER THERE OF LATE OR
OR NOT THEY'RE HAPPENING- AND
THE OF A REFERRAL TO RULES TO
GET THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT
CONTINUED- MEANINGFUL UP A
DIALOGUE AND CONVERSATION
BECAUSE THAT'S SOMETHING WE
HAVEN'T HAD ENOUGH OF THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS- ON THESE ISSUES
BUT PUTS A LOT OF US IN
DIFFICULT POSITIONS THAT YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT WHAT THAT THAT
UNDERSTAND THE URGENCY OF THE
HOUSING ISSUE WE ALSO UNDERSTAND
THE NEED TO STAND WITH OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS LABOR. AND
YOU KNOW I AM I AM COMMITTED TO
THE BEST IMPOSSIBLE FINDING THAT
PATH FOR BOTH AND SOMETIMES IT'S
NOT ACHIEVABLE WHEN YOU MATTER
HOW MY HEART BE TRY BUT WE HAVE
TO TRY HARD. AND WE HAD A BIT
AND I HAS TO TRY BECAUSE- PEOPLE
ARE SUFFERING. IT AND I SEE IT
EVERY DAY- IN A PLACE WHERE THAT
SHOULDN'T BE HAPPENING. IN
CALIFORNIA WE SHOULDN'T HAVE THE
SUFFERING- IN CALIFORNIA WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE WORKERS WORKING
IN NEAR LIKE SLAVE CONDITIONS IN
CALIFORNIA WE SHOULD HAVE WASTE
AFTER THEY APPRECIATE THE WAGE
THEFT- COMPONENTS OF THIS- AND
AGAIN ABOUT HOW TOUGH THE
COMPONENTS ARE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY ASPECTS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL NEED TO BE EQUALLY
AS STRONG AND SO THESE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT I BELIEVE. CAN BE
WORKED OUT WHETHER THEY WILL BE
WORKED OUT OR NOT IS UP TO ALL
OF US- IT IT'S UP TO ALL OF US
SINCERELY WANTING TO FIND A
SOLUTION AND UNDERSTANDING THAT
WHILE WE DELAY- THERE'S A LOT OF
SUFFERING THAT'S HAPPENING AND
I'M NOT THE ONE THAT'S GOING TO
THAT SUFFERING BUT I FEEL IT-
BECAUSE THESE ARE PEOPLE I CARE
ABOUT MY COMMUNITY. MANY OF WHOM
I KNOW- THAT THAT ARE SUFFERING
THROUGH THIS AND SO I JUST
IMPLORE AND I PRAY THAT- ALL OF
US GOING TO DO WHATEVER I CAN TO
COME TO THE TABLE TO WHATEVER
EXTENT I CAN BE HELPFUL- TO HELP
US GET THERE. BUT I DO
APPRECIATE- OF THE AUTHOR AND I
APPRECIATE THE BUILDING TRADES
OTHER OPPOSITION THAT REACH OUT
AND HAVE. MADE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT THEY ALSO UNDERSTAND THE
URGENCY OF THE SITUATION BUT-
THEY HAVE A VERY SINCERE- UP.
DESIRE TO REPRESENT THEIR
INTERESTS I THINK THEIR THEIR-
THEIR THEIR OPPOSITION COMES
FROM A PLACE OF SINCERITY AS
WELL- AND I THINK THAT WHEN YOU
HAVE A BUNCH OF SINCERE PEOPLE
IN THE ROOM. THAT THAT THAT WANT
TO FIND A PLACE OF COMMON
GROUND. I THINK IT'S ACHIEVABLE
AND SO- I HOPE WE CAN GET THERE-
I'LL BE SUPPORTING. THE BILL
TODAY- AND I HOPE TO DO SO IN
THE FUTURE BECAUSE THAT MEANS
THAT THERE'S BEEN PROGRESS AND I
HOPE THAT WE CAN ALL. GET THERE
SO THANK YOU ALL. SO I HAVE A
FEW COMMENTS BEFORE WE GO BACK
TO THE AUTHOR- YOU KNOW I COME
FROM A DISTRICT IT HAS NEWER
COMMUNITIES- COMMUNITIES BEEN
AROUND A LONG TIME AND ARE NOW.
EXPERIENCING THE GROWTH. THAT
OCCURRED IN ORANGE COUNTY AND
OVER IN L. A. COUNTY AND IN
THOSE AREAS- ONE OF THE-
PROBLEMS I SEE WITH OUR APPROACH
NOT NECESSARY JUST WITH THIS
BILL BUT OUR APPROACH IN GENERAL
IS THAT WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO
FIX AND FIND SOLUTIONS FOR THIS
CRISIS IN URBAN AREAS. AND URBAN
AREAS WERE BUILT A HUNDRED YEARS
AGO AND YES THERE ARE CHANGES
THAT NEED TO BE DONE AND THEY
DIDN'T ENJOY THE BENEFITS OR
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE PROCESS
OF CREATING GENERAL PLANS AND
HAVING ZONING AND ALL THESE
DIFFERENT THINGS- AND NOW THINGS
NEED TO CHANGE M. WHAT USED TO
WORK BACK THEN WHEN IT WAS ALL
INDUSTRIAL AND- PEOPLE WERE
BUILDING THINGS. NEEDS DO YOU
KNOW THOSE ARE SIT EMPTY AND
THOSE NEED TO GO OUT AND OUR
NEED IS HOUSING. AND SO WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT THOSE URBAN
AREAS. ARE THE ONES WHERE WE'RE
FOCUSINGSOME OF OUR A LOT OF
OUR EFFORTS ON. AND AT THE SAME
TIME NOT HAMPERING THE EFFORTS
OF SUBURBAN AREAS. TO INCREASE
AND GET THEIR HOUSING BUILT
BECAUSE A LOT OF THEM HAVE THE
PLANS FOR HOUSING BUT THEY'RE
RUNNING INTO OBSTACLES. THAT
CREATE- DELAYS IN TRYING TO GET
THESE ON THE GROUND- I WAS ON A
CITY COUNCIL THAT APPROVED A-
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- COMPLEX WITH
THE BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB AND EVEN
. FIVE YEARS AGO SIX YEARS AGO.
IT'S STILL GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS. IN THE PROCESS IS
SOMETHING THAT I DON'T HEAR US.
NECESSARILY YOU KNOW FOR ME IT'S
LIKE WE'RE CHANGING THE
WINDSHIELD WIPERS BECAUSE OUR
CAR WON'T START. IN THE PROCESS
ITSELF IT IS CREATING THESE
DELAYS THE CREATE THE COST. AND
FRANKLY I AGREE WITH EVERYBODY I
WOULD RATHER BE SPENDING A
LITTLE MORE MONEY. ON THE PEOPLE
THAT ACTUALLY DO THE WORK THEN I
WOULD FIND CARRYING COSTS
STUDIES THAT ARE REDUNDANT. AND
THESE DELAYS- THAT OUR OUR
AGENCIES AT ALL LEVELS STATE
LOCAL FEDERAL AND LOCAL ARE AND
I COUNTY. ALL ALL THOSE ALL HAVE
AGENCIES THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
THE PROCESS TO GET SOMETHING
THROUGH THIS THIS DEVELOPMENT I
WAS TALKING ABOUT. THEY WAITED
TWO YEARS TO TRY AND FIGURE OUT
. WITH EIGHT CD WHAT THE FUNDING
FOR THAT WE HAVE MONEY THAT
WE'VE MADE AVAILABLE TAKEN TWO
YEARS TO JUST GET THROUGH THAT
PROCESS. IN THE MEANWHILE COSTS
HAVE SKYROCKETED FOR MATERIALS
AND EVERYTHING ELSE WE HAVE A
LABOR SHORTAGE BECAUSE- WE WENT
FROM BUILDING A LOT OF HOMES
BACK IN THE SEVENTIES AND
EIGHTIES. TO CREATING A BUNCH OF
REGULATIONS TO SLOW THAT DOWN
WHAT WE SLOWED IT DOWN. AND AS
THAT SLOW SLOW PERIOD CAME
WORKERS WHO USED TO BUILD HOUSES
HAD TO GO SOMEWHERE ELSE HAD TO
FIND OTHER TYPES OF WORK TO GO
INTO. NOW WE HAVE A SHORTAGE OF
LABOR. AND WE HAVE TO TRY TO
CATCH UP BECAUSE WE CAN'T JUST
APPROVE EVERYTHING BECAUSE WE
DON'T EVEN HAVE ENOUGH FLAVORS
FOR THE FOR THAT TO HAPPEN. SO
THERE'S A LOT OF PROBLEMS THAT
WE NEED TO WORK ON AND YOU KNOW
I WOULD BE REALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
A LOT OF THESE EFFORTS. IF WE
WOULD TAKE THIS AREAS AND I
CONTINUE WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH
THEM AND THEN TAKE THE URBAN
AREAS AND CREATE THAT CHANGE FOR
THOSE AREAS CREATE THE
MECHANISMS TO CREATE THAT CHANGE
- RIGHT NOW IN. IN OUR AREAS WE
HAVE A LOT OF LAND THAT IS ZONED
. FOR HIGH DENSITY PROJECTS
WHICH INCLUDES THIS SO THEY HAVE
TO GO THROUGH ALL THAT PROCESS
TO DO THAT BUT WE'RE CREATING A
MECHANISM HERE WHERE THEY CAN GO
INTO THE COMMERCIAL AREA. AND
JUST BUILD BY RIGHT. WE SHOULD
DO BETWEEN THAT AND THE OTHER
WHERE IT'S RESIDENTIAL WORDS
DON'T FOR BECAUSE IN THE GENERAL
PLAN OF A COMMUNITY OF THESE NEW
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE GROWING.
ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE TAKING A
CONSIDERATION ALL OF THE REASONS
THAT WE HAVE YOUR OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE EFFORTS
THAT PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO DO. IN
IN OUR URBAN AREAS THE REASON
THEY'RE HAVING TO DO THAT IS
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T PLANNED OUT
VERY WELL. AND SO YEAH YOU HAVE
TIRE STORES NEXT TO A
RESIDENTIAL BUILDING AND SO WHAT
DID THEY GET TO LISTEN TO THEY
GET THE LISTEN TO. THE IMPACT
WRENCHES IN THE TIRES BEING
CHANGED IN CARVER YOU KNOW ALL
THE NOISE AND ALL THE ADVERSE
IMPACTS THAT COME FROM BEING
NEAR A STORE LIKE THAT. SO WE'VE
SEPARATED THOSE ALL OUT WE'VE
HAD TO DO IT WE HAD TO GO
THROUGH PROCESSES OF AIR TRAFFIC
SCHOOLS WATER RUN OFF HABITAT
ECONOMIC BALANCE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT BALLOTS. AND THE
JOBS AND HOUSING BALANCE. WE
WERE TOLD AS CITIES YOU CAN'T
JUST BUILD HOUSES YOU CAN'T JUST
BUILD COMMERCIAL YOU HAVE TO
BUILD A BALANCE OF THEM SO THAT
THE PEOPLE THAT MOVING THE
HOUSES HAVE A PLACE TO WORK.
WELL WE'RE TAKING THOSE OFF
LINE. THEY'VE GOT TO BE MADE UP
SOMEWHERE IN THE GOING TO BE
MADE UP IN THE NEXT GENERAL PLAN
BECAUSE THE NEXT JOURNAL PLAN.
IT HAS TO BE UPDATED EVERY FIVE
TO TEN YEARS HAS TO BE. IN
BALANCE WITH WHAT YOU'VE
CREATED. SO THEY'RE GONNA WIND
UP TAKING OTHER AREAS THAT ARE
MORE SUITABLE FOR THIS OUT. IN
THOSE SUBURBAN AREAS. SO IT'S
HARD FOR ME TO SUPPORT THIS NOT
NOT BECAUSE OF THE- THE ISSUES
WITH WITH THE LABOR ALTHOUGH I.
YOU KNOW I HOPE THEY CAN GET
THAT ALL IRONED OUT. BUT BECAUSE
I COULD SUPPORT SOMETHING THAT
WOULD CREATE ZONES WHERE THIS IS
THIS APPLIES AND IT WORKS. AND
IT'S USABLE. AND AND ALSO IF WE
START REFORMING THE PROCESS.
THAT HAS CREATED THIS CRISIS. IF
WE RECOGNIZE THAT. YOU KNOW WHAT
INSTEAD OF EXEMPTING THIS FROM
C. QUITE AND THAT FROM CIGNA AND
THEN THAT FROM SIKA. BUT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO TAXICABS. WE NEED
TO EVALUATE IT SO IT COMES INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH WITH WHAT WHAT
OUR NEEDS ARE TODAY. AND THERE
ARE TRADE OFFS TO BE MADE AND WE
DO AND WE ARE TRADING RIGHT NOW
WE'RE TRADING OFF THOSE PEOPLE
IN THE STREET THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. FOR A PROCESS THAT NEEDS
TO BE UPDATED DESPERATELY BUT
NOBODY WILL TOUCH. AND SO THAT
YOU KNOW THAT'S WHERE MY
FEELINGS ARE ON THIS IS YOU KNOW
I IT IS GREAT IDEAS GREAT
INTENTIONS IT'S NOT GONNA FIX
THE PROBLEM. AND UNTIL WE START
FIXING THE PROBLEM I RECOGNIZE
THAT. OUR PROCESS IS THE PROBLEM
LET'S ATTACK THAT. DAN ALL OF
THIS OTHER STUFF IS JUST IT'S
GOING TO BE ON THE BOOKS AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE THE SAME
PROBLEM IN TEN YEARS. WE WON'T
BE HERE BUT SOMEBODY ELSE WILL
BE GOING HEY WHAT THE HECK ARE
THOSE GUYS DOING. SO YOU KNOW I
WOULD I WOULD SAY WE NEED A LOT
MORE WORK ON THIS. SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE IT WORKABLE. FOR ALL
AREAS TO URBAN AREAS THE
SUBURBAN AREAS. LET THOSE PLACES
TO BUILD LIKE THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE BUILDING. AND REDO THE
URBAN REAS TO BE ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE WHAT THE NEED. SO WE
WON'T HAVE THOSE HOMELESS
PEOPLE. SO WE WILL HAVE HOUSING
FOR EVERYBODY- BUT UNTIL WITHOUT
SUPPLY CATCHES OF THE DEMAND THE
HOUSING CALIFORNIA IS NOT GOING
TO CHANGE. THE LAST THING I WANT
TO SAY IS- WHEN YOU'RE ACQUIRING
COMMERCIAL LAND THAT'S THREE
TIMES AS MUCH- ACQUISITION
COSTS. AS IT IS FOR RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY. JUST GO THROUGH
GENERAL PLANT PLAN PROCESS TRY
TO CHANGE SOMEBODY'S. THE LAND
FROM COMMERCIAL TO RESIDENTIAL
ZONING AND WATCHING SCREAM.
THAT'S BECAUSE THEY JUST LOST A
MILLION DOLLARS ON THE PROPERTY.
SO YOU KNOW THOSE ARE THINGS
THAT- WE ALSO HAVE TO CONSIDER
A- CONSIDER IN THESE COSTS FOR
DEVELOPMENT. I'D RATHER THOSE
COSTS BE SPENT ON ON THE PEOPLE
TO BUILD PLACES BUT WE'RE
SPENDING ALL THIS OTHER STUFF.
AND THEN. OUR OUR WORKERS ARE
CUT SHORT. SO I APPRECIATE YOU
ALLOWING ME TO- COMMENT ON IT. I
WILL BRING IT BACK TO YOU MISS
WICKS- FOR CLOSE. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR I WANNA- THANK THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES ON
THE DYESS AND GIVE YOU ALL MY
COMMITMENT. AND MY COMMITMENT TO
THE OPPOSITION AS WELL TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS-
HOPEFULLY A SOLUTION WE CAN ALL
AGREE TO- I'M COMMITTED TO THE
PROCESS- I WANT TO THANK THE
FOLKS WHO CAME OUT TO SPEAK OUT
IN SUPPORT THROUGH THE HALLWAYS
AND THE FOLKS WHO CAME OUT TO
SPEAK OUT IN OPPOSITION- AND I
DON'T DOUBT THE SINCERITY OR THE
PASSION OR THE BELIEFS BEHIND.
BOTH SIDES- WHAT I DO KNOW IS
THAT- WE HAVE A MORAL IMPERATIVE
TO TAKE ACTION IN THIS BODY AND
I RESPECTFULLY MISTER CHAIR
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS BOLD
AND IT DOES ADDRESS SOME OF THE
STRUCTURAL ISSUES THAT FACE. US
AS A STATE THAT FACE OUR HOUSING
POLICY AND I DO BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS A BILL THAT- AS I SAID
IN MY STATEMENT RISING TIDE
LIFTS ALL BOATS AND THAT WE HAVE
TO TACKLE THE WAGE THEFT. WE
HAVE TO PROVIDE YOU KNOW-
PREVAILING WAGE AND HEALTH CARE
AND A LOT OF OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
I THINK OR PORTANTINO I'M
SOMEONE WHO I CAME OUT OF THE
LABOR MOVEMENT I WORKED IN THE
LABOR MOVEMENT MOVEMENT. OF MY
VALUES ARE LABOR VALUES AND THAT
IS WHAT DRIVES ME IN THIS JOB
EVERY SINGLE DAY AND WHEN I SEE.
ENCAMPMENT AFTER ENCAMPMENT
AFTER ENCAMPMENT GROWING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AT OUR FREEWAY
UNDERPASSES ON OR OFF RAMPS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. CANNOT SIT
AROUND. AND DO NOTHING. I CANNOT
SIT AROUND AND SAY NOW I HAVE TO
SAY YES AND I HAVE TO WORK WITH
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO GET TO YES
AND I BELIEVE. MY COLLEAGUES
ARE. ON THAT PAGE I BELIEVE
TRUTHFULLY THE OPPOSITION WANTS
TO GET TO YES AS WELL. AND
OBVIOUSLY OUR SPONSORS SO I'M
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS. I LOOK FORWARD TO
MORE CONVERSATIONS I GIVE YOU MY
WORD IN ALL HONESTY AND
SINCERITY THAT. I WILL WORK WITH
OPPOSITION TO TRY TO FIND SOME
SENSE OF SOLUTION. I APPRECIATE
THE SUPPORT OF COMMENTS TODAY.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND ALSO WHEN I ALLOW MY JOINT
AUTHORS TO SAY ANY CLOSING
REMARKS. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- FIRST OF ALL
LET IT BE- STATED THAT ALL
CREDIT- SO CREDIT GOES TO THE
VERY HARD WORK OF CHAIR WICKS AS
AUTHOR OF TWENTY OPEN AS WELL AS
THOSE SPONSORS THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK TO- OUT
OF ALL THE MYRIAD OF HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA TWO OF THEM ARE AT
ISSUE ONE IS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT IS- THAT BENEFITS FROM
SUBSIDY. THEN THERE IS ANOTHER
TYPE OF HOUSING IT'S HOUSING
THAT'S AFFORDABLE AND THAT IS
THE MISSING MIDDLE MANY OF THE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO BELONG TO THE
UNION LABOR FAMILY IN THIS STATE
ARE CHALLENGED AND HAVE
DIFFICULT ACCESS ACCESSING
AFFORDABLE OR HOUSING THAT IS
AFFORDABLE AND IT'S TIME THAT WE
ADDRESS THOSE OBSTACLES IT'S
TIME THAT WE PAVE A PATHWAY
FORWARD TO PRODUCTION AND MAKING
IT POSSIBLE FOR THAT DREAM TO
OWN A HOME IN CALIFORNIA TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE AN AFFORDABLE
LIVING UNITS ASSESSABLE IN
CALIFORNIA. ONCE AGAIN SO WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
SHARE WICKS AUTHOR OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- OFTEN ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ELEVEN AND AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. VERY GOOD WITH THAT
WE DID HAVE A MOTION BY. MISS
MISS GODY- AND WE HAD A SECOND
BY WARD- AND THIS IS DUE PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON RULES- GO
AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL. WICKS I
WEEKS I'D SAY OCTOBER THEY ARE
NO CAREER. CAREER I GABRIEL.
APRIL I- KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
QUIRK-SILVA WARD WARD I READ
THAT BILL IS OUT I BELIEVE.
THAT'S OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT
FIVE TO ONE AND WE'RE GONNA
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS
TO ADD ON THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR ALL. DOING.
OKAY ONLY TWENTY TWO MORE BILLS
TEAM OKAY- WE HAVE THREE ITEMS
ON CONSENT TO THE MOTION TO MOVE
THE CONSENT AGENDA. WE HAVE A
MOTION TO SECONDS PLEASE
CALDERON- BILLS AND THEY CAN
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER CAN AB TWENTY
SIXTY EIGHT DO PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT- ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
TWO TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS. A WEEKS
FIVE WEEKS I SEYARTO SCARED
CORREO THREE WHITE. GABRIEL I
KALRA KALRA KILEY QUIRK-SILVA
WARD WHAT I. SIX ZERO THAT IS
OUT BUT LEAVE IT OPEN- LET'S ON
TO ITEM NUMBER TW MISTER REAVIS
CAN BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MANAGE AND SO THIS IS
IT SIXTY FIFTY FOUR. YES SIXTEEN
FIFTY FOUR. ALSO TO SEE
EVERYBODY THIS MORNING- AND
BEFORE WE BEGIN I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON ON THIS BILL AND I
WANT TO KNOW THAT I'LL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT THAT WAS
PROPOSED IN THE ANALYSIS. AND
THIS LEGISLATION IS ON THE BILL
A ONE SIX FIVE FOUR- SEEKS TO
HELP ELIMINATE OUR STATEWIDE
SHORTAGE OF PHARMACARE HOUSING
IN TWO IMPORTANT WAYS THE FIRST
IS LEGISLATION REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. TO
CONDUCT A FIRST OF ITS KIND
STATEWIDE ASSESSMENT OF FORMER
HOUSING NEEDS AND CONDITIONS AND
THEN DEVELOP A FORMAL HOUSING
STRATEGY. ON THOSE FINDINGS
UNFORTUNATELY- AS A STATE WE
CLEARLY LACK- YOU KNOW THE KIND
OF STATEWIDE DATA NEEDED TO
TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM. YEAH I
SHOULD NOTE A TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FARMWORKER HOUSING
STUDY IN ACTION PLAN- THAT WAS
CONDUCTED FOR THE SALINAS APOLLO
VALLEYS- WAS PUT AND WAS
PREPARED BY THE CALIFORNIA'S TWO
FOR REAL STUDIES IT ILLUSTRATED
A DIRE DIRE HOUSING SITUATION
HIGH RATES OF OVERCROWDING AND
HOMELESSNESS AMONGST OUR OUR OF.
AMONG FARMWORKERS THEIR FAMILIES
. AND SECOND SUCH SEEKS TO
PROVIDE A DEDICATED FUNDING
SOURCE FOR FORMER HOUSING YOU
KNOW BY SAID INSIDE AT LEAST 5%
OF ALL AFFORDABLE HOUSING TAX
CREDITS. FOR A FORMER HOUSING
FOR TEN YEARS. BOTH OF THESE
MEASURES ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT IN THIS BILL- AND THEY
WILL PUT OUR STATE ON A PATH TO
DO MUCH MUCH MORE. THAN WE HAVE
AS A STATE TO ADDRESS OUR FORMER
HOUSING SHORTAGE- ANY SURE
DECENT DECENT LIVING CONDITIONS
FOR THESE ESSENTIAL WORKERS.
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IS BRIAN
AUGUSTA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RULE ASSISTANCE-
FOUNDATION. ACTUALLY OF THE
CHAIR FOR HER- PARKER MISTER
EVANS GO FIRST AND THEN ALL NO
PROBLEM THESE CERTAINLY. THE
MORNING MY NAME IS PARKER I'M A
PROUD MANAGER WITH- MUTUAL
HOUSING CALIFORNIA WE'RE A
NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPER BASED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. AND ONE OF THE
REASONS I'M HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT THE BILLS BECAUSE MUTUAL
HOUSING IS ONE OF THE VERY FEW
DEVELOPERS IN THE STATE THAT CAN
SAY THAT WE HAVE ACTUALLY USED
THE STATE FARM WORKER TAX CREDIT
IN ITS CURRENT FORM- SURE YOU
GUYS HAVE ALL HEARD PLENTY OF
HORROR STORIES ABOUT HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CALIFORNIA
BOTH HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE AND
FROM THE DEVELOPERS IN YOUR
DISTRICT- BUT THIS PROJECT WAS
WAS REALLY A TREMENDOUS SUCCESS.
LET'S START WITH A CALL ABOUT A
SITE IN THE CITY OF WOODLAND AND
YOLO COUNTY- SMALL COMMUNITY
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE MINUTES
NORTHWEST OF HERE ABOUT THIS
SITE WE- SCOPE IT OUT TALK TO
SOME ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
MEMBERS AND TURNED OUT THEY WERE
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON THE SITE
SO HEY WE'RE OFF TO A REALLY
GREAT START. TO LAUGH. IT
DEPENDS START OFF MAKE IT BETTER
START THAN SOME ONE WAY TO IS
ONE WAY TO MOVE OF THE DOOR
CLOSES. I'LL TWO GRADES ON ON
THIS SITE SO WE TALK TO SOME
MORE LIKE THAT OFFICIALS MORE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS HEY WHAT KIND
OF- POPULATIONS ARE YOU LOOKING
TO SEARCH AND WE LEARNED THAT
THERE'S A HUGE NEED FOR
FARMWORKER HOUSING IN THE CITY
OF WOODLAND. FANTASTIC LET'S
BUILD A FARMER HOUSING. AND WE
ALWAYS START WITH THE LOCAL
RESOURCES FIRST BECAUSE THOSE
ARE ALMOST ALWAYS THE FIRST ONES
THAT NEED TO BE COMMITTED. AND
IMMEDIATELY WHEN WE RUN INTO THE
PROJECT THE PROBLEM THAT IS
INHERENT BUILDING FARM WORKER
HOUSING WHICH IS YOU'RE DEALING
WITH SMALL JURISDICTIONS. SMALL
CITIES THAT DON'T HAVE THE KIND
OF RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
TO US EVEN HERE IN SACRAMENTO
MUCH LESS WHAT'S AVAILABLE IN
THE BAY AND IN LOS ANGELES. NO
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT THE CITY
WOULD ONE DIDN'T HAVE ANY
RESOURCES THEY DID. THEY HAD AND
HOME ALLOCATION THEY HAD THEIR
CDBG ALLOCATION. EVEN HAD THE
FOR A HOUSING TRUST FUND WHICH
NOT ALL CITIES OF THEIR SIZE DO.
AND THEY- BASICALLY GAVE
EVERYTHING THAT THEY HAD TO THIS
PROJECT. BUT STILL NOWHERE NEAR
ENOUGH TO FILL THE GAP THAT THAT
THAT IT TAKES TO BUILD THIS
FARMER HOUSING PROJECT. SO WE
TURN TO- YOU STA. WHO SUPPORTS A
LOT FROM ACCOUNTING PROJECTS I
KNOW THERE ARE SOME COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HERE WHO ARE. INTERESTED
IN STREAMLINING PROCESSES IT T.
CACH INSIDE LIKE A CD AND I
WOULD LOVE IF YOU GUYS COULD GET
YOUR HANDS ON USDA. BUT WE- WE
ENDED UP GETTING AN ALLOCATION
FROM THEM. CLOSER STILL NOT
QUITE ENOUGH WHICH IS WHAT LED
US TO. GET REALLY FAMILIAR WITH
THE STATE FARM WORKER TAX
CREDIT. NOW THE STATE FARM OF
TAX CREDIT IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW IS A GRAND TOTAL OF FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
THAT'S NOT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH IS THE STATE TAX
CREDIT ALLOCATION THE BROADER
ONE PERFORMERS IT'S FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. WHICH IS ENOUGH TO GET
YOU MAYBE HALF A UNIT IN THE BAY
AREA EACH YEAR. IT'S NOT VERY.
MUCH- IN. IT'S SO SOME THAT YOU
CAN DOESN'T EVEN IT OUT OF YEAR
THEY HAVE TO WAIT FOR TO POOL
UP. AFTER LIKE FIVE YEARS FOR IT
TO GET TO A POINT WHERE IT'S
EVEN USABLE FOR A PROJECT- SO
FOR THIS PROJECT WE WERE.
FORTUNATE IN OUR TIMING AND WE
WERE COMPETITIVE ON OUR
APPLICATION AND WE WERE ABLE TO
RECEIVE AN AWARD OF FIVE YEARS
WORTH OF THIS STATE FARM WORKER
CREDIT. TWO AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS AND THAT HELPED CLOSE
THE GAP AND FUND THIS PROJECT.
GET A BILL YOU COULD NOT WRAP UP
COMMENTS PLEASE. YES THIS FIVE
HUNDRED THIS THIS UP THIS THIS
MOVEMENT OF. TO GET TO TWENTY
FIVE MILLION OF THE FORMER
HOUSING TAX CREDIT WOULD BE.
ABSOLUTELY TREMENDOUS. IT WILL
ENABLE US TO BUILD MORE
TREMENDOUS PROJECTS LIKE SPRING
LAKE- AND- I WOULD. REALLY
APPRECIATE IF YOU SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DISTRIBUTIVE BRINING US ON
BEHALF OF THEIR CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
THAT. CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
RAW HOUSING SPONSORS OF THE BILL
FOR ALL THE REASONS THAT THE
AUTHORED. MR HAVE JUST LAID OUT.
YOU KNOW. WE'RE GOING TO STUDY
THE- PROBLEM WE KNOW THERE IS A
SHORTAGE FOR FARMWORKERS BUT
WE'RE GONNA PUT SOME MORE
DETAILS ON THAT SO WE CAN CRAFT
SOME SOLUTIONS. AND IN THE
MEANTIME. FOR ALL THE REASONS
THAT MISTER EVANS WAS JUST
DESCRIBING. WE NEED MORE
RESOURCES THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
THAT. WE WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT. OF AB. FIFTY FOUR.
ANYONE SUPPORT. IF NOT WE CAN GO
AHEAD AND GO TO THE PHONE LINES
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB. SIXTEEN
FIFTY FOUR.
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN
ZEROED THIS TIME PRESS ONE ZERO
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE SPELL. WE HAVE AT LEAST
ONE KOLU SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT JUST A
MOMENT. GOING TO GO TO LINE
FORTY THREE. JACKYL BEEN GEHRY
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU LINE SEVENTY ONE.
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN EACH. THIS UNIQUELY GO WITH
POLICY WENT SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL
PERSON. LINE ONE OH EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN ALL THAT HI
ANTHONY ZELLER FROM LOS ANGELES
SINGLE FAMILY HOME OWNER IN THE
PORT. THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION ON FILE BUT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR. LET'S GO
AHEAD OF THE PHONE LINES ANYONE
ON THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. THERE IS NO ONE. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY COMMENTS OR
MOTIONS. I AM A MOTION. WAS
AMERICA APRIL SECONDED BY SOME
AWARD ANY OTHER COMMENTS. LET
THEM MOVE. SECOND OKAY.
QUESTIONS OKAY CENTER AWARD
THANK YOU MR- I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- I REMEMBER- I DON'T
TOUR THAT I'M HE HOSTED AND US
THINK THIS LENIS AREA WE HAD A
CHANCE TO REALLY DIVE INTO FARM
WORKER HOUSING AND I KNOW WHAT A
NECESSARY COMPONENT IS FOR OUR
TOTAL HOUSING NEEDS AND
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE- WHO- WHO
ARE FARMWORKERS AND DESPERATELY
NEED THIS IS A RESOURCE AS WELL-
I AS A GENERAL RULE OF THUMB I
HAVE VERY STRONG RESERVATIONS
ABOUT CARVE OUTS ESPECIALLY ON
EXISTING FUNDING STREAMS ARE
EXISTING PROGRAMS- THE PIE IS
LIMITED THAT IT IS RIGHT NOW WE
WANT TO BE EFFICIENT- WITHOUT
THAT PINE. I THINK AS A PIE
GROWS WE CAN SEE YOU KNOW MORE
OPPORTUNITIES THERE ARE TO BE
ABLE TO HELP AREAS OF
DEVELOPMENT OR FUNDING SOCIAL
PROGRAMS OR WHATEVER IT IS- IN A. MORE- CONCERTED WAY BUT- THAT
SAID I WANT TO BE SENSITIVE AND
I WANT I WANT I WANT TO BE IS AS
HELPFUL AS POSSIBLE TO THE NEED
FOR FARMWORKER HOUSING. DOESN'T
GET DIGGING INTO THIS IS THOUGH
I JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS. ONE IS- YOU KNOW ON
THE ANALYSIS OF THE COLLEGES
THAT- THE- SOME OF THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS- SPECIFICALLY UNDER. AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR- NOTED THAT.
TEN PERCENT- OF THESE PROGRAMS
NEED TO BE SET ASIDE FOR HOUSING
IN RURAL AREAS SO THIS IS
ALREADY. EXISTING LAW. HOW IS.
THIS BILL REQUIRING A 5% SET
ASIDE REALLY ADDING VALUE. SO AS
YOU KNOW APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
IN MISTER EVANS I THINK YOU KNOW
IF. IF YOU CAN ANSWER THEM
PROGRESS CERTAINLY- I THINK ONE
CRITICAL ASPECT IS THAT THE
CURRENT STRUCTURE OF THE FARM
FOR BILL THERE'S A PROVISION
THAT ALLOWS. 34% BASIS BOOSTS
WHAT'S ADDITIONAL EQUITY- THAT
WOULDN'T OTHERWISE BE AVAILABLE
UNDER THE LARGER FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION STATE TAX CREDIT. THE
30% BASIS BOOST- FOR PROJECTS
THAT AREN'T LOCATED IN. A
DIFFICULT TO DEVELOP AREA
QUALIFIED CENSUS TRACT- IT
PROVIDES SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL
EQUITY TO THESE PROJECTS THAT'S
NOT. PART OF THE SET ASIDE FOR
THE- FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OKAY. OKAY MAYBE I JUST
ONE MORE THING THAT MISTER WARD
IS I THINK THE 10% REFERENCE IN
THAT HOUSES WHICH WAS EXCELLENT.
WAS TRYING TO ILLUSTRATE HOW.
THE AUTHOR MAY HAVE COME 25% FOR
THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM THAT WE
HAVE. DIFFERENT AS YOU KNOW
SILENCE. FUNDING STREAMS SOME OF
WHICH CREATED A SET ASIDE THERE
COULD BE AS HIGH AS 10% IN RURAL
AREAS OKAY AND ON THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM WITH LIGHT
TECH- THE HISTORICAL SORT OF
SUCCESS OF THIS- IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ONLY TWO. HOUSING
PROJECTS RECEIVED BY TECH AWARDS
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN ONE RECEIVED
IT BUT THE RETURN THE CREDITS-
RETURNING- YOU KNOW THE SET AND
THEN YOU KNOW THE CURRENT SET
ASIDE IS THERE AT. AT FOUR POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS- MEANWHILE
THIS BILL WOULD- SUBJUGATE I
GUESS FUTURE ALLOCATIONS OR
FEATURE SET ASIDES FOR THREE
YEARS AND FINE YEARS BUT WE HAVE
SUCH A BROADER NEED RIGHT NOW.
IN THE PROJECTS ARE SHOVEL READY
AND READY TO GO AS MUCH AS I
WANT THAT TO BE PRIORITIZED. I
ALSO DON'T WANT TO HOLD IT
FUNDING BECAUSE AND IMPLEMENTED
LAW WAS SETTING ASIDE SOMETHING
ELSE THAT IT WAS READY TO GO.
AND I'M JUST TRYING TO RECONCILE
THIS. REMEMBER THE A QUESTION-
SO IF YOU TO ONE OUR PRE THAT I
THINK. THE PARTICULAR PROJECT WE
HAVE A VERY SMALL POOL TO
COMPARE THIS TO BECAUSE THAT
PARTICULAR PROJECT IS ONE OF
ONLY THREE THAT HAVE. RECEIVED
FUNDING IN RECENT. TIMES AND MY
UNDERSTANDING FROM TALKING TO
TEACH AXAPTA ABOUT THIS. RAN
INTO SOME PROBLEMS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND RELATED TO. THE VALUE
OF THE CREDITS OR ANYTHING THERE
SO- AND YES IMPORTER THOSE THOSE
MONIES CAME BACK AND WE HAD TO
BE REPROGRAMMED. BUT IN ALL BUT-
THAT'S NOT A TYPICAL I THINK
WHAT WERE- ONE PIECE OUR
CONTACTS AND I UNDERSTAND. AND
ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT
FOR STYLING MONEY AND LEAVING IT
THERE WHEN IT. IS ELSEWHERE. OR
WHAT WE'RE DOING IN PART IN THIS
BILL IS THAT THERE HAS BEEN FOR
A LONG TIME BEEN A FARMWORKER
CREDIT WHICH- IS. A VERY
VALUABLE FOR THE REASONS THAT
MISTER EVANS TALKED ABOUT AND.
AS WE'VE EXPANDED THE OVERALL
POOL. FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
HAVE NOT. CORRESPONDINGLY THAT
FARMER GRAD SO. WE'RE WE'RE LESS
CREATING SOMETHING NEW AS
IMPLEMENTING THAT POLICY MORE
FULLY AND I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES HAS BEEN THAT FOR.
DEVELOPERS AND MISTER EVANS
COULD ADDRESSES WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT A PROJECT AND YOU SEE
THAT THE CREDITS ARE ONLY GOING
TO BE AVAILABLE MAYBE EVERY
THREE YEARS WHEN THEY GET UP TO
THAT AMOUNT. YOU SORT OF START
PICKING DIFFERENT PROJECTS BUT
IF WE ARE ABLE TO PUT THIS MONEY
ASIDE HAVE IT BE ROBUST ENOUGH
UP TO TWENTY FIVE MILLION WE'RE
GOING TO SEE MORE UPTAKE AND
WE'RE GONNA GET BETTER PROJECTS
COMING THROUGH THE DOOR SO THAT
. ETHNOLOGY ALL YOUR CONCERNS I
THINK THAT IS. PART OF WHY WE
THINK THIS IS VERY VALUABLE
OKAY- THANK YOU I TRUST THAT
THAT THAT BACKGROUND AND
EXPERTISE AS WELL BECAUSE I WANT
THIS PROJECT TO BE SUCCESSFUL WE
DESPERATELY NEED THEM- HAPPY TO
GIVE IT A COURTESY VOTE TODAY AS
WELL- THE THING ONE. I THAT I
LIKE HERE A LOT IS THE
REQUIREMENT FREE CD TO WORK BY
TWENTY TWENTY SIX ON A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY. TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THE FARM WORKER
HOUSING SHORTAGE THAT WE HAVE AS
WELL. I'M GLAD THAT'S IN HERE
AND I HOPE IS THIS MOVES FORWARD
I'LL BE WATCHING IT WILL BE
TALKING TO OTHER. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- INTERESTS AS WELL
BECAUSE WE JUST DON'T. WE
HAVEN'T FUNDED LIKE TECH ENOUGH
MAYBE HAS MORE OPPORTUNITY IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET TO ALSO
INCREASE THE PINEY AND THEN THAT
ALLOWS AT THE FOR- ANY. ABILITY
FOR A SET ASIDE TO MAKE EVEN
MORE SENSE AND TEST THIS OUT I'M
NERVOUS ABOUT THE THREE YEAR
HOLD- WITHHOLDING- TO BE ABLE TO
RETURN IT. OR ANY UNUSED FUNDS
AS WELL. I'LL BE WATCHING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS BILL AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK
ON THIS MYSTERY THIS THANK YOU
KNOW AND YOU KNOW I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERNS AS WELL
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW. THEY'RE VERY
REAL AND I THINK IS BRIAN HAD
MENTIONED THE FIVE PERCENT- IS
INTENDED TO BE A FLOOR RIGHT-
BUT THEN ALSO. TO YOUR POINT
MAINTAINING FLEXIBILITY I WANNA
SAY THE LEGISLATION EXPRESSLY
ALLOWS THE LEGISLATURE- TO AMEND
ANY AMOUNT AFTER THIS THE- IS
DONE. SO THANK YOU SHORT. AND I
WAS JUST RESPECT ASK NOT ABOUT
TURNOUT QUESTIONS GREAT AND I
THAT WILL TAKE THAT AS YOUR
CLOSING- I'M SUPPORT OF THE BILL
I WANT TO SEE IT GET THROUGH
COMMITTEE TODAY WE OBVIOUSLY
NEED MORE- FARMWORKER HOUSING I
KNOW MYSTERY THIS YOU'VE BEEN
SUCH A LEADER IN THE SPACE
REALLY APPRECIATE RAFIC SENIOR
VOICE- WITH THAT WE CAN TAKE
ROLE. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS- WICKS FIVE. I
SEYARTO CARILLO. GABRIEL GABRIEL
I KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA I WARD
WAR DIE. FOR THE BILL IS OUT
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN THOUGH
FURTHER SAT ON AND WE CAN GO
INTO YOUR SECOND BILL AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY TWO THIRTY FOUR I
SHOULD NOTE ALSO MANAGER THAT I
WILL BE PRESENTING- SIXTEEN
NINETY FIVE FOR MR SANTIAGO-
GREAT OKAY.
TO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- AGAIN
IT'S LIKE I THINK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL ENOUGH THAT I'LL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AS
PROPOSED IN THE ANALYSIS IN THIS
BILL SENATE BILL TWO TWO THREE
FOUR A SEEKS TO CREATE STANDARDS
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO APPROVE
POST ENTITLEMENT RESIDENTIAL
BUILDING PERMITS. NOW THESE POST
ENTITLEMENT BUILDING PERMITS
INCLUDE EVERYTHING THAT IS
NECESSARY PRIOR TO AND DURING.
THE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
PROCESS THIS INCLUDES GRADING-
SOME DEMOLITION SPRINKLERS THREE
CLOSURES ADDRESS AT. TO BE CLEAR
THIS LEGISLATION ONLY AFFECTS
PERMITS THAT ARE ISSUED AFTER
AFTER A PROJECT HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCY AND AFTER ANY SEQUEL
REVIEW. YOU UNLIKE THE
PERMITTING THE PERMITS TO MINE
ACT AS WAS NOTED THE BILL
ANALYSIS WHICH REQUIRES PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO ACT FAIRLY AND
PROMPTLY ON APPLICATIONS FOR
DEVELOPMENT OPPOSE WILLS.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO
STANDARDIZED PROCESS FOR THE
APPROVAL OF HOMEBUILDING PERMITS
AS A RESULT THE ABILITY FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO RECEIVE
APPROVE AND EXECUTE HOMEBUILDING
PERMITS IN A TIMELY MATTER. VARY
FROM JURISDICTION TO
JURISDICTION AND IN SOME LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS MAY PROJECT BEEN
MONTHS OR EVEN YEARS WAITING FOR
THE APPROVAL AND EXECUTION OF
THESE BUILDING PERMITS- AND THIS
IS AFTER THE PROJECT ITSELF HAS
BEEN REVIEWED AND APPROVED.
THESE ADMINISTRATOR PERMITTING
DELAYS INCREASED PROJECT COSTS
AFFECT HOUSING AFFORDABILITY.
THEY SLOW OVERALL CRITICAL
HOUSING PRODUCTION PARTICULARLY-
AMID ARE WORSENING HOUSING
CRISIS. YOU KNOW AGAIN
ADMINISTRATIVE- THESE
ADMINISTRATIVE- SOME PERMITTING
DELAYS EXIST BECAUSE THERE ARE
NO CLEAR GUIDELINES OR STANDARDS
PROCESS AND SO THIS LEGISLATION
WOULD CREATE A PREDICTABLE AND
EFFICIENT PROCESS. FOR THE
APPROVAL AND EXECUTION OPPOSE
ENTITLEMENT PHASE HOMEBUILDING
PERMITS IN THREE WAYS FIRST
INFORMATION POSTING SECOND-
ESTABLISHING A DEEMED COMPLETE
TIME FRAME AND THIRD. BY- A
STAFF ASSIST OF REVIEW TIME
FRAME. YOU KNOW ALL THESE
PROVISIONS WILL GO A LONG WAY TO
REDUCE UNNECESSARY LOCAL
ADMINISTRATIVE DELAY WHEN
PROCESSING THESE PERSON TELL ME
HOMEBUILDING PERMITS- WITH US
HERE. THIS MORNING TO TESTIFY R.
CORY SMITH THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE HOUSING ACION COALITION.
AS WELL AS K. CONLEY ARCHITECT
AND PRINCIPAL- AT ARCHITECTS FOR
A WHO CAN ADDRESS A TACKLE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BILL THEY
SHOULD. SO GOOD MORNING I CHAIR
MEMBERS CORY SMITH ON BEHALF OF
THE HOUSING ACTION COALITION. WE
ARE A MEMBER SUPPORTED NONPROFIT
THAT ADVOCATES FOR BUILDING MORE
HOMES FOR RESIDENTS AT ALL
INCOME LEVELS AND WE'RE PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TWO
THREE FOUR. OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED
A NUMBER OF BILLS RELATED TO THE
ENTITLEMENT PROCESS WITH THE
HOPES THAT IT WOULDN'T INCREASE
HOUSING PRODUCTION AND
AFFORDABILITY ACROSS THE STATE.
HOWEVER I MEMBERS AND MANY OTHER
HOME BUILDERS ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE ALSO IDENTIFIED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE THE POST
ENTITLEMENT BUILDING PERMIT
ACQUISITION PROCESS. AB TWO TO
THREE FOUR WOULD CREATE A
FRAMEWORK FOR DEVELOPERS AND
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO PROCESS
RESIDENTIAL BUILDING PERMITS
MORE EFFICIENTLY AND COST
EFFECTIVELY. IN REALITY THERE
ARE NUMBER OF REASONS PERMITS TO
NOT GET REVIEWED IN A TIMELY
MANNER. FOR EXAMPLE MANY PROJECT
APPLICATIONS DO NOT SUPPORT
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT INFORMATION
THE CITY NEEDS TO ACCOMPLISH A
REVIEW. AND BY REQUIRING A
SIMPLE CHECK. CHECKS WILL NOTE
WHAT IS TO BE DONE. SOMETIMES IT
IS A STAFFING CAPACITY ISSUE AND
BY REQUIRING MODEL PERMITS
HIGHER QUALITY APPLICATIONS WILL
GET SUBMITTED. BECAUSE THE
PROJECT UNDERSTANDS HOW A CITY
WANTS TO RECEIVE THAT
INFORMATION. SOMETIMES AND THIS
IS WHERE. IT IS ACTUALLY A CITY
ACTING IN BAD FAITH IN TRYING TO
SLOW DOWN THE PRODUCTION OF NEW
HOUSING. REGARDLESS OF THE
REASON THE PERMITTING PROCESS
CAN UNNECESSARILY TAKE UP TO
THREE YEARS IN CERTAIN
SITUATIONS. AND CAN BE MONTHS
BEFORE AN APPLICATION IS EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGED BY LOCAL
JURISDICTION. BY REQUIRING
REASONABLE TIMELINES TO REVIEW
PROJECTS ARE NOT GOING TO WAIT
ENDLESSLY TO GET THEIR PERMITS
APPROVED. THIS BILL IS GOING TO
BE PARTICULARLY IMPACTFUL 41100%
SUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS AS MANY OF YOU KNOW.
FINANCING 1100% SUBSIDIZED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT AND DUE TO THE COMPLEX
TAX SYSTEM MANY PROJECTS FACE A
VERY TIGHT TIME FRAME TO ACQUIRE
PERMITS IN ORDER TO SECURE. WE
BELIEVE THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO CREATE A BETTER
PROCESS FOR PROJECT TEAMS CITIES
AND COMMUNITIES. SO WE CAN
HOPEFULLY SEE MORE HOUSING BUILT
ACROSS OUR STATE THANK YOU. AND
MADAM CHAIR- MISS CONNELLY IS
NOT HERE TO TESTIFY OKAY THANK
YOU AND WE WILL BRING IT HERE
INTO THE ROOM FOR. SUPPORT
POSITIONS NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION PLEASE. ONLY FOR MANY
TO HAS THIS OF LATE HAS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS HERE IN SUPPORT TODAY ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA CIVIC WELL IN SAND
HILL PROPERTY'S. AND ENSURE
MEMBERS DROPPING TO COVER ALL ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA ME IN
SUPPORT. GLOBAL ACTING WITH THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN SUPPORT. CHECK A VERY ON
BEHALF OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. EVEN DÍAS OF THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. MARCH
DIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT. THIS
DEBRA CARLTON THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
. NEVADA MERRIMAN MID PENN
HOUSING AND SUPPORT. ALLEN J.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT. I LEARNED EVELYN C.
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION WE'RE KIND
OF IN BETWEEN- POSITION BUT
REALLY APPRECIATE WORKING WITH
THE SPONSORS AND THE AUTHOR AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IS THAT IT HERE
IN THE ROOM FOR SUPPORT OKAY AND
WE WILL NOT MOVE OPERATOR TO THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU COULD OPEN
THE LINES OR PEOPLE DIALING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
FOUR NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION
PLACE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME PRESS ONE ZERO
. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FORTY SIX
. IT MAY BAN ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWO THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU. LINE. SEVENTY SIX- MEDICARE BOB
NAYLOR- REPRESENTING FEELS DEAD
AND KIND OF OWNED BY HOWARD
AHMANSON JUNIOR THEY PRO HOUSING
. ENTREPRENEUR THANK YOU. LINE.
FORTY THREE. I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER IN
SUPPORT. AND FOR THOSE ONCE
AGAIN YOU WISHED TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE AWAY.
IT'S NOT ME. FINE YES. RIGHT
THANK YOU ALBUM SCHALLERT ARE
LOST. ONE TIME READ IN THE
FAMILY HOME. AND BIG HOUSE
ADVOCATES IN. THANK YOU. LINE.
SEVENTY ONE SEVENTY SEVEN THE
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU FOR
HOUSING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
PARDON ME BUT JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE. WE'RE GETTING SOME KIND
OF NOISE ON THE PHONE LINE HERE
I'M NOT SURE WHERE IT'S COMING
FROM. ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO FINAL CALL. MADAM CHAIR
THERE WAS NO ONE ELSE PARDON ME
WE HAVE ONE PERSON LEFT. MINE
NINE. AND WE HAVE NO ONE LEFT TO
SPEAK. OKAY WE'LL BRING IT BACK
HERE- FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HE'LL HAVE A DAY
PRIMARY WITNESSES OPPOSITION. IF
YOU CAN COME SIT DOWN IF YOU
WANT ARE YOU OF A- IF IT'S JUST
YOU. YOUR FORM FOUR MINUTES THAT
OKAY. I'LL BE SURE THAN FOUR
MINUTES GOOD MORNING SURE WICKS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES TODAY REGRETTABLY
WITHIN OPPOSITION POSITION
REALLY TO CORE ISSUES WITH THIS
BILL THERE'S THE PROCESS AND
THEN THERE'S THE TECHNOLOGY
PROVISION SO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE PROCESS. WE APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
SO FAR WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
THE BILL HAS MOVED A LOT IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION I ALSO WANT TO
SAY TO THE SPONSORS I DO REALLY
APPRECIATE THE RECOGNITION THAT
SOMETIMES ABOUT THE QUALITY OF
THE APPLICATION IS THIS IS ABOUT
RESOURCE CONSTRAINTS OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IT'S NOT ABOUT
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ACTING IN
BAD FAITH AND SO WITH THAT SORT
OF RECOGNITION I THINK THAT
HELPS US HAVE A GOOD
CONVERSATION. ABOUT HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE THE PROCESS FOR
REVIEWING THESE I THINK ONE OF
THE ISSUES FOR US IS REALLY THE
EXPANSIVE NATURE OF WHAT THE
SUPPLIES TO YOU THIS ISN'T JUST
KIND OF THE THINGS GOING TO THE
PLANNING DEPARTMENT IT'S THE
OFFSITE IMPROVEMENTS IT'S OUR
PUBLIC WORKS DEPARTMENT IT COULD
BE YOUR FIRE DISTRICT UTILITY.
PROVIDER THAT- IS OWNED BY THE
COUNTY OR THE CITY AND SO WE
WANT TO HAVE REALLY CLEAR SORT
OF BRIGHT LINES ABOUT WHAT IS
INCLUDED I THINK THERE'S SOME
CONFUSION IN THE CURRENT TEXT OF
THE BILL AS WE POINTED OUT IN
OUR LETTER WHAT'S IN AND WHAT'S
OUT BUT WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THE OFF RAMP THAT WAS ADDED FOR
PARTICULARLY COMPLEX
APPLICATIONS THAT REALLY JUST
CAN'T BE REVIEWED IN THE TIME
FRAMES IN THE BILL. BUT WANT TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON TAT PIECE
ON THE TECHNOLOGY SIDE WE DO
HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS- WE'VE
CONSISTENTLY TOLD THE AUTHOR
THAT WOULD REALLY LIKE TO FOCUS
ON EITHER THE PROCESS OR THE
TECHNOLOGY BUT NOT BOTH WITHIN
ONE BILL THERE ARE REAL COST AND
AS THE ANALYSIS NOW NOTES THOSE
WON'T BE PAID BY THE STATE RIGHT
THIS IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE
PASSED ON TO APPLICANTS AND SO
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT OST.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE RECENT
HOUSING DATA STRATEGY REPORT
FROM EACH CD YOUR OWN
ADMINISTRATION IS TELLING YOU
THAT THIS IS A VERY COSTLY
UNDERTAKING TO MOVE TO AN
AUTOMATED ONLINE. ELECTRONIC
PERMITTING SYSTEM IS DOLLARS OF
AVERAGE. WHERE DO IT AND IT'S
NOT JUST THE COST OF. IT UP IT'S
THE- OF MAINTAINING IT LONG TERM
SO WE THINK THAT'S A SEPARATE
CONVERSATION WE THINK WE SHOULD
REALLY HAVE STATE RESOURCES ON
THE TABLE FOR THAT. GIVEN THE
FISCAL SITUATION THE STATE IS AS
COMPARED TO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SO. CONTINUE TO
HOPE THAT THAT PEACE CAN COME
OUT OF THE BILL AND WE CAN
CONTINUE TO HAVE A GOOD
CONVERSATION ABOUT IMPROVING THE
PROCESS. IN A REASONABLE WAY BUT
FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE POST
TODAY AND APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A MALL
TAKING HER TO THE FOLKS IN
OPPOSITION NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION YES THANK YOU MANAGER
MEMBERS JASON RILEY CALIFORNIA
CITIES WE CERTAINLY ECHO THE
CONCERNS EXPRESSED OF SUCCESS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR NUMBERS BRADY KERN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING OFFICIALS AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AN OPERATOR IF WE CAN
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES- FOR
FOLKS WHO WISH EXPRESSED
OPPOSITION TO AB. TWENTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
<c.red>MPOSITION PLEASE. IF YOU WISH</c>
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE
ENTERED TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
WE GO TO LINE FIFTY EIGHT.
RECALL LIVABLE CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE AT LEAST
ONE ADDITIONAL PERSON WHO SIGNAL
THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A MOMENT.
APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY JUST A
MOMENT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WE
APOLOGIZE FOR THE DELAY JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE.
WE'RE GOING TO GO NOW TO LINE
ONE FORTY NINE. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KIANA VALENTINE ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AT IN OPPOSITION THIS
MORNING THANK YOU. AND I'M SURE
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL NEVER GET BACK
TO COMMITTEE TOO MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES HAVE QUESTIONS FOR MR
REAVIS. AND WE HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY MYSTERY WRESTLE A CLOSE
REQUEST PRIVATE MIS MANAGER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY- I
APPRECIATE- HOW THIS BILL OF
CERTAINTY IN CLEAR AND CLEAR
TIME FRAMES ARE HOUSING PRICES.
HOUSING A PROCESS WOULD LOVE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IF IT
GETS OUT OF COMMITTEE- WITH THAT
YOU COULD TAKE THE ROLE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS
WEEKS FIVE WEEKS I SEYARTO
CARILLO. RIADY GABRIEL GABRIEL I
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE. KILEY
QUIRK-SILVA. OKAY AYE WARD. WART
BY. SITTING OKAY THE BILLS OUT
IT OPEN NOW- IF YOU PERCENT NOW
FOR MR FOR A. B. C. NINE FIVE IN
THE WE'LL GET TEMA PRIME THE
HAPPY TO SAW BEHALF OF- OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE MEMBER SENT-
ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE SIX NINE
FIVE- THE SIX INCLUDES THE
PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS AND EFFICIENT AND COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE ANY
NOTICE. OF FUNDING AVAILABILITY
ISSUED BY H. C. D. FOR
AFFORDABLE MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
LOAN AND GRANT PROGRAM TO STATE
THAT ADAPTIVE RE USE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS INELIGIBLE
ACTIVITY. ADAPTIVE RE USE IS
DEFINED AS THE RETROFITTING AND
REPURPOSE SCENE OF AN EXISTING
BUILDING TO CREATE NEW
RESIDENTIAL UNITS. THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPOSITION AND OTHERS WITH US
HERE. THIS WILL TESTIFY IS
AROUND MARTIN ON BEHALF OF ONE
OF THE SPONSORS THE AIDS HEALTH.
CARE FOUNDATION THANK YOU
MANAGER. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS RANDOM ARE NOT BEHALF OF
HF AND IT'S HEALTHY HOUSING
FOUNDATION. THE LAST FOUR YEARS
AHF IS EMBARKED ON A MAJOR
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXTREMELY AND
VERY LOW INCOME WE CURRENTLY
HAVE THIRTEEN PROJECTS ACROSS
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES WITH
ABOUT THIRTEEN HUNDRED UNIT. FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXTREMELY AND
VERY LOW INCOME WITH- WITH THE
RENTS FOR ABOUT- FOUR TO SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER MONTH. FOR
THOSE PERSONS. WE HAVE BEEN.
ADVOCATING THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
TO TRY AND MAKE ADAPTER FOR USE
A MORE PROMINENT PART OF THE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROCESS IN
CALIFORNIA- WE WERE SUCCESSFUL
IN. GETTING THE GOVERNOR WELL I
I'LL I'LL GIVE UP WITH THE
CREDIT ON THE GOVERNOR'S ON TO
ADD A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
HIS BUDGET PROPOSAL THIS YEAR-
FOR ADAPTIVE REUSE ACD WERE
HOPEFUL THAT THIS BILL WILL ALSO
CAST A BRIGHTER LIGHT. ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF ADAPTER FOR USE IN
TERMS OF DELIVERING MORE HOUSING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR. PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. WITHOUT FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU MUCH. GREAT NOT
TO BE- IT WOULDN'T. IN SUPPORT-
IN THE ROOM. THE ONE AT ON.
DIFFICULT TO THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. JERRY SMITH WITH A
HOUSING ACTION COALITION SUPPORT
GREAT. AND ANY OPERATOR IF YOU
COULD GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO AN
EXPRESS A SUPPORT FOR A BI
SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE. FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN JERIT THIS TIME
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WHEN I GO
TO LINE UP ONE OH EIGHT. BY
ALLISON SCHALLER CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES SINGLE FAMILY HOME
OWNER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE FIFTY EIGHT. RECALL
LEVEL CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
LINE ONE FORTY FIVE. NOT ONLY
DOES THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
ROUNDTABLE IN SUPPORT. THERE IS
ANOTHER TO SIGNAL BUT THAT YOU
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK HERE INTO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANY ONE
LIKE TO ADD ON IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. AND SIGNAL WITH NO
POSITION ON FILE RIGHT OTHER
REALTORS OKAY- AND- OPERATIVE
YOU KNOW OVER THE PHONE LINES
FOR ANYONE WISHING TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTEEN NINETY
FIVE NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO PRESS ONE ENTERED TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. NO ONE KNEW
SIGNALED THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU WILL BRING ABOUT HERE
TOO KELLY COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR. WE
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THE
MEMBER SANTIAGO RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I'VE- THE- HOBBIT IS FOR
THE BILL TODAY AND GIVE MR
SANTIAGO A CHANCE TO KEEP THE
BILL MOVING FORWARD WITH THAT
TAKE PLACE ACROSS MOTIONS TO
PASS- TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS WICKS FIVE. I
SEYARTO CARILLO. I GABRIEL
GABRIEL I KALRA. COLOR AYE KILEY
QUIRK-SILVA. QUIRK-SILVA AWARD.
WHAT NINE. THAT THAT SIX VOTES
THAT BILLS OUT WILL KEEP IT OPEN
AND WITH THAT MISTER PRIME
YOU'RE UP TO BAT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR GOOD
MORNING THIS RENT. TODAY I RISE
TO PRESENT A. B. SIXTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE WHICH IS SPONSORED BY THE
LOS ANGELES HOMELESS SERVICES
THIRTY HOUSING CALIFORNIA IN
MANY ON HOUSE PERSONS THIS BILL
AIMS TO REMOVE BARRIERS TO
EXITING HOMELESSNESS FOR PEOPLE
LIVING IN THEIR VEHICLES BY
INCREASING OPTIONS FOR TICKET
FORGIVENESS. IN L. A. COUNTY
ALONE OF THE SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESS ON
ANY GIVEN NIGHT NEARLY NINETEEN
THOUSAND OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE
LIVING IN VEHICLES FOR MANY THIS
VEHICLE IS THE LAST VESTIGE OF
STABILITY AND THE ONLY THING
KEEPING THEM FROM BEING DIRECTLY
ON THE SIDEWALK THEIR ONLY
PROTECTION FROM THE ELEMENTS.
AND IS THE ONLY PLACE THEY HAVE
TO SAFELY STORE THEIR BELONGINGS
VEHICLES ALSO A LIFELINE TO EXIT
HOMELESSNESS THE ABILITY OF THE
VEHICLE CAN HELP YOU GET A JOB
ACCESS HEALTH CARE ME WITH THE
CASE MANAGER. GOT A JOB.
INTERVIEWS AND APPLY FOR MUCH
NEEDED BENEFITS IN MANY OF OUR
NEIGHBORS LIVING IN THEIR
VEHICLES ARE AT RISK OF LOSING
THAT VEHICLE SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEIR PARKING TICKETS THEY
CANNOT AFFORD TO PAY IN SOME
CASES PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE SCRAPING MONEY
TOGETHER THE THEY COULD BE USING
TO GET HOUSE TO PAY THESE
TICKETS OFF OR TURNING TO
ILLICIT ACTIVITIES TO HELP THEM
PAY THOSE TICKETS. DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE THAT WE ARE PAYING FOR
PROGRAMS TO RE HOUSE PEOPLE ON
THE STREETS WITH ONE HAND AND
THEN. THEM FOR BEING. THE OTHER
HAND THIS BILL LOOKS TO BUILD ON
THE SUCCESS OF PROGRAMS IN
CITIES WERE TICKET FORGIVENESS
PROGRAMS ARE ALREADY WORKING TO
HELP ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTY FIVE WOULD ASK
ALL OF OUR CITIES TO CREATE
TICKET FORGIVENESS PROGRAMS FOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE GIVING
PEOPLE LIVING IN THEIR VEHICLES
A PATHWAY TO STABILITY. INSTEAD
OF PUSHING PEOPLE DEEPER INTO
CRISIS AND MAKING IT HARDER FOR
THEM TO BECOME HOUSE. BUT ALSO
LIKE TO MENTION THAT THIS
PROGRAM- IS NOT THE SAME AS LOST
REVENUE THE VAST MAJORITY OF ON
HOUSE PEOPLE FACING THESE FINES
DO NOT HAVE THE MONEY TO PAY
THEM. THERE'S NO RETURN ON
INVESTMENT FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FROM MUNICIPALITIES EVEN IF THEY
SEIZE AND SELL THE CARS IN FACT
IT COST THE GOVERNMENT. MORE
TRYING TO COLLECT THESE FINES
AND FEES THAN THEY ACTUALLY
RECEIVE. THIS IS HARM REDUCTION
COMPASSIONATE. IT'S GOOD
GOVERNANCE A. B. SIXTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE ALSO HAS A LIMIT IS FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN FINES.
ADDITIONALLY A. B. SIXTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE RELIES ON VERIFIED
ENROLLMENT IN EXISTING HOME
SERVICE PROGRAMS. MEANING THAT
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE THIS BENEFIT
YOU HAVE TO HAVE CONTACT WITH
THE HOMELESS SERVICE PROVIDER.
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WITH
ME- BY PHONE I HAVE AN ADVOCATE
FOR CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING SHAUN PLEASANTS AND KIET
DO PLAY ALSO LIVED EXPERIENCE
ADVISORY BOARD MEMBER FROM
LAWSON. THANK YOU PLEASE BEGIN.
TELL FOR OVER THE HOPESORRY
TELL THE OPERATOR PHONE LINE
PLEASE FOR A PRIMARY WITNESS.
AND IF YOU ARE WITNESS TODAY
YOUR PHONE LINE SHOULD BE OPEN
RIGHT NOW. OKAY OKAY THIS IS A
STRONG BUTTON THE INDEPENDENT
HOMELESSNESS THE ADVOCATE AND AS
SOMEONE WHO ARE EXPERIENCED
HOMES USED FOR OVER TEN YEARS IN
THE NBA BETWEEN JANUARY- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
ON ON THE MACHINE MY- ACTUAL
EXPERIENCES WITH WITH THIS
SITUATION- AFTER AFTER DEATH OF
MY MOTHER IN A FAILED BUSINESS I
ENDED UP- UNABLE TO. TO REPORT-
MY APARTMENT IN MY HOUSING AND
ENDED UP LIVING IN MY IN MY
VEHICLE- LITTLE BY LITTLE THEY
STARTED I STARTED GETTING WITH
RGB LIGHTING PARKING TICKETS-
WHICH- ENDED UP RUNNING UP TO
SIXTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS- AND I
MANAGED TO PAY IT OFF ONE TIME
BY THE- BONDS OF FAMILY AND
EXHAUSTED ALL MY OTHER BY ME
BUT- IT HAPPENED AGAIN- AND-
THIS TIME. I TO HANDICAP PLACARD
AND IT DIDN'T MATTER TICKETS
REGARDLESS I WAS EVEN TOLD BY
THE PARKING- I'M- IN SPACE WITH
WORD AGAINST THEIR WORD EVEN
THOUGH I HAD IT GOT KICKED THE
FRONT WINDSHIELD PERMANENTLY THE
MOBILE DIFFERENCE- ONCE BELIEVED
FONG CHAN UP AGAIN I'VE BEEN NO
LONGER FOR TO PAY FOR THE
REGISTRY. WILL THEN- WHEN I LOST
A VEHICLE. I LOST ALL MY
CLOTHING RECYCLE PICTURES I'D
MONEY THAT I'VE BEEN SAVING- ALL
MY MEDICINES NINE PORTANT PAPERS
GOING- BIRTH CERTIFICATE SOCIAL
SECURITY CARD YOU DON'T THINK OF
THAT NATURE. AND I LOST THE
ABILITY TO USE THE VALUE OF THE
VEHICLE- IT. FOR APARTMENT APART
TO GET A THE POCKET OF IT YOU
CAN USE THAT A WAY TO THE PLACE
TO LIVE- LIVING ON THE STREETS
AND- IT WAS THE- TOUGH. AND IT
IS A TRUCK THAT WOULD WITH THE
WAY I'M FIRST. FOR NIGHT
SLEEPING ON THIS ADDRESS I TAKE
. OF COURSE DO ONCE. WHICH I
JEFF MATTHEW THIS MAY BECAUSE
TOO BAD SEVENTEEN. I JUST
MANAGED DISMISSED THE THREE
MONTHS AGO WE CHECKED LAWYERS A
JUDGE. WHICH MAKES NO SENSE- BUT
BASICALLY THE OF MY VEHICLE
PROLONG MY THE TIME THAT I WAS
HOME. AND IT DEFINITELY ADDS TO
ALL THE GIVE THAT I IN IN AND
FINDING WHAT YOU HOW. AND SO I'M
DEFINITELY REDUCE BECAUSE OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE NOT. PRIMARY WITNESS HERE.
ALSO THE FOR TECHNIC WITNESS
FOR. ALSO ON THE PHONE OPERATIVE
YOU DON'T PHONE LINES OF A GREAT
THING YOU. GOOD MORNING- MY NAME
IS HERE BECAUSE- BUT JUST TO
SHOW- I STARTED HOMELESS AT THE
AGE OF FORTY. AND THE ULTIMATELY
TO THE TRAFFICKED FIFTEEN FROM
TEN YEARS OF MY LIFE I WOULD ON
AUTO PILOT TO SET. AND WHICH-
TRYING GIVE ALIVE- I LIVED IN
FEAR FIRST LONG BECAUSE I HAD
VIOLENT ABUSER- WHEN I WAS ABLE
TO GET OUT THE LIGHT AND STUFF
MY CHANGE. IN STABILITY STATES.
I OBSERVER. THAT THERE WAS SO
MANY. THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
FACE. I REMEMBER A TIME TO. WITH
THE MARK WHY IS THAT ALI DON'T
WORRY DAY- IT WOULD START. TO
THIS INTO THE NORTH SINCE. IS
THAT WHEN PEOPLE THINK THE I WAS
ONE HARD- NO HOME NO REAL JOB
NOT EVEN EXPERIENCE. HOW DO YOU
BUILD AND VIOLATIONS JUST
STARTED ADDING UP AND I DIDN'T
HAVE NO IDEA BECAUSE I WOULD BE. A BOUNCE AROUND BONTA
TRAFFICKERS. THE MORE I WOULD BE
TRAFFIC TO THE MORE TO GIVE THAT
GUY. THE MOST THE TIME I EVEN.
AND AS A SURPRISE. OUR CUTE COME
WITH INTEREST- SO I COULDN'T A
ROOM WHERE I WAS THAT. THE TELL
THE COURT. WHAT WHAT WAS GOING
FOR TO TRY TO. THE DISPUTE ANY
OF THE TICKET ALL I COULD SAY.
THAT HOMELESS AND I VERY BY. AND
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT OF TO DO. HOW
COULD I HOW COULD I HAVE MADE IT
TO COURT ON OWN- OR DO ANY.
PRINT PROTESTED I WAS BEING
AGAINST MY WILL. THEN I LOST MY
LICENSE AS A RESULT AND THE CARD
THAT IS THE CAR THAT I WAS IN
HELLO. IT WAS A REPORT OF ME
TRYING DO THE RIGHT THING AND
CHANGE MY- BUT LIKE I SAID A ONE
BARRIER AFTER ANOTHER- I DON'T
CHOOSE THAT LIFESTYLE. AND IT
NOT I CAN TAKE WERE FORGET IT I
WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO KEEP MY-
A NOT ONLY ADDS TEN. BUT AS THE
ROOF OVER MY- TRIED TO GET AND
GO TO GET A THE ARE GO SEE. TO
GET MY HEALTH IN ORDER- BECAUSE
CATCH THE BUS WAS. BUT ONE
MCCARTY FULL BACK THERE YOU'RE
JUST BECAME MORE. I WILL GROW UP
IN THE- OF MY CAR. IN PARK IN
THE- WHAT LIFE AND CHAIRMAN VIKA
GAS. OR SOMETHING- AND I WAS SO
FACED. AT LEAST THEY FOR NOW TO
SLEEP IN IT WAS MUCH BETTER THAN
. BEING A YOUNG FOR IN A PARK-
OR AT A BUS STOP. I CAN FIGURE
FORGIVENESS A GAME GIVEN ME A
WAY UP IN THIS WORLD. WHAT WE
KNOW NOW I'LL SHOW GET. FOR ROAD
REALLY FAST- AND NOT COULD. THE
FINAL BY AND I CAME. EVEN SO
THEY MY COLLEAGUES SAID LEAST
STILL FIGHTING- IF THIS BILL IS
PASSED IT WILL SURELY PEOPLE
LIKE ME- AND ELIMINATE. THE
BIGGEST. THING IS TRYING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. IN. FOR FIVE- I'M A
GOOD. AND PEOPLE JUST
AUTOMATICALLY ASSUME THAT I
WOULD BECAUSE I HAD A TRAFFICKER
AND I WAS IN PROSTITUTION BUT
THAT WASN'T THE LIFE THAT I
CHOSE IF I HAVE PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS GOING ON AND
HELP ME GET MY LICENSE BACK OR
HELP ME GET MY CAR BACK THERE
HELP ME GET RID OF THESE TICKETS
ULTIMATELY WOULD HAVE BEEN SO
MUCH MORE SUCCESSFUL THAN WHERE
I AM TODAY. ASSEMBLY HI NICK
BILL BECAUSE IT SURELY WOULD
CHANGE MY LIFE AND I KNOW HOW
MANY OF THESE GUYS THAT CAN
CHANGE. THANK YOU ARE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WANT TO THANK BOTH-
MISTER PLEASANTS AND MISS. DO DO
PROCLAIM ACTION PLANS TO YOUR
NAME CORRECTLY I REALLY
APPRECIATE. YOUR LIVED
EXPERIENCE IN YOUR STORIES HER I
THINK OFTEN TOO MANY TIMES- WE
DON'T HEAR THOSE HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE ROOM SO JUST
APPRECIATE THAT- WITH THAT WE
WILL BRING IT BACK HERE TO THE
ROOM AND IF FOLKS WANT TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR. MR BRAINS
BILL EIGHTY SIXTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE STEP UP- SAY NAME
ORGANIZATION AND SUPPORT. THE
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING JACK AVERY
WITH HOUSING CALIFORNIA WE'RE
PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND
RESPECTFULLY URGE OF I HAVE A
THANK YOU. SYNDICATES THE ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ALONG
POVERTY IN STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT
I RESERVE THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT. READ
MORE NUMBER HAVE THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION IS HOUSING
IS A HUMAN RIGHT DIVISION TO
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AN
OPERATOR WILL NOW BRING IT TO
THE PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES
FROM THE PUBLIC COULD LIKE TO
ADD ON FOR AB. SIXTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE IN SUPPORT NAME
ORGANIZATION AND- POSITION. FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE IN
SYRACUSE TIME TO GO TO LINE ONE
FIFTY FOUR. HI THERE THIS
STATELY WITH ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
WHERE YOU. LINE FIFTY FOUR. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS YOUR COURT TRIANGLE ON
BEHALF OF THE CONDEMN WHEN
TRICKS COUNCIL THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE
BERKELEY TENANTS UNION WE ARE IN
SRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. LINE ONE THIRTY NINE
. MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
MARK LOOKS TO MATCH AND I
CAMANCHE COUNTY I'M STRONG
SUPPORT ITSELF THANK YOU. LINE%
THIRTY SIX. AND BOOKBINDER
INDIVIDUALS SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU.
ONE ONE FIFTY NINE. HI THERE
THIS IS BUT THE FISH FROM STREET
FOR ALL TRANSPORTATION JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION IN L. A. COUNTY AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. LINE
ONE AWAY. HI ALLISON SCHALLERT
SINGLE FAMILY HOMEOWNER IN LOS
ANGELES AND STRONG SUPPORT. FIND. ONE FIFTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS THE EXTENT OF ALL WITH
PATH PEOPLE ASSISTING THE
HOMELESS IN INTO THE ATTIC
SUPPORT. BY. TWENTY NINE. TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JANE GENERALLY
HAVE THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. LINE. ONE
FORTY FOUR.
BY ONE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. WHEN TO MOVE ON TO
LINE THIRTY THREE. THANK. THIRTY
THREE. THEY GOT A LINE OF ONE OH
ONE. M. PARDON ME LINE ONE ZERO
ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. LINE
FIFTY EIGHT. RECALL CULTURAL
ACTION NETWORK IN SUPPORT. LINE. ONE FIFTY SEVEN. A DONALD
PAYNE CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES HOMELESS SERICES
AUTHORITY THEY'RE A CO FOUNDER
AND WORK SUPPORT SYSTEM. ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
SPEAK ABOUT THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. WE GO TO
LINE THIRTY THREE. LINE ONE
FORTY FOUR. BUT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. YEAH
KANE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY URBAN INSTITUTE
WE STAND STRONG SUPPORT. THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. GREAT WILL BRING
IT BACK HERE- TO THE COMMITTEE-
SORRY WILL BRING IT TO THE
OPPOSITION BUT WHEN IS REVENUE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
. ANY FOLKS IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER A
POSITION. OPERATOR ANYONE THE
PHONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION AB. SIXTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE. WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE
CALLER WHO WISHES TO SPEAK JUST
A MOMENT. LINE. ONE FIFTY SIX.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS NOT DECIDE RULING ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA MOBILITY
AND PARKING ASSOCIATION WHICH IS
COMPRISED OF HUNDREDS MUNICIPAL
SPECIAL DISTRICT IN COUNTY
PARKING PROGRAMS UNFORTUNATELY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE I WOULD YOU AGREE
WITH THE INTENT OF THE MEASURE
THE LAUDABLE GOAL PROVIDING A
PATH FORWARD FOR THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS TO
ADDRESS THEIR FINANCIAL BURDENS.
OF THE PROTEST PROPOSED IN THE
BILL IS PROBLEMATIC THE MAIN
PROBLEM BEING WITH THE PARKING
TICKET ISSUED AT THE AUTHOR
STATED THE AGENCY WOULD NEED TO
DEDICATE TIME RESOURCES AND
MANPOWER TO THE TASK LIKE THAT
YOU CAN FIND TO DO ONLY TO
DISCOVER THAT THE END
INDIVIDUALS QUALIFIED UNDER
SIXTY FIVE FOR FINANCIAL EVERY.
MORE STREAMLINED AND EFFECTIVE
APPROACH WOULD BE TO REQUIRE
STATE LEVEL PRE QUALIFICATION
REQUIREMENT PER PLACARD TYPE
PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT THE
TARGETED INDIVIDUALS IN THIS
BILL- IN THE BILL THIS WEEK THAT
THE BILL SEEKS TO ASSIST OR
SIMPLY NOT TAKEN IN THE FIRST
PLACE OUR CONCERNS OF MAKING
AVAILABLE PARKING AND PARKING
SPACE TURNOVER WOULD REMAIN- BUT
IT WOULD REMOVE SOME OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS THE
CURRENT BILL DOES IMPOSE. LASTLY
THE MEASURED DID NOT SPEAK TO
VARIOUS TYPES OF OTHER ACTIONS
THE CONCERT TRIGGER TAKE
INCLUDING PARKING IN A
HANDICAPPED PARKING SPACE
WITHOUT A PLACARD BLOCKING A
FIRE HYDRANT RECORD NO PARKING
ZONE BLOCKING STREET SWEEPING
AND BUTTON TRANSIT LINES AS WE
LIKE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO
ADDRESS THESE AS WELL- AND AGAIN
WE'D BE LIKE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORED
EXPLORE ALTERNATIVES JUSTICE
DISPONIBLE POPULATION. OF THE
FOR THE PREVIOUSLY STATED
REASONS WE. WE ARE CURRENTLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY WE WILL BRING IT
BACK NOW. COMMIT REQUEST FOR MR
QUIRK-SILVA. I'M NOT NOT
QUESTION JUST VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS BILL. A FEW OF THE ROOM
SPONSORS RIGHT NOW FROM THE
OPPOSITION. THERE MAY BE SOME
PLACE TO WORK ON SOME OF THAT
BUT I WOULD DEFINITELY SAY YOU
KNOW THIS IS PART OF THE PUZZLE
OF- PREVENTING HOMELESSNESS WE
TALK A LOT ABOUT HOUSING WE TALK
ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT-
PREVENTING HOMELESSNESS-
CERTAINLY HAS TO BE PART OF IT
NOW CERTAINLY SOME PEOPLE WOULD
SAY. USING YOUR CAR OR AN RV- IS
NOT IDEAL AND IT IS NOT IDEAL
BUT IF THAT IS THE LAST STOP
FROM BEING ON THE STREETS THIS
IS A VERY WORTHY AND SO I
SUPPORTED AND- GOOD JOB. THANK
YOU MISS QUIRK-SILVA ANYONE ELSE
. DO WE HAVE A MOTION. SECOND
MISS CRUZ MART MOVE SMITH
QUIRK-SILVA SECONDS AND- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- AND THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES- COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE OPOSITION WE CARE
ABOUT GETTING EVERY POLICY WE
INTRODUCE RIGHT AS BILLS
PERSONAL FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS
. I HAVE A SIBLING WHO CAME OUT
OF THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM WHO-
RE INTO THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
IN THEIR TEENS- STRUGGLE TO FIND
HOUSING. I HELPED BY THEN THE
CAR THAT THEY ENDED UP LIVING
IN. WHEN THEY COULDN'T KEEP THE
CAR ANYMORE THAT'S WHEN THEY
FELL INTO THE STREETS- AND
MENTAL. ILLNESS STARTED TO CREEP
IN AND THE STRUGGLE TO GET UP
OFF THE STREETS IS INCREDIBLY
IMMENSE- AND SO. KEEPING PEOPLE
FROM FALLING INTO HOMELESSNESS
ALBEIT ARGUING THAT LIVING IN
YOUR CAR IS DEFINITELY A FORM OF
BEING ON HOUSING- IS OMETHING
WE HAVE TO DO WE CAN'T
CRIMINALIZE WILL PENALIZE OUR
WAY OUT OF HOMELESSNESS OR
POVERTY. AND SO THIS BILL IS A
RESPONSIBILITY AND IT'S A GOOD
GOVERNANCE BILL BEEN MORE MONEY
TRYING TO COLLECT THE FINES AND
FEES THE WIND OF COLM-
COLLECTING IT PASSED OUT OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
FOURTEEN ZERO NO NO VOTES
INCLUDING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER BROWN I'M
THROUGH CS SIX SUPPORTER OF THE
BILL I BELIEVE ALREADY VOTED FOR
AND TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE-
APPRECIATE YOUR VOICE AN
ADVOCACY IN THE SPACE SO
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET OUT OF
COMMITTEE IN ON ON WHAT IT GOES.
WITH THAT YOU CAN TAKE ROLE-
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS
WICKS. I SEYARTO. THANK YOU. I
GABRIEL KALRA I KALRA I KILEY
QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA I WORK
FOR TI. IT'S GOT FIVE VOTES
IT'LL GET OUT LEAVE IT OPEN
THOUGH. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WE HAVE MISSED FRIEDMAN NEXT
I THINK YOU HAVE TO BILLS UP SB
NATION ANY THREE MAYBE TWENTY
NICE NINETY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING
SHARE- I THINK THIS IS NOT THIS
IS MOBILE. THAT'S OKAY. I AB
TWENTY THE TWENTY NINETY SEVEN
FIRST YEAH WHICHEVER YOU PREFER
OKAY WE'LL START WITH TWENTY
NINETY SEVEN- GOOD MORNING URN
MEMBERS- THIS IS A BILL THAT
PASSED WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE LAST YEAR
THIS IS A BILL THAT WOULD
BASICALLY ALLOW FOR DEVELOPERS
TO RIGHT SIZE THE AMOUNT OF
PARKING THAT THEY NEED FOR THEIR
PROJECT AS LONG AS THE BILL THE
PROJECT IS WITHIN A HALF A MILE
OF A TRAIN STOP OR OTHER HIGH
QUALITY TRANSIT. WE PROVIDE MORE
SPACES FOR CARS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE DO BEDS FOR
HUMAN BEINGS WHO LIVE HERE AND
IT MANY TIMES ESPECIALLY IN
THESE URBAN AREAS ARE CLOSE TO
TRANSIT- WE HAVE OF THE PLETHORA
OF PARKING SPACES- WE DO SO MUCH
PARKING THAT'S UNDER USER AND
USE IT ALL THAT CONTINUING TO
REQUIRE DEVELOPERS TO ADD A
PRIEST OF SUBSCRIBED AMOUNT OF
PARKING REGARDLESS OF THE NEEDS
OF THEIR RESIDENTS DOESN'T MAKE
ECONOMIC SENSE IT DOESN'T MAKE
PUBLIC POLICY SENSE IT'S NOT
SUSTAINABLE. AND THE DEVELOPERS
KNOW HOW MUCH PARKING THAT THEY
NEED SAN DIEGO A FEW YEARS AGO
INSTITUTED THIS POLICY IN THEIR
DOWNTOWN CORE AND YOU KNOW WHAT
PEOPLE THOUGHT OF PARKING THEY
STILL BILL PARKING BUT THEY BOTH
THE RIGHT AMOUNT OF PARKING AND
IT ALLOWS THEM TO OFFER
RESIDENTIAL UNITS WITH MAYBE ONE
SPACE INSIDE OF TWO OR TANDEM
PARKING HAS SINCE- THERE
RESIDENTS INTO GIVEN THE CHOICE-OF PAYING A LITTLE BIT LESS A
MONTH TO ACCOMMODATE THEIR
PARTICULAR NEEDS. A ARM. OF THE
BILL HAS GAINED A LOT OF SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IT'S
SPONSORED BY CALIFORNIA YIMBY
SPUR ABUNDANT HOUSING LA THE
COUNCIL OF INFILL BOULDER
BOULDER'S. AND SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO THE LA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. THE SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION AND
TRANSFORM. AND I WANT TO SAY
THAT WHEN YOU GET ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS AND THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE TOGETHER. MAYBE IT'S A
IT'S GOOD POLICY. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT THIS MORNING- COLIN
PARENT COUNCIL MEMBER WITH THE
CITY OF LA MESA. AND MIA KANG
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT WITH THE
RELATE WITH RELATED CALIFORNIA
AND DIRECTOR OF THE COUNCIL OF
INFILL BUILDERS. I APPRECIATE
YOUR RESPECTFUL YOUR THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CHECK TWO MINUTES. MORNING
MY NAME IS COLIN PARENT I'M ON
THE CITY COUNCIL OF WILL MESA
WHICH IS ABOUT TEN MILES EAST OF
DOWNTOWN SAN DIEGO- I'M ALSO THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND GENERAL
COUNSEL WITH THE NONPROFIT
CALLED CIRCULATE SAN DIEGO- HERE
TESTIFYING FOR THE BUILDING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR THE
INVITATION AND- JUST WANT TO
MAKE A THREE KEY POINTS ABOUT
THIS BILL. SO FIRST YOU KNOW
IT'S THE CEILING SO YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE SIXTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE VERY SUBURBAN- IN A SMALL
TOWN- BUT YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT A
GREAT ACCESSORY DWELLING UNIT
ORDINANCE VERY PERMISSIVE-
YOU'RE VERY PRO HOUSING WE'VE
GOT- IMPLEMENTATION OF STATE
DENSITY BONUS LAW. REALLY GOOD
FAITH IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT AND
THERE'S NO WAY WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DO ANY OF THESE
ORDINANCES LOCALLY IF THE STATE
HADN'T ACTED FIRST THE JUST THE
POLITICS ARE THERE FOR IT AND I
THINK FOR THOSE OF YOU WILL WHO
SERVED IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT-
ESPECIALLY OUTSIDE OF A LARGE
CITY I THINK WE'LL WILL
UNDERSTAND WHY AND SO THAT'S WHY
IT'S A BIG PART OF WHY- WE
REALLY WANT TO SEE SOME ACTION
FROM THE LEGISLATURE ON THIS.
BECAUSE I'M CONFIDENT YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE GOOD FAITH
IMPLEMENTATION OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AS LONG AS OTHER
FOLKS- AS LONG AS THE
LEGISLATURE RACKS IN SECOND- YOU
KNOW JUST BECAUSE THERE ARE
PARKING MINIMUMS DOESN'T MEAN
THAT PEOPLE DON'T BILL TWENTY
PARKING SO IN THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO WHERE THERE HAVE BEEN-
VERY SIMILAR POLICY THAT THAT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORD. SUPPORT
AND GET ACROSS ON PEOPLE ARE
STILL BUILDING PARKING WHEN THEY
WHEN THEY NEED TO BUT THEY'RE
ALSO BUILDING AN APPROPRIATE
AMOUNT OF PARKING THAT THEY
THINK IS NECESSARY TO SERVE THE
EVOLVING- MARKET PLACE AS
OPPOSED TO ASSUMING EVERYONE
NEEDS THE EXACT SAME AMOUNT OF
PARKING IN MY CITY IN LA MESA
LOTS OF PEOPLE ARE MOVING IN
THERE TO START A FAMILIES BUY
HOMES FOR THE FIRST TIME. A LOT
OF THESE FOLKS DON'T HAVE CARS
THERE AND THEY ARE ACTUALLY
HAVING THEIR YOU'RE CHOOSING NOT
TO HAVE CARS ARE HAVING FEWER
CARS IN YOUR HOUSEHOLD TO BE
ABLE TO AFFORD THEIR OVERALL
HOUSEHOLD EXPENSES- INA BILL
LIKE IN THIS BILL WILL HELP-
ALLOW FOR MORE THOSE PRODUCTS TO
BE ON CREATED TO SERVE THAT
CHANGING MARKET AND THEN
FINALLY- MY ORGANIZATION
CIRCULATE SAN DIEGO PUBLISHER-
ABOUT A WEEK. A HALF AGO-
SHOWING THAT IN THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO- EVEN AFTER PARKING
REFORM- WAS- ENACTED DENSITY
BONUS PRODUCTION ACTUALLY. WENT
UP ACTUALLY WENT UP A LOT. IN
TWENTY TWENTY- 44% OF THE UNITS
ENTITLED. IN THE CITY SAN DIEGO
USE THAT- DENSITY BONUS PROGRAM.
AND IT YEAH AND THE PARKING
REFORM THAT HAD HAPPENED A FEW
YEARS REALLY DIDN'T UNDERMINE
THE PRODUCTION THAT SO WE'RE
STILL SEEING GREAT USES OF THAT
PROGRAM. AND PARKING REFORM- CAN
ABSOLUTELY WORK WELL WITH. AND
SUPPORT- AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION IN THE USE OF DENSITY
BONUS. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST OF
THE SUPPORT THIS BILL. GOOD
MORNING AMIR KHAN A WITH RELATED
CALIFORNIA AND OF THE COUNCIL OF
INFILL BUILDERS I'VE BEEN IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER FOR
THE LAST. TWENTY FIVE YEARS
BUILDING. UP AND DOWN THE STATE
IN RURAL URBAN AND SUBURBAN
COMMUNITIES IN THE NUMBER ONE
THING THAT'S COMMON IN ALL OF
THE DEVELOPMENTS I'VE EVER
WORKED ON IS. NEEDING TO REDUCE
THE PARKING REQUIREMENT FOR
EVERY SINGLE DEVELOPMENT. OF
PRIMARILY BECAUSE THE ONE SIZE
FITS ALL REQUIREMENTS DON'T
REFLECT TODAY'S SOCIETY
ESPECIALLY RENTERS-
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH. ACCORDING
TO THE LAST CENSUS. OVER 52% OF
CALIFORNIA RENTERS OWN ZERO OR
ONE CAR. AND SO WE'RE REALLY
BUILDING WERE THESE REQUIREMENTS
ARE SORT OF SET IN PLACE OF BACK
WHEN FRANKLY EVERYONE OWNED
MULTIPLE CARS. AND YET WE'RE
SEEING THIS ABSOLUTE CHANGE AND
PART OF IT IS THE COST OF
HOUSING IS SO EXPENSIVE PEOPLE
ARE FORGOING THE COST OF CARS.
BUT ALSO BECAUSE WE'VE WALKABLE
COMMUNITIES AND WE HAVE TRANSIT
AND WE HAVE THINGS LIKE RIDE
CHER- ACCORDING TO THE NUMBER OF
US STUDIES I'VE BEEN READING
RECENTLY. MILLENNIALS ARE
ACTUALLY VALUE ACCESS TO A CAR
RATHER THAN OWNING THEIR OWN
VEHICLE. SO YET WE STILL HAVE
THESE FRANKLY IN SOME CASES-ARCANE PARKING REQUIREMENTS IN
ONE CASE I'VE HAD TO REDUCE
PARKING. FOR PARKING SPACES PER
UNIT DOWN TO ONE OR LESS. AND SO
THE BILL LIKE THIS IS A STRAIGHT
FORWARD IN MY OPINION
COMMONSENSE WAY TO BE
TRANSPARENT AND COULD PROVIDE
CLARITY TO THE DEVELOPMENT
MARKET. IT'S ALSO IT IN WHILE
FOR COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS A MIXED
USE BUILDINGS TO ALSO TAKE
ADVANTAGE. OF A PARKING THAT IS
RIGHT SIZED FOR THEIR SITES. AND
FOR THEIR BUILDINGS I THINK IT
WILL UNLEASH A LOT OF NEW
DEVELOPMENT POTENTIAL IN ALL THE
RIGHT PLACES. IN THE STATE NEEDS
LOVI EMPTY AREAS AND AREAS
AROUND TRANSIT. AND IT WILL
ABSOLUTELY REDUCE THE COST OF
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT WHICH WILL
REDUCE THE COST OF HOUSING FOR
THE END USER. AND AS WE ALL KNOW
I THINK WHEN YOU WHEN YOU READ
A- AN APARTMENT THAT HAS A
PARKING SPACE IT COSTS MORE.
MEANING APARTMENT THAT DOESN'T
HAVE A PARKING SPACE. AND SO IT
WILL TRANSLATE INTO MORE HOUSING
FOR THE ELIQUIS AND MORE.
PRODUCTION IN MY AND I STRONGLY
URGE THIS COMMITTEE IS AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I WILL GO TO FOLKS HERE IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO ADD ON
NAME ORGANIZATIONS. AND-
POSITION THANK YOU. ONLY FOR
MANY TO HAS THIS OF LATE HAS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE IN SUPPORT
TODAY ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA CIVIC WELL
AND SAND HILL PROPERTY'S. LAUREN
DILANSIR REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANKS. LOUIS MONDAY
WITH CALIFORNIA BE HERE'S THE
SUPPORTER IN A PROUD CO SPONSOR
THANK YOU. CORY SMITH HOUSING
ACTION COALITION SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MORE TOP HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR LETTING
WITH THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP IN SUPPORT.
NEVADA MERRIMAN MID PENN HOUSING
AND SUPPORT. DIFFICULTY THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU OPERATOR
WE WILL TAKE IT TO THE PHONES-
FOR FOLKS WISHING TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A BI NINETEEN NINETY
THREE PLEASE JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR WE WILL NOW GO
TO LINE ONE FIFTY ONE. MICHAEL
ENGLISH FOR A BILL SPONSORED
STRONG SUPPORT. SLIDE ONE OH
EIGHT. HI ALPHEN SCHALLERT MARK
OF LOS ANGELES AND- FOR STRONG
SUPPORTER THAT BREAKS DOWN THANK
YOU. ONE SIXTY TWO. THE PROPOSAL
WITH ABUNDANT HOUSING LA PRADA
SUPPORTING CO SPONSOR AB TWENTY
NINETY SEVEN. LINE THIRTY SIX.
FIVE NOT A BOOKBINDER ON BEHALF
WITHOUT THE FRAUD FOR DEATH AB
TWENTY NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU.
FIND. ONE SEVENTY TWO.
WINDJAMMERS NEED ABOUT MILLION
BEING TRANSPORT. LIKE SEVENTY
FIVE. BASICALLY AND REPRESENTING
FREMONT FOR EVERYONE IN SUPPORT
. BY ONE SIXTY THREE. HI THIS IS
ERIN LAWYER ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. WHY
ONE THIRTY NINE. MARK BOOKS BUT
SHE FROM STREET FOR ALL WHO ARE
PROUD TO SUPPORT A LOT BACK WHEN
HE QUALITY THAT THE FLIGHT
SESSION. THANK YOU. LINE FORTY
THREE. DECAL THINK YOU'RE A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER IN SUPPORT. FIND. ONE SEVENTY EIGHT. POLITECNICA
ON BEHALF OF THEM. OR. AFTER
SANTA MONICA FOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU WHY SEVENTY. I
ALSO SOME ARGUMENTS ALREADY
ARRESTED FROM SUPPORT. NINE ONE
SIX NINE. HI PUBLIC MORE-CALIFORNIA BE INSTRUCTIVE. LINE
ONE SIXTY SIX. THANK YOU MATT
MATT STOPPER CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE SANTA MONICA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE SEVENTY SEVEN. PARDON
ME ONE ONE SEVENTY ONE. I WAS
DISTURBING MORE SHINER CALLING
FROM LOS ANGELES ON BEHALF OF
WEBSITE FOR EVERYONE STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE. THIRTY
TWO. ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. FIND. ONE SEVENTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING I MEAN ORTIZ
ON BEHALF OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ACTION
FUND SUPPORT. LINE ONE SEVENTY
NINE. I CARE ME YES. ANDREW
LEWIS- THREE FIFTY- STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU. BY ONE
EIGHTY. BORN WELL SPROUT UNDER
COUNTY BY TWO COLLISION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. BY ONE EIGHTY
ONE. SH PUBLICIST FROM BY CULVER
CITY IN STRONG SUPPORT. FIND.
ONE EIGHTY FIVE. IF YOU'RE A
CHAMPION FOR MORE ON THE HOCKEY
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT. BY
ONE EIGHTY THREE. HELLO MY NAME
IS BRIAN PRESCOTT CALLING IN
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA AS A
MEMBER OF THE ABUNDANT HOUSING
LA SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. FIND ONE FORTY FOUR. AIR
CANADA THAT GIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY URBAN INSTITUTE
IN FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT. FINE THIRTY HILL. ONE
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. I'M SURE THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
TO SIGNAL THEY WISH TO SPEAK
GREAT THANK YOU NOW IS SUPPORT
FOR AB TWENTY NINETY SEVEN I
THINK WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL
PERSON THERE IN HOLLAND
EXPRESSED SUPPORT. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS UP THE CHUCKLE AT
THE ELLIE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND
WHEN I BRING IT BACK HERE INTO
THE ROOM FOR OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IF YOU
COULD COME. TAKE A SEAT UP HERE
. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES I WAS REALLY
APPRECIATE WHAT THE SOMEONE
TRYING TO DO HERE THE BILL
UNFORTUNATELY JUST RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH THE APPROACH AND
WE HAVE THREE PRIMARY- ISSUES
WITH THE BILL ONE- YOU KNOW
THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THAT THERE
THE COST SAVINGS ACTUALLY PASSED
ON TO THE RENTER OR HOMEOWNER
I'M RELYING ON FOR PROFIT
BUSINESS TO FOREGO PROFIT IN
ORDER TO LOWER THE COST OF THE
PRODUCT I'M WORDS CAPITAL THAT
APPROACH- NUMBER TWO- YOU KNOW.
THE ALLOWING A TRANSIT AGENCY OR
A DEVELOPER TO DETERMINE-
PARKING REQUIREMENT SEEMS A BIT.
ODD WHEN WE HAVE LOCALLY ELECTED
OFFICIALS ON THAT ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE VOTERS WHO WHO ARE
TRADITIONALLY IN CHARGE. OF THIS
PARKING STANDARDS IF THERE NEEDS
TO BE REFORMED. I WITH OUR
CITIES GO ABOUT- INCEPTION IS
WORKING REQUIREMENTS WERE
CERTAINLY OPEN TO IT BUT JUST
ALLOWING THOSE FOLKS TO DO IT
UNILATERALLY- WE CERTAINLY
OBJECT TO IT- AND THEN FINALLY
WE DO HAVE CONCERNS. ABOUT THE
MEASURES IMPACT AND DENSITY
BONUS LAW ON THAT STATE LAWS
VERY EFFECTIVE IN GETTING YOU
KNOW AFFORDABLE UNITS BUILT-
BECAUSE CITIES HAVE TO GIVE UP
CERTAIN- YOU KNOW. CONCESSIONS
AND WAIVERS I'M TO DEVELOPERS IN
ORDER TO GET AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT'S THE KEYMANDATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IF WE ARE
GOING TO PROVIDE RELIEF FROM
PARKING REQUIREMENTS FOR
EXAMPLE- FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO ADD ON HERE
IN OPPOSITION NAME ORGANIZATION
PLEASE. SYMPATHY ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WHILE WE ARE PREACHING
OF THE GOLD ON TEN OF THE BILL
WE HAVE SOME ISSUES WITH THE
LANGUAGE IN PRINT BUT ARE
WORKING VERY COLLABORATIVELY
WITH THE OFFICE TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES AND LOOK FOR TO THE
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AN OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES FOR THE
PUBLIC FOR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY NINETY SEVEN. NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION PLACE. FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
. GOING TO GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING MANAGER
MEMBERS A COMMITTEE BALKANS
OFFICE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA CLARITA IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY EIGHT.
RECALL ON BEHALF OF GLOBAL
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. WIRED
ONE SIXTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
YOU'RE A ROCK ON BEHALF OF THE
TOWN OF TRUCKEE WE ARE OPPOSED
TO MATHEMATICS AND THEN THE
OPPOSED FROM THE- AYRTON COUNTY
MEMBERS OF MY- CITY. FIVE ONE
EIGHTY FOUR. HI THIS IS A IDEA
ABOUT THIS THING WITH LITTLE
BOOK CALIFORNIA AND LOS ANGELES
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THANKS. LINE. ONE EIGHTY SEVEN.
WHY ONE EIGHTY SEVEN NO ONE IS
NOW OPEN. HI I'M SO HIGH I'M
CALLING AND I'M SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF REDWOOD CITY I WAS
TRYING TO GET INTO EARLIER AND
IT WOULDN'T WITH NAMES I
APOLOGIZE. AND ONCE AGAIN FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ONE
ZERO. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL BRING IT
BACK HERE TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MISTER WARD. YOU HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT YOUR WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL
AS WE STATED LAST YEAR ON BOTH
IN COMMITTEE ON IN THE FALL ON
THE FLOOR I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP TAKE THE STATE
WHY WE HAVE. BEEN ONE OF THE
CITIES THAT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
LEAD THIS CHARGE- IN THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO- I THINK THE EVIDENCE
IS RIGHT THERE THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO PRODUCE. LOWER RENT HOUSING
AND LOWER UP FOR SALE PRODUCT AS
WELL BY REDUCING THIS COUPLED
COSTS- AND REALLY ALLOWING THE
MARKET TO BE ABLE TO DECIDE- AND
I WANT TO THANK MY FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE- FROM THE SAN DIEGO AS
WELL FOR HIS ADVOCACY ON A
NUMBER OF SOLUTIONS. I WONDER IF
YOU WANT TO COMMENT AS WELL IF
YOU SAW ANY YOU'VE ALSO BEEN- AN
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL AND DENSITY
BONUS LAW- AND ANY- CHALLENGE
THEIR- ACCORDING TO THE
OPPOSITION. YES YEAH THANKS FOR
ASKING SO THERE WAS A CONCERN
YOU KNOW REYES- THE LAST TIME
THIS WAS A BROUGHT UP ABOUT-
UNDERMINING DENSITY BONUS LAW
BECAUSE ONE OF THE BENEFITS OF
DENSITY BONUSES YOU CAN GET OUT
OF SOME PARKING RESTRICTIONS.
AND I WAS ACTUALLY WHAT I WAS
REFERENCING EARLIER REPORT THAT
CIRCULATE PUT OUT- LAST WEEK
SHOWED THAT AFTER SAN DIEGO
ADOPTED THEIR PARKING REFORM IS
VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED HERE- DENSITY BONUS
ACTUALLY DIDN'T GET UNDER MY
ACTUALLY ACTUALLY GREW A LOT.
AND IN TWENTY TWENTY- IT IT GREW
SO MUCH THAT WAS 44% OF THE
UNITS PRODUCED IN THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO USE DENSITY BONUS EVEN
AFTER THIS REFORM SO THESE
THINGS WHICH IS ASTONISHING IT'S
GREAT I MEAN PART BROUGH FOR
DENSITY BONUS BUT ALSO- THE
PARKING REFORM- DIDN'T DIDN'T
IMPACT THAT OFF- SO. I THINK
WE'LL HOPEFULLY THAT CAN GIVE
SOME COMFORT TO THE TO THE FOLKS
WHO EXPRESSED THE CONCERN THAT
THE OTHER SEPARATIST THANK YOU
WILL CONTINUE RUNS HERE ARE
PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR AT THE
AUTHOR WOULD ACCEPT IT. AND
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL TODAY.
THE YOU THINK WITH THE MOST.
SECONDS FOR. OF ANY. QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. MISTER SARATOGA.
AGAIN THE SAME SAME ISSUES I
HAVE. WITH ALL THIS WHEN YOU.
ARE WORKING ARE WHEN YOU'RE DOWN
IN SAN DIEGO- THESE. THESE
SOLUTIONS WERE GREAT THERE. THEY
WERE GREAT IN LA THEY WERE GOOD
WHERE PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY LIVING
PRETTY CLOSE TO WHERE THEY WORK-
YOU GO TO A DISTRICT LIKE MINE.
61% OF THE PEOPLE COMMUTE. SIXTY
FIVE MILES TO WORK. AND WHEN YOU
DRIVE AROUND- IN BELIEVE ME IF
WE SAID TO DEVELOPMENT HEY. YOU
GUYS DECIDE HOW MUCH PARKING YOU
NEED. ADOBE IS MINIMIZED AS
POSSIBLE. AND- AND THEN THE
PROBLEM IS. THE VEHICLES ARE
MINIMIZED AND THEN SO WE HAVE
PARKING SPILLING OUT INTO OTHER
NEIGHBORHOODS- WALL TO WALL CARS
ON THE STREETS AND IN THOSE
CREATE OTHER HAZARDS THEY CREATE
HAZARDS FOR. PEOPLE THAT ARE
WALKING DOWN THE SIDEWALK AND
TRYING TO CROSS AS THEY GET AND
SO WE HOW WE WIND UP WITH SAFETY
HAZARDS OUT THERE FOR THAT SO
AGAIN THIS WORKS IN THOSE AREAS
THAT WE WOULD TAYLOR SOME OF
THESE SOLUTIONS TO URBAN AREAS-
AND ALLOW THE FLEXIBILITY FOR
OTHER AREAS TO DECIDE WHAT IS
WORKING FOR THEM I'M FAMILIAR
WITH THE CITY OF LA MESA MY
COUSINS LIVE THERE- AND IT
ISN'T- THERE ARE AREAS THERE
WHERE IT. WOULDN'T WORK AND YOU
WIND UP HAVING IMPACTS TO EVERY
BODY- INCLUDING- YOU KNOW WHEN
PEOPLE'S. HOUSING VALUES WHAT IF
YOU LIVE IN THE MIDDLE OF A AREA
WHERE IT'S JUST HEAVILY IMPACTED
BY PARKING ALL OVER THE LOOK AT
LOYOLA MARYMOUNT IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AROUND THAT IT
AFFECTS OUR HOUSING VALUES. AND
SO PEOPLE ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT PEOPLE MY DISTRICT
ARE EXTREMELY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT I THINK IT NEEDS TO BE LEFT
UP TO OUR COMMUNITIES TO DO WHAT
WORKS FORM BECAUSE BELIEVE ME IF
WE HAVE ALL PARKING LOT THE-
THOSEINTO SOMETHING A TAXES.
THEN IT IS A PARKING LOT SO
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO- NET. BUILD
MORE PARKING THAN THEY NEED. BUT
LIKE I SAID SAN DIEGO WORKS. OUT
IN OUR AREA DOESN'T WORK AT ALL.
SO I WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
BECAUSE OF THAT IF IT WERE
NARROWLY TAILORED TO URBAN AREAS
I'D BE ALL OVER IT THANKS. MR
GABRIEL THANK YOU MATTER CHECK A
SIMILAR RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUE OVER THERE-
YOU KNOW PARKING IS AN AMENITY
THAT CONSUMERS WANT AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT THEY'LL LOOK AT
WHEN THEY'RE DECIDING WHERE TO
BUY WORD AROUND WHERE THEY WANT
TO LAUGH AND SO I GUESS I JUST
HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE FAITH. IN
THE PRIVATE MARKET TO FIND THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCE OF SUPPLY
DEMAND OF PARKING AND SO I THINK
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IS
STOPPING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. FROM
REGULATING THOSE PRIVATE
ENTITIES TO COME TO THE OPTIMAL
SOLUTION FROM A SOCIETAL
PERSPECTIVE SO I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY- AND
APPRECIATE THE OTHER BRING
AFFORD. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
WANT TO SPEAK OUT IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY NINETY SEVEN OR
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR. OKAY
WITH THAT YOU CAN CLOSE THANK
YOU AND I APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT. YOU KNOW RIGHT
NOW WITH LIMITED RESOURCES
PARTICULARLY TO BUILD HOUSING
THAT. WE HAVE TO MAKE A CHOICE
OF WHAT WE'RE PRIORITIZING. AND
THERE ARE SO MANY BENEFITS TO
ALLOWING THESE AREAS THAT BY THE
WAY ARE NOT ALL OVER CITIES
THERE RIGHT NEXT TO HIGH QUALITY
TRANSIT. TO BECOME A MORE
WALKABLE AREAS AND TO OFFER A
DIFFERENT KIND OF PRODUCT AND-
AS WE SAW. WE HAVE ACTUAL
EVIDENCE OF WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
PRICE OF HOUSING DOES GO DOWN
AND THEY DO OFFER THOSE UNITS
WITH SOME FLEXIBILITY FOR PEOPLE
WHO. WANT TO USE THAT TRANSIT.
AS THEIR PRIMARY MEANS OF
GETTING AROUND. AND I WOULD ALSO
SAY THAT CITIES HAVE A LOT OF
TOOLS AT THEIR DISPOSAL TO ALSO
HELP MITIGATE ANY IMPACTS. MY
CITY BILL TO MUNICIPAL PARKING
LOTS IN THEIR DOWNTOWN WHICH
TOOK THE BURDEN OFF OF ALL THE
MOM AND POP SHOPS TO PROVIDE
THEIR OWN PARKING. AND IT BECAME
A REVENUE GENERATOR FOR THE CITY
AS WELL WE ALSO CAN RUN BUS.
THAT HELP WITH THESE AND WE'RE
TRYING TO ENCOURAGE CITIES TO DO
IS TO. TO THINK OF THESE OTHER
SOLUTIONS. THOUGH IT DOES BUILD
SUSTAINABILITY. AS WELL AS BUILD
THE ALLOWANCE TO BUILD HOUSING.
AND SO MANY OF OUR CODES ARE
STUCK IN THE PAST AND TAKE WAY
TOO LONG TO CHANGE. AND THIS IS
A PLACE GIVEN THE- THE CRISIS
THAT WE HAVE. BOTH THE FOR
CLIMATE. AND FOR HOUSING WITH
THE CITY WITH THE STATE DOES
HAVE A VESTED INTEREST IN TAKING
A LEAD. SO I DO APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT OF MY COLLEAGUES TODAY
WE UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS AND
AS SOMEONE WHO COMES FROM LOCAL
pHAVE THE TOOLS ALSO TO. MITIGATE
ANY IMPACTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I MISS FRIEDMAN I KNOW
YOU'VE WORKED ON THIS ISSUE FOR
QUITE SOME TIME I AM. VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR WORK AND
GLAD YOU'RE CONTINUING TO DO
THAT I'M GOING TO
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY AND I THINK IT
ADDRESSES TWO OF OUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGES. INCREASING HOUSING
SUPPLY AND SLOWING CLIMATE
CHANGE AND I VIEW AND I KNOW YOU
DO THESE ISSUES IS VERY-
CONNECTED- WE MUST ACT. URGENTLY
URGENTLY AND SWIFTLY AND WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL AS FOR ROLL CALL PLEASE.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS
WEEKS I. DON'T SEE ORIGINAL
CARILLO. GABRIEL GABRIEL I.
KALRA HI KALRA AYE KILEY
QUIRK-SILVA. QUIRK-SILVA A WARD
WHAT HI. HAS FIVE OH TO W. WOULD
OPEN. I MISS FRIEDMAN YOUR UP
AGAIN HERE ON AB NINETEEN THIRTY
THREE. THANK YOU I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB NINETEEN THIRTY THREE
A BILL TO EXPAND THE PROPERTY
TAX WELFARE EXEMPTION TO
ELIGIBLE NONPROFIT CORPORATIONS
THAT'S ALL OF THAT CELL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS TO LOW
INCOME PEOPLE. THIS IS A TAX
CREDIT THAT ALLOWS FOR THE SAME
NONPROFIT CORPORATIONS TO
REHABILITATE- TO BUILD- FOR-
RENT UNITS USE THE SAME TAX
CREDIT BUT THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
USE IT WHEN THEY'RE BUILDING
pPROJECT LIKE THIS AND CITY OF
GLENDALE WAS I WAS ON THE
COUNCIL WHICH WERE TOWN HOUSES
THAT WERE SOLD TO LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS. AND IT'S VERY VERY
DIFFICULT- FOR DEVELOPERS TO
FINANCE THIS KIND OF PRODUCT
THIS WOULD HELP THEM- BECAUSE-
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT A NONPROFIT
DEVELOPERS WHO BUILD A DEED
RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR HOME BUYERS ARE CURRENTLY
DENIED A PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION
BECAUSE THE HOME BUYERS PAYING
INTEREST ON A CONVENTIONAL
MORTGAGE. INSTEAD OF ALL THE
FINANCED AND GOING THROUGH A 0%
INTEREST LOAN. HOW WE'VE HEARD
FROM ONE AT NONPROFIT DEVELOPER
WHO I BELIEVE IS HERE HERITAGE
HOUSING PARTNERS THAT THEY'RE
FORCED TO PAY THE PROPERTY TAX
IN THE TIME THEY PURCHASED THE
LAND. THROUGH CONSTRUCTION UNTIL
THE CLOSE OF ESCROW WHEN THEY
TURN THE KEYS OVER TO THE BUYER.
THIS RESULT IN PROPERTY TAX
PAYMENTS OF MANY THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS PER HOME THAT COULD
INSTEAD BE PLACED BACK INTO
DEVELOPMENT CONSTRUCTION TO GIVE
THESE LOW INCOME RESIDENTS A
CHANCE TO DEVELOP STABILITY.
EQUITY ALL THE THINGS THAT WE
KNOW HOMEOWNERSHIP OFFERS. AND
YOU KNOW THIS ALSO IS SOMETHING
THAT A LOT. OF MONEY BECAUSE
WHEN THAT THE ON LIKE WITH
RENTAL PROPERTY THESE HOMEOWNERS
WILL EVENTUALLY PAY THEIR OWN
PROPERTY TAX SO IF WE DON'T
ALLOW THESE PROPERTIES TO BE
BUILT IF WE USE THIS IS A
BARRIER. THE CITIES IN THE STATE
IS FOREVER DENIED THATTAX
REVENUE. AND I WILL ALSO SAY
THAT- THESE ARE VERY OF A VERY
SMALL AMOUNT OF THE- PRODUCTS
THAT ARE BROUGHT TO MARKET IT'S
REALLY AN INSIGNIFICANT DROP IN
THE BUCKET N TERMS OF TAX
REVENUE. FOR THE STATE BUT IT
DOES RESULT IN A LOT OF SAVINGS.
AB NINETEEN THIRTY THREE IS
SUPPORTED BY THE ASSESSOR OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY JEFF PRANG AND
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC.
CONFERENCE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
TODAY ARE DAVID WILLS AT BUT NO
I THINK IT'S JUST CHARLES
LUCKMAN. FOR HERITAGE HOUSING
PARTNERS AND HOLLY OF FERMENTED
TO HIS USE FOR HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU PERCENT AT MADAME
CHARTER MORNING- DAVID WOLF WITH
WELL VERSED CONSULTING
REPRESENTING HERITAGE HOUSING
PARTNERS WE ARE THE SPONSOR OF
AB NINETEEN THIRTY THREE. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE CHARLES
LEVIN THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
HERITAGE HOUSING PARTNERS WHO
FLEW UP FROM LOS ANGELES TODAY-
JUST TO TESTIFY ON. THE BILL
SOME VERY DAVID. NO I YOU MY
NAME IS CHARLES WEBB AND I'M
EXECUTIVE HERE HOUSING PARTNERS
WHERE THE SPONSOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION- JUST A FEW QUICK
WORDS ABOUT OUR ORGANIZATION AND
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
LEGISLATION TO US HERITAGE
HOUSING PARTNERS IS A NONPROFIT
HOUSING DEVELOPER FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT SO WE'VE
BEEN AROUND FOR ABOUT TWENTY
THREE PLUS YEARS WE'RE DIFFERENT
THAN MOST OTHER NONPROFITS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR TWO REASONS FIRST
IS OUR FOCUS ON AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP WE SURE THAT FOCUS
WITH OUR FRIENDS AT HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY. AND THE OTHER REASON
THAT WERE DIFFERENT IS BECAUSE
OF OUR FOCUS ON MIXED INCOME
HOUSING SO WHEREVER POSSIBLE WE
DEVELOP OWNERSHIP UNITS FOR LOW
INCOME MODERATE INCOME MIDDLE
INCOME AND MARKET BUYERS ALL
LIVING IN WITHIN THE SAME
PROJECT- WE LIKE TO DO IT
BECAUSE OF A WE FOUND THAT TO
CREATE THEIR SOCIAL OUTCOMES FOR
HOMEOWNERS ECONOMIC DIVERSITY IS
DIVERSITY- AND THE SECOND REASON
IS FRANKLY BECAUSE THERE'S SO
LITTLE FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE
OWNERSHIP- AT THE STATE THEY
WERE ABLE TO TAKE THE PROFITS
FROM DEVELOPING MARKET UNITS
WITHIN OUR PROJECTS AND SELF
SUBSIDIZE MODERN MIDDLE INCOME
UNITS. SO THAT'S WHY WE DO THAT
OUR GOAL IS TO MAKE OWNERSHIP
HOUSING- ATTAINABLE AND
AFFORDABLE TO REALLY ANY
CALIFORNIANS WHO WANTS TO BE AN
OWNER AND QUALIFIES TO BE AN
OWNER AND WE THINK WE DO THAT
WITH A COMBINATION OF TWO THINGS
WHEREVER POSSIBLE BENDING THE
COST CURVE ON THE COST OF
PRODUCING HOUSING WHICH THIS
LEGISLATION WILL DO AND SECOND
PROVIDED FAVORABLE FINANCING TO
OUR HOME BUYERS- WHICH IS REALLY
THE BIG WAY THAT WE DO THAT
HABITAT DOES THAT TO. MAKE
HOUSING AFFORDABLE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN HOLLY
FOR MANY ON BEHALF A HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA AND I THINK
MANY OF YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH
HAVE A TOP AT THE MODEL AND HOW
MUCH HAVE HIS EVENT INVOLVING
THE TIMES TO GET REALLY KEEP UP
WITH NOT JUST HOME PRICES WHICH
ARE NOW ACCORDING TO ZILLOW FAR
OF HUNDRED OUT A HOME IS THE%
AVERAGE BEFORE YEAH I DON'T KNOW
WHO. THAT IS AFFORDABLE TO BUT
IT'S DEFINITELY NOT AFFORDABLE
TO PEOPLE WHO UNDER PERCENT OF
THE A MY- AND THERE AND A THE
STATE. AND JUST LAST NIGHT WHEN
YOUR COLLEAGUES AS A WRITING ME
THAT JUST SEVEN YEARS AGO WHEN
HIS LOS ANGELES YOU CAN STILL
BUY A HOME FOR UNDER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS JUST SEVEN
YEARS AGO. AND THOSE SAME HOMES
ARE NOW SELLING AT SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND SO HABITAT INHERITED
ANOTHER IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS BUILD MORE HOMES. BECAUSE
THEY'RE SUCH A GREAT NEED THAT
ARE AT THE PRICE POINT THE
PEOPLE WHO MAKE LOW INCOMES CAN
ACTUALLY STILL AFFORD. AND I
JUST RECENTLY ASKED HABITAT ARE
IN OUR GREAT ALESSI UNTIL IT
GREATER SAN FRANCISCO AREA IN
EAST BAY SILICON VALLEY THEY
WERE TELLING ME. RIGHT NOW JUST
READ UNDERSTAND THE DEMAND FOR A
TWENTY UNIT- PROJECT THAT WE'RE
BUILDING WE HAD OVER ONE
THOUSAND APPLICATIONS. FOR
TWENTY SIX UNITS AND AN EIGHTY
UNIT A NEW ONE THAT'S ON THE
HORIZON IN MARIN COUNTY ALREADY
FOUR HUNDRED APPLICATIONS ARE IN
THE QUEUE. AND I ASKED THEM HOW
MANY OF THOSE APPLICANTS ARE
QUALIFYING AN ELIGIBLE TO GET
INTO THOSE HOMES AND THEY SAID
IT'S A FIVE TO ONE RATIO SO
EVERYONE HOME HABITAT IS
BUILDING AND SERVING A FAMILY.
FIVE OTHER YOU KNOW FOR OTHER
FAMILIES ARE NOT GETTING INTO A
HOME. ELIGIBLE GAINFULLY
EMPLOYED BUT THERE'S JUST NOT
ENOUGH HOMES ON THE MARKET. SO
WE ARE HAVING TO. BUILD THE
BRIDGE THIS GAP AND REDUCE THE
COST OF NEW CONSTRUCTION TO GET
MORE FAMILIES INTO HOMES BUT IN
ORDER TO DO THAT WOULD BE THAT
TAX CODE TO OF ALL. WITH THE
MODELS THAT ARE EVOLVING OVER
TIME AND WE REALLY HOPE TO HAVE
YOUR SUPPORT- FOR THIS BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW BRING IT. BACK HERE IN
THE ROOM FOR ANYONE WHO LIKE TO
ADD ON IN SUPPORT NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION PLACE.
I'M SURE MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND ITS HOUSING IS A
HUMAN RIGHT DIVISION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JERRY SMITH
HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND WILL NOW OPERATE OR GO TO
THE PHONE LINES ANYONE FROM THE
PUBLIC COULD LIKE TO WITH. A
REGISTERED SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE NAME
ORGANIZATION IMPOSITION PLEASE.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. WE'RE GONNA LINE ONE
NINETY ONE. LOOK UNDER WATER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB NINETEEN THIRTY THREE THANK
YOU. LINE ONE OH EIGHT. ALPHEN
SCHALLERT IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB NINETEEN THIRTY THREE THANK.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK OKAY
GREAT WILL BRING ABOUT HERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM. COMMITTEE. THREE
THE MOTION OF. THE MOTION BY
MISTER COLOR SECOND BY MISTER
SERCO WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE RESHAPED US SUPPORT
TODAY THANKS THANK YOU AGAIN M.
AS MR MRS FREEMAN FOR YOUR
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP IN THIS
SPACE RIGHT SHARE ADVOCAY HERE
HOW BECAUSE FOR THE BUILDING.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS WICKS I
SAY OCTOBER SATELLITE CORREO
GABRIEL GABRIEL I'D KALRA AYE
AYE KILEY QUIRK-SILVA WARD THANK
YOU ALL GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THAT BILL. IS- IT'S ON
CALL. IF ABSENT MEMBERS WITHOUT
OF MISTER BLUE. YOU'RE BACK IN
COMMITTEE. AND WE WOULD THAT
I'VE NEVER BEEN I KNOW WE WANT A
ROUSING CLOSING SPEECH FROM YOU
HERE MR BLOOM. TURNS OUT I DID
HAVE MORE BILLS I HAVE ONE MORE
AT- IT'S STILL COMING UP TO.
YEAH BEGIN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- I'M PRESENTING AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY SEVEN AND I'D
LIKE TO START BY TAKING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND ALSO
REASSURE COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT
OF MY OFFICE WILL BE WORKING AS
ALWAYS WITH THE OPPOSITION- ON-
ISSUES THAT- FRANKLY SOME OF WE
FOUND OUT THAT- AS RECENTLY AS
FRIDAY SO WE'RE- GOING TO GET TO
WORK ON THOSE. THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THE PLANET IS
GETTING WARMER AND EVERY DAY WE
HEAR ABOUT NEW RECORD HIGH
TEMPERATURES ON SEPTEMBER SIXTH
TWENTY TWENTY. THE STATE SOUGHT
NEW RECORD HIGHS ACROSS MUCH OF
THE STATE WOODLAND HILLS NOT TOO
FAR FROM MY DISTRICT SAW A HIGH
OF A HUNDRED TWENTY ONE DEGREES
RIVALING DEF ALLEY OAKLAND HAD A
HUNDRED AND TWO SAN JOSE WAS A
HUNDRED AND FIVE SANTA ANA A
HUNDRED AND TEN ESCONDIDO ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN AND BEVERLY
HILLS WHICH IS IN MY DISTRICT.
AND NOT FAR FROM THE OCEAN A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN DEGREES.
EXTREME HEAT WARNINGS ARE
BECOMING MORE COMMON AS THE
PLANET WARMS AND SEA LEVELS RISE
AND IT IS THE POOR AND ELDERLY
WHO SUFFER THE MOST. EXTREME
HEAT IS ONE OF THE DEADLIEST
CONSEQUENCES OF GLOBAL WARMING
BETWEEN TWENTY TEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN. THE HOTTEST DECADE ON
RECORD. OFFICIAL REPORTS WERE
THAT FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY
NINE PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA DIED
DUE TO HEAT EXPOSURE. HOWEVER
ACCORDING TO AN INVESTIGATION BY
THE L. A. TIMES THE ACTUAL DEATH
TOLL WAS ALMOST SIX TIMES HIGHER
THAN WHAT WAS REPORTED. TOTALING
NEARLY FOUR THOUSAND DEATHS
THESE NUMBERS WILL CONTINUE TO
GROW AS IT CONTINUES TO GET
HOTTER. EACH YEAR EXTREME HEAT
KILLS MORE AMERICANS THAN ANY
OTHER CLIMATE FUELED HAZARD.
LIKE OTHER CLIMATE CHANGE
DISASTERS EXTREME HEAT IMPACTS
THE POOR ELDERLY SICK AND VERY
ON THE MOST. STATE DATA SHOWS
THAT BLACK CALIFORNIANS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO DIE THAN THOSE OF ANY
OTHER RACE FROM HEAT. AND PEOPLE
OVER SIXTY FIVE ARE ESPECIALLY
AT RISK. PEOPLE DIE IN HOUSES
APARTMENTS AND MOBILE HOMES THAT
LACK MITIGATIONS LIKE MODERN
INSULATION COOL ROOF TECHNOLOGY
ENERGY EFFICIENT WINDOWS AIR
CONDITIONING OR EVEN SOMETHING
AS SIMPLE AS SHADE TREES. HE
DOES SOMETHING THOSE WITH
RESOURCES CAN IGNORE WELL FOR
THOSE WITHOUT RESOURCES IT IS A
THREAT TO THEIR SURVIVAL. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEGUN TO TAKE
EXTREME HEAT SERIOUSLY AND HAS
STARTED INVESTING IN PLANS AND
PROGRAMS TO HELP MITIGATE THE
IMPACTS OF EXTREME HEAT EVENTS
AND TO SAVE LIVES WHAT IS
MISSING IS A PLAN TO KEEP PEOPLE
SAFE FROM EXTREME HEAT. IN THEIR
OWN HOMES. CURRENTLY STATE
BUILDING AND HABITABILITY
STANDARDS REQUIRE THAT RENTAL
HOUSING BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN A
MINIMUM INDOOR TEMPERATURE OF
SEVENTY DEGREES. BUT SET NO
MAXIMUM TEMPERATURE. WHEN
TEMPERATURES SOAR OUTSIDE INDOOR
TEMPERATURES CAN REACH EVEN
HIGHER IN UNITS THAT LACK COOLEY
FEATURES WHILE STILL BEING
DEEMED HABITABLE UNDER THE STATE
CODE. THIS MAKES LITTLE SENSE IF
THE GOAL OF HABITABILITY
STANDARDS IS TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE
AND HEALTHY IN THEIR OWN HOMES.
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY SEVEN IS A
MEASURE THAT WILL ENSURE THAT
EVERY CALIFORNIANS LIVES IN A
SAFE AND RESILIENT HOME THAT
PROVIDES REFUGE FROM EXTREME
HEAT. IT WOULD MODERNIZE THE
STATE'S HABITABILITY CODE TO
REQUIRE THAT RENTAL UNITS CAN
MAINTAIN A SAFE INDOOR
TEMPERATURE REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER TEMPERATURES ARE
EXTREMELY COLD OR EXTREMELY HOT
. THE BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE
EVERY LANDLORD TO. FOR AND AIR
CONDITIONING OR ANYTHING ELSE
FOR THAT MATTER. INSTEAD IT
REQUIRES THE DEVELOPMENT OF
STANDARDS TO ENSURE SAFE INDOOR
AIR TEMPERATURE ON HOT DAYS BUT
LEAVES IT UP TO THE EXPERTS TO
DETERMINE HOW WE GET THERE. WHAT
IT WILL TAKE TO ACHIEVE THE
STANDARD WILL VERY BASED ON
GEOGRAPHY AND A HOST OF OTHER
FACTORS INCLUDING ENSURING
CONSISTENCY WITH STATE CLIMATE
GOALS. THE BILL DOES NOT DICTATE
ANY OF THIS BUT INSTEAD SET THE
PROCESS IN MOTION TO DEVELOP THE
STANDARDS. SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE
OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY WE'RE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE
A REASONABLE AND PRACTICAL
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING THIS
CRITICAL PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE.
AND TODAY WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE OUR
AUGUST IN PEDRO PEDRO A TENANT
AND RESIDENT OF MERCED. AND
SASHA HARNDEN WITH THE INNER
CITY LAWCENTER. AND I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S TRANSLATIONS WILL GIVE
YOU MORE TIME FOR THAT. YOU.
YEAH WHEN THE PHARMACY NUMBER OF
HOSTING BATTLE LEAVING UNLESS
YOU IN MONTANA IT ALONG AN
ACCOMPLICE. GOOD MY NAME IS
EXISTING FEDERAL PEDRO I LIVE IN
THE CITY OF MADERA AND I'M A
FARM WORKER. RENTAL OWN OWN IS
NOT ENOUGH TO THAT. THE ECONOMY
HONESTLY AND- GENTLE LOS EFECTOS
LAS. OLAS IN COLOGNE. YEAH WHEN
ONE OF. THE THAT THAT ALLOW HOME
. IN YOUR COMPANY THE MOON. KA.
AND ANOTHER MAN ON YELLOW
ENSEMBLE. IT THAT ALLOW HOPE
IT'LL- NEED TO GET A POINT OF
THIS CONFIDING ME BUT A PICASA
WHAT IT IS. HELLO MORE. DOLOR
THE- IT'LL THE HELLO STANMORE
THAN IN THE CASA. IT IS LEARN
GOING OKAY QUE ES DOLLAR. MARKET
CO BONTA. WHERE THEN CARE LIKE
US ON THIS KEY MEN WITH A VERY
THE AND- IMPORTANT BOB K. S. THE
CAR LOT FOR L. CINEREA. YOU IN
THE CITY AND EVERY SOME I FEEL
THAT OF WAVES I FROM LONG DAY OF
WORK A THE FIELD TO A HOUSE THAT
CAN GET UP TO A HIGH TWENTY
INSIDE THE- IN SO IN THE SUMMER
I ARRIVED FROM BUT I EVEN IN MY
OWN HOME BECAUSE THEY DOESN'T
ALLOW ME I'M SWEATING I FEEL
FREE LOW OF THE TIME I'VE HAD A
LOT OF HEADACHES TO THE X. HEAT
MY HOW. I'VE ASKED THE ON TWINS
ANY THAT CAN COOL THE HOW SINCE
I MOVED OF WONDER THE HE BUT HE
REFUSED. I THAT IS ON YOUR PHONE
UP A HIGH SWEET THIRTY ANNUAL
THEM WITHOUT ALONG IS B.
STRAIGHTENING NOT PLAY THE
CONSENT THAT ARE ONLY HIS
BECAUSE WITH THAT AREA. THE LAST
QUELLA. WE K. LAST MONTH FOR
THIS WILL IN THIS QUANTAL VIA
SEE THE C. FOR REPEAT THAT YOU.
THREE YEARS A COUPLE IN THERE SO
THIRD YEARS- LIVED THE HOUSE I
SEEN THE STRAW WITH THEIR
HOMEWORK THIS AND THIS AFFECTS
THE SCHOOLING- WE NOTICED THAT
THE WINDOW IN THE HAVE BEEN SEE
BY THE HILL THE LANKY. YOU GET
LAUGH. SENATE WAR TWO WEEKS TO
OKAY REVELADO YOUR LOOK AUSTIN
KILLER SEVEN TON OF THE WHAT I'M
PAID READ ON A LIGHTER THE I AYE
IN ESTAMOS FOR THE HOTTEST COME
I TOLD THE LANDLORD HE HAD TO
FOR THE WAY. BUT HE READ SO I TO
FIX IT MIGHT BUT YOU WITH THE
WINDOWS DURING THIS THEY THAT
COME IN IS AIR THIS DOES NOT
COOL YOU DOWN. LOTUS IS SIMPLE
TOWN. KID ESTABLISH. THING OWN
MICROPHONE UP SIX. THEY GET A-
DONNA LAST. WHEN YOU THE IS THEY
KNOW WHO ARE WOUNDED THE-
VATICAN OF THE- EVIDENCE. MORE
PHOTO. NO NO FOR. ME WAS WE
WE'VE.
REQUIRING ALL RENTAL UNITS TO
HAVE SOME TYPE OF COOLING
MECHANISM WE DON'T DESERVE TO
LIVE LIKE THIS WHERE YOU CAN'T
EVEN REST TO RELAX BUT YOU FEEL
EVEN WORSE THAN YOU DO OUTSIDE.
THIS BEAUTIFUL IS BEAUTIFUL
BOTTLES GET. OUR WATER UP
WHATEVER IS THE PROJECT WITHIN
THE- MEDICINE WAS THE VIDEO ON.
THE SCENTED CANDLES POLITICIAN
THE CALL LOW FIX THEM FIRED YOU
OUGHT TO PLEASE PASS THIS BILL
WE DESERVE TO LIVE IN A- CENT
HOLDER PROTECTS US FROM EXTREME
HEAT. STILL THE YOU MAYBE GOOD
AFTERNOON SASHA HUNTER WITH THE
INNER LAW CENTER A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
SEVEN- AS WE'VE HEARD HE RELATED
ILLNESS AND DEATHS HAVE
INCREASED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
IN RECENT YEARS AND STAND TO
CONTINUE INCREASING DUE TO THE
ACCELERATED FREQUENCY OF EXTREME
HEAT EVENTS. THIS ISSUE HAS
PARTICULAR IMPACTS WHERE PEOPLE
SPEND THE MOST TIME AT HOME.
HOWEVER THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT
FOR RENTAL HOMES IN CALIFORNIA
TO MAINTAIN A SAFE MAXIMUM
INDOOR TEMPERATURE. THIS FAILURE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
CHILDREN SENIORS AND THOSE WITH
PRE EXISTING HEALTH CONDITIONS
WITH THE MOST EXTREME IMPACTS IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THERE'S NO
QUESTION THIS IS A PROBLEM
EXTREME HEAT IS THE DEADLIEST
CLIMATE HAZARD AND COUNTLESS
CALIFORNIANS SUFFER FROM HEAT
RELATED ILLNESS EACH YEAR.
ELECTED LEADERS HAVE STEPPED UP
WHEN ISSUES OF HEALTH AND SAFETY
IN THE HOME PRESENT THEMSELVES.
FOR EXAMPLE THE TRAGIC TWENTY
FIFTEEN BALCONY COLLAPSE IN
BERKELEY LED TO A SERIES OF
LEGISLATION ADDRESSING ON TOWN
BUILDINGS. WE'VE ALSO SEEN
NUMEROUS LOCAL POLICIES
REQUIRING SEISMIC RETROFITS OF
SOFT STORY APARTMENTS. AND
EXTREME HEAT IS AN ISSUE THAT IS
APPROPRIATE FOR SIMILAR ACTION.
WE'VE LONG REQUIRED HEATING IN
APARTMENTS TO ENSURE A SAFE
MINIMUM TEMPERATURE HEN IT'S
COLD. THIS BILL SIMPLY CREATES A
COMPANION REQUIREMENT FOR SAFE
MAXIMUM TEMPERATURE AND RELIES
ON THE BUILDING STANDARDS
PROCESS TO DEVELOP THAT
REQUIREMENT. WHILE HUMAN SAFETY
MAKE OFFER A C. IN SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT IS NOT WHAT
THIS BILL REQUIRES FOR THE VAST
MAJORITY OF UNITS. AND A RANGE
OF CLIMATE FRIENDLY TECHNOLOGIES
LIKE WEATHER IS ATION EXIST TO
HELP ACHIEVE SAFE TEMPERATURES.
IN MANY REGIONS SIMPLE
INSTALLATION OR SHADE TREES MAY
DO THE TRICK. BUT GIVEN THE
STATEWIDE IMPACTS OF THIS ISSUE
A STATEWIDE STANDARD IS THE
RIGHT APPROACH. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO ENGAGING WITH SO THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THE
PROPER STANDARD AND THIS BILL
ALLOWS THAT PROCESS TO BEGIN. IF
WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT ADDRESSING
CLIMATE CHANGE WE CANNOT STAND
BY AS CALIFORNIANS SUFFER IN
THEIR HOMES WE URGE ARRIVA.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WITH IT
WILL GO TO SUPPORT HER IN THE
ROOM. MARINO I OR THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM WE DON'T HAVE
A POSITION ON DISPEL BUT WE DO
THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE- THAT IS PLAGUING MANY OF
OUR MOST LOW INCOME RESIDENTS IN
THE STATE. AND WE ENCOURAGE YOU
TO CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION OF
THE BILL TODAY THANKS. I KNOW
LAWLER. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION ONE OF THE
SPONSORS THE BILL AS WELL AS THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT IN
SUPPORT. UNLESS FROM ASSEMBLY
HAVE A PUBLIC ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT THANK. SIMPLY BECAUSE
THE ON BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER
LAW AND POVERTY PROUD CO SPONSOR
ALSO ADDING REMARKS FOR POLICY
LINCOLN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BRANDON COULD GET AT THE
REGIONAL ASTHMA MANAGEMENT AND
PREVENTION- ALSO CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT. RIQUELME SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA BERMAN- JUSTICE
ALLIANCE AND REGISTERING SUPPORT
FOR THE CENTER FOR COMMUNITY
ACTION AND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WITH THAT
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR FOLKS IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY SEVEN.
NAME A ORGANIZATION RECESSION.
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. FINNA GO TO
LINE ONE NINETY NINE. ROMERO
WITH CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
VOTERS FORMERLY THE LCD AND
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE TWO HUNDRED
. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
FOR LINE TWENTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JANE CAN- ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT. LINE ONE FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CARE MEMBERS GREATER NUMBER HALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
OFFICIALS- WE HAD A SUPPORT OF
COMMENDED BUT AFTER FURTHER
REVIEW WERE DISCONTINUED TO NEW
DRUGS TIME. LOOK FOR DOOR WITH
THE SPONSORS ON THE ISSUE. LINE
ONE SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS A ORTIZ ON BEHALF OF
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
COALITION AND NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL ACTION FUND IN
SUPPORT. AND THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
BRING ABOUT HERE FOR A PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IF YOU
COULD COME SET UP HERE THAT BE
GREAT. TWO MINUTES EACH.
WHICH GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CORNELIUS BURKE- WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION I WILL BE EXTREMELY
BRIEF- WE ARE STRONG AND- IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY SEVEN FOR THE
FOLLOWING FOR REASONS NUMBER ONE
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY SEVEN
CIRCUMVENTS THE STATE REGULATORY
PROCESS FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS A
STATE LEGISLATURE HAS AVOIDED
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF BUILDING
CODES AND STATUTES INSTEAD OF
DIRECTING EIGHT CD AND THE
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION TO
INVESTIGATE THIS ISSUE AND A
TERMINAL FOR REGULATORY ACTION
IS NEEDED AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
SEVEN LEAPS OVER THE MINISTER
PROCESS AND MANDATES A CD TO
DEVELOP. AND THE BUILDING SOUNDS
COMMISSION TO ADOPT MANDATORY
BUILDING STAF TO A CAR AC IN
EXCESS AND BIT INTO WELL UNITS
NUMBER TWO THIS BILL HAS A LOT
OF TECHNICAL IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES RETROFITTING AN OLD
DWELLING UNIT WITH A COOLING
UNIT TO MEET THIS NEW CODE IS
NOT A SIMPLE MATTER FOR EXAMPLE
MANY APARTMENTS ARE NOT DESIGN-
TO ALLOW FOR CENTRAL AC ALSO WE
HAVE A LOT OF CUSTOM HOME
BUILDERS AND ARE. A MAGIC YOU
WANT TO REDUCE OUR CO TWO
EMISSIONS YOU WANT TO REDUCE
YOUR ENERGY USAGE ANYONE TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF WINDOWS AND NATURAL
AIR AND BREEZE THIS BILL REQUIRE
YOU TO HAVE INDOOR AC. NUMBER
THREE. WE HAVEN'T REALLY STUC
THE- ON MY TOLD BILLS. THE COST
RUN A- IS A SINGLE GREATEST USE
OF ENERGY AND A HOME ESPECIALLY
DURING THE PEAK LOAD TIME
PERIOD. THE IMPACT OF MONTHLY
BUDGETS- ENERGY CALLS NEEDS TO
BE FULLY EXAMINED. I JUST LOST A
NUMBER FOR WHEN YOU REALLY
STUDY. THIS THE BILL'S IMPACT ON
OUR EXISTING ELECTRICITY GRID.
IT'S GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF
SIGNIFICANT LOAD AND DEMAND SO
THE GRID THAT'S A RODGER FRAGILE
DURING PEAK DEMAND PERIODS SO WE
NEED TO REALLY THINK ABOUT WHAT
THIS BILL WOULD DO TO LITERACY.
FOR THESE REASONS AND MORE CBRE
THE HOMEBUILDING INDUSTRY AS
OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
SEVEN WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO
VOTE TODAY BUT WILL ALWAYS ENJOY
CONTINUE CONVERSATION WITH
AUTHOR. THANK YOU. I DEBRA
CARLTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION I DON'T
WANT TO REPEAT ALL THE WORDS
THAT MR AT. THE CORNELIUS TOLD
YOU TODAY BUT I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT WE WOULD
LIKE THE REGULATORY PROCESS TO
CONSIDER IS- THAT MANY OLD
BUILDINGS DO NOT- ARE NOT GOOD
FOR RETROFIT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT DOES TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT VARIABLES THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM OUTLINED.
AND OF COURSE THE FINAL
CONSIDERATION SHOULD BE THE
REVIEW OF AREAS OF THE STATE
THAT STILL MAY NOT REQUIRE OR
HAVE THE NEED FOR. A COOLING SO
WITH THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NOBLE
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE
WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO TO I
BELIEVE THERE'S AN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINES. OR IN PERSON IN
PERSON. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
RUN KINGSTON I REPRESENT SEVERAL
ASSOCIATIONS THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION
PACIFIC SOUTHWEST THE AFFORDABLE
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
ORANGE COUNTY AND THE EAST BAY
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION OR- WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINE IF WE CAN GET HIM ON
THE LINE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS PLACE.
YES SAYS- GOOD MORNING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON RATHER- MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS- TO COLORADO BY
PROCEED. PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
CHAIR I APPRECIATE IT- CREAM
GREASY ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS- HERE
TODAY IN OPPOSITION- TO AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY SEVEN- AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY SEVEN
UNFORTUNATELY IMPOSES IN
OXBRIDGE RETROACTIVE RETROFIT
STANDARD ON SMALL HOUSING
PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
MOST CONCERNING IS THAT THE
PROPOSED STANDARD IS UNDEFINED
SO IN THE COOLING TRANSPORTATION
ORDERS THE TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR AC UNIT NEED TO BE
INSTALLED- SMALLHAUSEN GRIDER
STILL RECOVERING FROM THE
PANDEMIC SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES. NECESSARY
TO COMPLY WITH THE ON
REQUIREMENTS THE BILL AS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY SEVEN LACKS
SPECIFICITY THEREBY CREATING
UNCERTAINTY FOR SMALL HOUSING
PROVIDERS WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS ON THIS
MEASURE HOWEVER UNFORTUNATELY IS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED SEE
THAT'S RESPECTFULLY REQUESTED NO
COAT ON AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU. SO MUCH. THANK
YOU NOT BRING IT BACK THE ROOM
ANYWAY WISHED ADD ON. IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL HERE IN
PERSON. OKAY OPERATOR WE CAN GO
TO THE PHONE LINES ANYONE WISH
AT ON OPPOSITION ON THE PHONES
FOR AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY SEVEN
JUST NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION
PLACE. WE WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS TO THEIR
OFFICE. THEN GO TO LINE. ONE
FOUR. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS KATE TOWN BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION AND DEPARTMENT
THIRTY XIN OF GREATER L. ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. FIND.
NINETY EIGHT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS REX W. HARM ON THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION ALSO PLANS THANK YOU
. ONE ONE EIGHTY EIGHT. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS PAT MORAN WITH
THEIR AND RITA SOCIUS
REPRESENTING THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE IS
SIGNALED THEY WISH TO SPEAK OKAY
THANK YOU WILL BRING ABOUT CARE
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS. FOR THE AUTHOR. HE
WAS CARILLO NO NO QUESTIONS TO
THE AUTHOR AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH
THE OPPOSITION TO GET TO A
RESOLUTION. IF I MAY JUST SEE A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS IN SPANISH. A
SENIOR GIVING ALL EXCEPT THIS
THE LAWYER- A LITTLE AS GOOD US
YES BORDER MAY NEED BORDERS THAT
IKEA THEN COPY HILL BY UP WITH
WILL THAT FOR LESS FOR MEDIA THE
A LOT THEM TO STAY EVEN. IF HE-
THE I COULD ALMOST A LITTLE SO
DON THEY WILL GET SONIC ONE
CABLE WALK WILL GET CLOSE TO.
SINGLE OPEN OTHER POLITICALLY A
KEY COPY OKAY ONE AND IF HE
STILL. BETTER ACCOMMODATE BUT I%
CAN'T. OF POLITICAL LIST OF
IMPORTANT THE A CASSETTE GUESS
WHO. CISCO CHECK. GET THE MEAT
NAME OF THE PERSON CEILING OKAY
THOSE AND STYLE. IN THE IN THE-
LOW THEY MUST SEE FOR LOW. AKA
THE- THOSE FROM- MATHIS AS HE
DOES A C. K. WHICH IS HAS
PURSUED THIS. EVM BENEATH. THANK
YOU. AND THE DO WE HAVE A MOTION
. OF MOTION I MISSED SECOND BY
MY- AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CALL
MISTER THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
I'LL BE BRIEF- LET ME FOR POINT
OUT- THE BILL DOESN'T REQUIRE.
INDOOR AIR. THIS BILL SETS IN
PRAGUE. SAID IN MOTION A- TO
DETERMINE A NEW HABITABILITY
STANDARD THAT TAKES INTO
CONSIDERATION EXTREME HEAT MUCH
IN THE WAY CURRENT HABITABILITY
STANDARDS TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION EXTREME COLD- DOES
IT COST MONEY TO. MAKE SURE THAT
HOUSES UGH- ARE ABLE TO ACHIEVE
AT LEAST SEVENTY DEGREES WHEN IT
COMES TO A LOW TEMPERATURE YES
COST MONEY TO PUT INSULATION IN
THE HOME BUT THAT'S REQUIRED
TODAY SO THE- BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION WOULD BE CHARGED WITH
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF GOING
THROUGH A PROCESS. TO DETERMINE
WHAT THE RIGHT ANSWER START TO
DETERMINE- YOU KNOW- IS THERE
GOING TO BE A BURDEN ON THE
ELECTRICAL GRID CERTAINLY
SOMETHING WORTHY TO TAKE
CONSIDERATION OF BUT NOT TODAY
NOT IN THIS BILL. RETROFITTING
INDEED- IS NOT EASY AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT THIS COMMISSION
WOULD NEED TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION IN DETERMINING ITS
STANDARDS. AS I SAID WILL
CONTINUE TO TALK WITH OPPOSITION
AND- COME TO AGREEMENT WHEREVER
POSSIBLE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM I KNOW- ARE LOWER
INCOME COMMUNITIES ARE GONNA
ONES THAT FEEL THE BURDEN BURDEN
MORE CLIMATE CHANGE THAN
WEALTHIER FOLKS- JUST BECAUSE OF
THE INEQUITIES THAT EXIST ACROSS
THE BOARD WHICH OF COURSE IS
HARSH AND IMPACT COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. SO I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
I'M OTHER STATE WANT YOU TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OPPOSITION
OTHERS I KNOW YOU WELCHER VERY
TOUGH AUTHORED WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO. HELP SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY AND SEE IT OUT OF
COMMITTEE IF WE CAN'T. ZERO MORE
. TO PASSAGE AMENDED THE
COMEDIAN PROJECT AN
APPROPRIATION. WICKS FIVE WEEKS
ICRP. CARILLO I APRIL KALRA
KILEY QUIRK-SILVA SCORED. THAT
BILLS ON COFFEE THANKS MISTER
BUMP THANK QUIRK-SILVA SHOULD
KIMBER COKE IS AN I GREAT. NEXT
UP WE HAVE MISTER TO WITH TWO A. TWENTY TWO ELEVEN TWO THREE
FIFTY SEVEN. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRS OPEN TO BEING BEGIN WITH
AB TWENTY TWO ELEVEN IF THAT'S
OKAY. SURE SO ME JUST TOUGH
THANK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS- FOR THE AMENDMENTS
WERE HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
THE SUNSET DATE OF TWENTY TWENTY
SIX- MY UNDERSTANDING IS WORKING
WITH OUR OFFICE WE'RE GOING TO
EXTEND THAT TO TWENTY THIRTY
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY THIRTY
THAT'S CORRECT THANK YOU- TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT BETWEEN TWENTY ONE
BUILT UPON MY WORK ON OUR
SHELTER CRISIS AS- WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT ALL MORNING- THE
COMMITTEES TO TALK ABOUT THE-
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN IN. THE BILL- DOES A NUMBER
OF THINGS TO EXPAND OUR WORK ON
THE SHELTER CRISIS ACTS OF THE
PAST THE EXTENT TO THIRTY TO
TWENTY THIRTY. IT DECLARES ANY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AS A POPULATION
UNSHELTERED HOMELESS. TO TOTAL
HOMELESS POPULATION GREATER THAN
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE EXCLUDING
CALIFORNIA BE INITIAL TO CRISIS
WITHOUT WAY- LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CAN AUTOMATICALLY OPT INTO A
SHELTER. IT EXTENDS THE BUILDING
STANDARDS ACCORDING TO THE
DOCTOR CRISIS OUT TO SHELTERS
LOCATED ON PRIVATE PROPERTY- AND
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S JUST EASIER.
EASIER TO USE AND ALSO. TO- MAKE
SURE. THAT WE EXPAND THIS TO
PRIVATE PROPERTY JUST PUBLIC
PROPERTY AS AMENDED THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRES LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO DEVELOP A PLAN
TO DEMONSTRATE HOW RESIDENTS OF
EMERGENCY SHELTERS WILL BE
TRAINS AND- TO PERMANENT.
HOUSING WITH ME OR TO INCIDENT-
AND THEY'RE GONNA TALK BOUT THE
BILL AND CREATE YOUR- SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANG MY NAME'S
ADRIAN COVERT AND WITH THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL BEAR COUNCILS PROUD
TO CO SPONSOR AB TWENTY TWO
ELEVEN. AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY CALIFORNIA
IS IN A SHELTER CRISIS
CALIFORNIA IS HOME 212% OF ALL
AMERICANS. 29% OF ALL HOMELESS
AMERICANS AND 53% OF ALL
UNSHELTERED HOMELESS AMERICANS
MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR TO
CALIFORNIA'S LARGE UNSHELTERED
POPULATION IS IT'SINSUFFICIENT
INVENTORY OF EMERGENCY SHELTERS.
CALIFORNIA PROVIDES JUST THREE
BEDS FOR EVERY TEN HOMELESS
RESIDENTS LESS THAN ANY OHER
STATE IN THE UNITED STATES AND
FAR BELOW THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
SEVEN AND A HALF BEDS PER TEN.
GIVEN CALIFORNIA'S SIZE IT
WEIGHS DOWN THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
WHEN INCLUDED TO SIX POINT TWO
BEDS OUT OF TEN. THESE THIS
IMBALANCE HAS ONLY GROWN WORSE
OVER THE PAST DECADE
CALIFORNIA'S UNSHELTERED
HOMELESS POPULATION INCREASED
57% SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN. YET
OUR INVENTORY OF EMERGENCY
SHELTERS INCREASED JUST 6%
SHELTER IS A BASIC HUMAN NEED
WITHOUT WHICH OUR HEALTH
DECLINES RAPIDLY. UNSHELTERED
HOMELESSNESS IS ASSOCIATED WITH
INCREASED RISK OF CHRONIC
DISEASES INCLUDING PULMONARY
DISEASE. HYPERTENSION DIABETES
AND INFECTIOUS DISEASES LIKE
HEPATITIS A AND INCREASED RISK
OF PHYSICAL ASSAULT SEXUAL
ASSAULT AN ACCIDENTAL DEATH BY
REDUCING BUREAUCRATIC BARRIERS.
TO EXPANDING EMERGENCY SHELTERS
AB TWENTY TWO ELEVEN WILL HELP
EXPAND ACCESS TO BASIC SHELTER
AND SANITATION THE CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESS RESIDENTS AND BRING
CALIFORNIA SHELTER INVENTORY
CLOSER INTO LINE WITH THE
NATIONAL. THANK YOU FOR TAKING
MY COMMENTS AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR VOTE. THE YOU VERY
MUCH YOU CAN BEGIN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANK YOU-
ASSEMBLY TANG MY NAME IS PETER I
DO AM THE ASSISTANT TO THE CITY
MAN WITH CITY OF BERKELEY I'M
HERE TO WIN MAYOR ERROR AGAIN
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY TWO ELEVEN
AND TO GIVE YOU A REAL LIFE
EXAMPLE FOR HOW THIS BILL WOULD
HAVE HELPED US IN BERKELEY IN
TWENTY NINETEEN HAD IT BEEN WHAT
THE TIME. I SOME TWENTY NINETEEN
WE WERE APPROACHED BY FRED FINCH
YOU SERVICES WHICH IS A NON
PROFIT SERVING- TRANSITION AGE
YOUTH THEY OWNED AND OPERATED A
TWELVE BED TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PROGRAM IN SOUTH BERKELEY- AND
AT THE TIME THEIR BOARD HAD MADE
THE DETERMINATION THAT
CONTINUING TO OPERATE THAT
PROGRAM WAS N LONGER
FINANCIALLY OR ADMINISTRATIVELY
VIABLE FOR THEM. AND THEY WERE
LOOKING TO SELL THE PROPERTY IN
TRANSITION THE PROGRAM TO
ANOTHER A NON PROFIT FORTUNATELY
THEY HAD IDENTIFIED A WILLING
BUYER IN COVENANT HOUSE
CALIFORNIA IS THAT ANOTHER
NONPROFIT SERVING TRANSITION AGE
YOUTH AT THE TIME THEY OPERATED
. BED EMERGENCY SHELTER FOR
YOUTH EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
IN BERKELEY AND D. AT LEAST ON
THAT SHELTER WAS EXPIRING AND
THEY WERE OUT WE AT RISK OF
BEING DISPLACED IN ORDER FOR THE
DEAL TO PENCIL OUT FOR KEPT
COVENANT HOUSE THEY PROPOSED AN
INTERIOR RENOVATION TO THE
BUILDING THAT WOULD. ADDED THE
THIRTY BED SHELTER IN ADDITION
TO MAINTAINING THE TWELVE BED
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM. AT
THE TIME THE PERSON IN QUESTION
WAS OWNED RESIDENTIAL IN
BERKELEY THE EXISTING ZONING
PERMITS DID NOT ALLOW FOR MORE
THAN TWELVE DADS AND OF COURSE
CHANGING THE PARCEL'S ZONING
WOULD HAVE BEEN A WINKY
DISCRETIONARY PROCESS THAT WE
SIMPLY DID NOT HAVE THE TIME FOR
GIVEN THE EXPIRING WEEKS THAT I
MENTIONED- BECAUSE THIS PROPERTY
WAS NEITHER LEAST NOR OWNED BY
THE CITY. WE UNFORTUNATELY HAD
NO IN FORTY UNDER EXISTING
LAUNDRY DISS AND SHELTER CRISIS
LAW TO INVOKE A CRISIS TO WAIVE
STRICT COMPLIANCE WITH THE
ZONING RESTRICTIONS EVEN THOUGH
A CITY FUNDED HOMELESS PROGRAM
HAD BEEN OPERATING THERE FOR
LITERALLY DECADES WHEN STAFF
BROUGHT THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE THE
COUNCIL NEIGHBORHOOD OPPOSITION
WAS QUITE FIERCE AND ULTIMATELY.
PROJECT BURKE WE LOST. THOSE
THIRTY DAD'S. HELLO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS A REAL I THINK.
OF COMMONSENSE PRY. THAT CANNOT
BE. AND EXPEDITED UNDER CURRENT
STATE LAW. EXISTIR EXISTING
SHELTER CRISIS BILL WOULD NOT-APPLIED. NORWOOD EIGHTY ONE OF
ONE WOULD HAVE HELPED BECAUSE
THAT LIES VERY. NARROWLY APPLIED
ONLY TO NAVIGATION CENTERS. AND
IN COMMERCIAL OR MIX AND MULTI
FAMILY ZONING DISTRICTS. THIS IS
WHERE AB TWENTY TWO ELEVEN WOULD
HAVE HELPED US WOULD HAVE
ALLOWED US TO WAIVE STRICT
COMPLIANCE WITH ZONING ON THE
PRIVATE PARCEL. AND IT WOULD
ALLOW US TO. APPLY THE SAME
EMERGENCY HOUSING STANDARDS
INITIALLY PROMULGATED AFTER
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY TWO. TO THAT
PRIVATE PARCEL- SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ON BEHALF OF MAYOR
DEAN REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING
ABOUT FOR ANYONE WHO ARE ONCE A
SUPPORT. MANAGER MEMBERS RANDY
MARTIN ON BEHALF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND ITS
HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT
DIVISION IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HOWEVER MANY
DAYS THIS FLIGHT HAS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF CIVIC WELL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEVADA
MERRIMAN AND PET HOUSING IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OPERATOR IF
YOU COULD OPEN THE PHONE LINES
FOR THE PUBLIC AROUND EXPRESSING
SUPPORT ON AB TWENTY TWO ELEVEN
. FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO. EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY TWO
ELEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. BENEGAL REMIND ONE NINETY
KILL. MICHAEL IT WAS FOR A BILL
SPONSORED STRONG SUPPORT. FIND
TO- FOR. I WANT TO TELL MY
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
REDWOOD CITY IN SUPPORT. ONE
TWENTY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS JANE CAN AROUND OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
RENNSPORT. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
. THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK
HERE IN THE ROOM FOR ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANYONE
IN THE ROOM LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAD
OPPOSITION FILE REGULAR HERE TO
THE DYESS- ANY ABOUT BOTH- FIRST
MISS KOREA THAN ITS QUIRK-SILVA
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS BILL- FOR THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THAT MAY BE LISTENING
I'M SURPRISED TO NOT SEE THE
CITY OF LA IN SUPPORT OR IN
CONVERSATION OF THIS BILL.
PRIMARILY BECAUSE IN THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES WE HAVE PERHAPS THE
MOST NEED BASED ON NUMBERS. WE
ALSO HAVE A SKID ROW WE KNOW
THAT OUR SHELTERS ARE OVER
IMPACTED AND NEED MORE RESOURCES
AND WE CLEARLY NEED SUPPORT. SO
THANK YOU TO THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL AND FOR YOUR REGION IN
PARTICULAR FOR TAKING THIS ON
AND I JUST WOULD HOPE. THAT THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES ENGAGES IN
SOME WAY THANK YOU. A PUBLIC
ADJUSTER QUICKLY AFTER THAT SO
SB NINE THIRTY TWO WAS MY
ORIGINAL BILL WHICH I WENT A
COUPLE CITIES IN THE CITY OF LA
WAS PART OF THAT BILL- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THEY HAVE- USE
DROPPED IT INTO USE THAT BILL IN
THE PAST AND SO- MY- JUST
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT LISTED I
WOULDN'T TAKE THAT AS THEY'RE
NOT SUPPORTIVE THEY THEY'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
MY- PREVIOUS BILLS AND THIS IS
JUST AN EXPANSION OF THAT. THANK
YOU MISS QUIRK-SILVA. I'M JUST
YES I SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
THANK YOU I IT AGAIN IT BRINGS
BACK ARE WE USING THE HAMMER OR
THE CARROT. AND LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES WANT US TO USE
THE CARROT EXCEPT FOR THE
PROBLEM IS THAT. THEY DON'T
RESPOND AND WE HAVE BEEN HERE
NOW YEAR AFTER YEAR. SEEN
MINISTER PELONIS PUSH OFF THEIR
HOMELESS FROM ONE CITY TO
ANOTHER WHICH IS NOT ACCEPTABLE
BUT THEN FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY
WHICH IS IN EVEN MORE ACCEPTABLE
SO UNACCEPTABLE. AND SOMETIMES
EVEN ORGANIZATIONS- THAT ARE
TRYING TO DO SOMETHING AS A NON
PROFIT- THE CITY'S WILL FIND
WAYS TO KEEP THEM FROM EVEN
DOING THAT WORK SO THIS IS
ESSENTIAL AS I'VE MENTIONED
BEFORE IT'S IT SHOULD BE A
TEMPORARY- A SCENARIO FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS- BUT NOT A THREE OR
FOUR YEAR STAY BUT ALL OF THIS-
FITS TOGETHER WITH ONE PIECE
AFFECTING ANOTHER BUT I
CERTAINLY AGAIN AS A LOCAL.
REPRESENTATIVE I DON'T
NECESSARILY LIKE THE STATE
TELLING LOCALS WHAT TO DO BUT ON
THE OTHER HAND IF YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO ACT AND WEAKENS SEE A
PROBLEM. INCREASING BEFORE OUR
EYES WE HAVE NO OTHER SOLUTION
THEN TO ACT SO I SUPPORT THIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND- DELIVER MOTION. OF MOSTLY-
MOVED IT AND MISS QUIRK-SILVA
SECOND IT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE UP JUST DURABLY APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUES FROM
FULLER TEN I THINK THIS GIVES
THE LOCALS- ANOTHER TOOL I KNOW
OFTENTIMES WE'RE ALWAYS DEBATING
TEMPORARY SHELTER FIRST
PERMANENT SHELTER I THINK WE
NEED TO DO MORE OF BOTH. WHICH I
KNOW IT'S BEEN DEBATED IN THIS
COMMITTEE FOR THE LAST FEW
YEARS- SO THIS THIS THIS WILL
MAKE IT EASIER FOR CITIES LIKE
BERKELEY TO REALLY WORK WITH
THEIR NON PROFITS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY CAN PRESERVE THEIR BEDS BUT
ALSO EXPAND THEIR BEDS AND IT'S
GREAT TO HAVE YOU KNOW HAVE THIS
HAVE A REAL. REAL LIFE EXAMPLE I
KNOW THERE ARE MANY OTHERS ALL
ACROSS THE STATE SO WITH THAT
RESPECT ESTRADA THANK YOU AND
HAVE IT IS FOR THE BILL OF
COMMITTEES TODAY AND WITH THAT
YOU CAN TAKE THE REAL QUESTION
IS TO PASS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMPETE. AGAINST WICKS
HI I SEYARTO CORREO. I GAVE REAL. KALRA KILEY. COURT THANKS TO I
BOARD. AT THAT BILLS ON CALL AND
MR TANG CAN MOVE ON TO A TWENTY
TH FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU SO-
AB. TWENTY THREE FIFTY SEVEN IS
JUST MORE OF A CLARIFYING BILL
BILLS UPON MY BILL- OUTINGS
TEETH TO THE SURPLUS LANDS ACT
THAT YOU AS YOU KNOW THE SURPLUS
LANDS AS ONE OF OUR- TOOLS
THAT'S BEEN UNDER UTILIZED TO
BUILD MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
THIS BILL WILL CLOSE LOOPHOLES
FOR LANDS THAT ARE LEAST AND
OTHER SWEETHEART DEALS. IT ALSO
PROVIDES NEW STREAMLINING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO COMPLY WITH THE
SURPLUS TRANSACT AND ENSURES
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE NOT
OVERLY BURDENED WITH
BUREAUCRATIC PROCESSES TO FILL
PROVISIONS OF THE SURPLUS LANDS
ACT WITHOUT- WE HAVE TO. TO
WITNESSES HERE. MISTER DÍAS FROM
N. AND MR GUSTER FROM THE PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW PROJECT. FIVE YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ON PROCESSED
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN ON BEHALF OF
THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OR THE CALIFORNIA.
I'LL BE BRIEF- AFFORD HOUSING
BUILDERS AND COMMUNITY GROUPS
ACROSS THE STATE HAVE LONG
CHAMPIONED THE USE OF PUBLIC
LAND FOR THE PUBLIC GOOD. AND US
ALLIES ARE KEY TOOLS ADVANCED
MISSION WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
THE GOOD WORK OF OUR AUTHOR AND
HIS STAFF TO IMPROVE THE ACT.
AND IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TO HELP
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS FIND
STABLE HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES AND
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. THANKS GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
PROGRESS ON BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW PROJECT ONE OF THE
CO SPONSORS OF THE MEASURE
APPRECIATE MR KING'S LEADERSHIP
ON THIS AND ONCE AGAIN
STRENGTHENING THIS IMPORTANT
AREA OF THE LAW TO MAKE MORE
SITES AVAILABLE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE WOULD URGE AN AYE
VOTE. AND I UNDERSTAND YOUR
BIRTHDAY TODAY. NO MAYBE WE'LL
GET THE BILL OUT OF COMMITTEE
THANK YOU YEAH THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. OF WITH THAT HERE- MORE
FOLKS LIKE I DON'T IN SUPPORT
OUR STAIRS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT
OF BRIAN AUGUSTA'S BIRTHDAY AND
THE- NEVADA MERRIMAN THE DEPEND
HOUSING AND SUPPORT. MARKET
STUDY ON BEHALF OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. ON THIS
FROM ASSEMBLY HAVE A PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU KNOW OPERATOR OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY SEVEN. THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
TWENTY THREE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS. ONE THEN ZERO. NO ONE IS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
OKAY THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK HERE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. ANYONE IN THE
ROOM LIKE TO ADD ON. ME TO USE
IN OPPOSITION. WELL AS OPERATOR
ANY OPPOSITION FOLKS ON THE ON
THE LINE WHICH EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY THREE
FIFTY SEVEN. ONE WISH TO SPEAK
IN UP THIS PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THERE ARE. THERE IS NO ONE OKAY
BRING IT BACK HERE FOR OUR
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR. TO THE MOTION. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND AND WITH
THAT MR TEAM WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
THE OUR LATEST CHANGE A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WHEN NO THE SURPLUS
LANDS AT BECAUSE WORKING I'VE
GOTTEN CALLS FROM. ALMOST EVERY
YEAR MANY CITIES MANY DEVELOPERS
ALL AROUND THE STATE WONDERING
HOW THEY NEED TO COMPLY WITH THE
SURPLUS LINES LIKE WHICH
IRONICALLY HAS BEEN AROUND FOR
DECADES AND SO WE KNOW THAT WHAT
WE DID A COUPLE YEARS BECAUSE
ACTUALLY WORKING FORCING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BEING
PRIORITIZED SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES HELP
IN THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT TODAY
RESPECT THAT'S **** UP. THANK
YOU APPRECIATE YOUR WORK IN-
TRYING TO MAKE. THE SERVICE
LANDS LIKE WORK BETTER FOR
EVERYONE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY. WITH THAT PLEASE
TAKE ROLE. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS WICKS I. I
SEYARTO CORREO. I APRIL KALRA
KILEY QUIRK-SILVA. EXABYTE WARD
. THAT'S ON CALL THANK YOU
MISTER KING HAPPY BIRTHDAY BROWN. WE ARE LOOKING FOR AUTHORS IF
ANY AUTHORS ARE MEMBERS ARE
WATCHING STAFFER WATCHING PLEASE
SEND YOUR BOSSES DOWN HERE TO
PRESENT BILLS. I BELIEVE WE HAVE
NINE MORE BILLS 2%
WHAT WILL OPEN THE ROLE HERE FOR
WAS IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINETEEN
NINETY THREE TO DO SO ADAMS.
NINE NINE AND THIS WAS ON CALL
ME YEAH HER. MISTER MISCREANT
WHENEVER. IT'S CLEAR NATURAL
AMOUNT OF THIS IS DONE- A- I
NUMBER SEVEN A. B. NINE THIRTY
THREE- PUBLIC AND THIS WAS TO
PASS OUT TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO IS A YES. AND THAT'S
FIVE ZERO THAT'S OUT IN MULTIPLE
KEEP IT OPEN AGAIN THANK YOU
MISS CREE OF. PLEASE GO AHEAD
AND YES PLEASE THANK YOU
QUIRK-SILVA. AN ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB NINETEEN THIRTY THREE.
IS THAT A YES YEAH YEAH THAT
WOULD BE THE SIX ZERO OKAY. WITH
THAT SALAD. SEE I SAID THERE'S A
SOLID IN THE LAST.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO I'M RECESSED
NOW RECONVENE AT ONE THIRTY
CROSS THE HALL SO EVERYONE GETS
A LITTLE BIT OF A BREAK. THANKS
EVERYONE.
NOW I THINK. FROM THE BEGINNING
. YEAH WILL TAKE FROM THE
BEGINNING. RIGHT SIX EVERY READY. I AM NUMBER ONE KILEY. KILEY I
QUIRK-SILVA SHE'S NOT HERE.
NUMBER ITEM NUMBER Q. SEYARTO HI
THERE.
SIX HAS NOT BEEN OKAY AND NUMBER
SEVEN AB NINETEEN THIRTY THREE-
SEPTEMBER KILEY. KILEY IS I.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD IS NOT HERE
- NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY NINETY
SEVEN CARILLO. KILEY KILEY.
NINETEEN FORTY. FROM SORRY
PLEASE BEAR WITH ME NUMBER- ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
ELEVEN. SEYARTO I'D SAY R. I.
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY I.
WARD SO THAT I AM THE SIX ZERO.
I'M ITEM NUMBER- FIFTEEN. YEAH.
HOUSING COMMITTEE IS BACK IN
SESSION. RIGHT I'M SORRY AGAIN
OUR ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY SEVEN- US
SEYARTO NO CYRANO GABRIEL
CHOLERA KALRA I. KILEY KILEY NOT
LAURIE WARD. HE. SORRY SIXTEENTH
AT EIGHT ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY SEVEN OF ZERO
. ZERO NO- GABRIEL KALRA KALRA
AYE KILEY KILEY I. WARD. ZERO
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO I KNOW THERE WE NEED
TO- I BELIEVE YOU WE NEED TO ADD
TO THE ARKANSAS CALENDAR-
CONSENT CALENDAR ARE YOU BELIEVE
LET ME SEE WHERE I HAVE GOT
HIDING. ALL RIGHT- WE HAD DIED
ITEMS NUMBER TEN TWENTY SIXTY
EIGHT DIED ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN
TWENTY FIVE NINETY TWO AND ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN TWENTY SIX
NINETY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY. HI
AS A MATTER QUIRK-SILVA. HERE.
ALL RIGHT THAT BRINGS US TO ITEM
NUMBER. WELLFLEET NUMBER OKAY SO
WE'RE GONNA RENOUNCE A CALLING
NUMBER- FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE
WITNESSES THEY WANT TO CALL IN-
TO- WEIGH IN ON ON THE ANY OF
THE BILLS THAT WE HAVE THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE ONE TWO SIX AGAIN
877-692-8957 AND THEN THE ACCESS
CODE OF ONE THREE ONE FIVE ONE
TWO SIX YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. SO THAT BRINGS US TO
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB TWO
THOUSAND TO. BE APPROVED BY.
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS FOR
SOMEONE I THINK YOU AND THANK
YOU IN THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE. AND
THE SPONSORS ON IMPROVING THE
MEASURE. I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT IS REQUIRED TO
INSPECT PARKS TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF ALL RESIDENTS IN THE-
IN THE PARK BY ISSUING HEALTH
AND SAFETY CITATIONS TO
RESIDENTS. AND OWNERS. IF A
RESIDENT FAILS TO CORRECT A
VIOLATION AFTER SIXTY DAYS THE
PARK OWNER TO USE IN PERCY'S
WHAT IS CALLED A NOTICE. TO
SUSPEND A PERMIT TO OPERATE
WHICH MEANS THAT THE PARK MAY
LOSE A LOT A ABILITY TO COLLECT
RENT FROM EVERY SPACE IN THE
PARK. UNLESS THE VIOLATION IS
CORRECTED WITHIN THIRTY DAYS
WHICH CURRENTLY MEANS EVICTIONS
. THE BILL DOES DOES TWO THINGS
FIRST IT CREATES A MECHANISM FOR
THE H. C. D. TO CREATE A NEW
GRANT FUND TO PROVIDE FUNDS FOR
THOSE THAT CAN'T. A FOR TO FIX A
VIOLATION THAT THAT COULD
ENDANGER THE LIVES OF THE
RESIDENTS THE NEIGHBORS AND HE
EVEN SURROUNDING CITIES. THINK
THINKING FIRE PRONE AREAS SECOND
THE BILL STATES- BILL STATES
THAT THE THAT A PERMIT TO
OPERATE WON'T BE. WON'T BE
SUSPENDED FOR THE RESIDENTS
VIOLATION HOWEVER I DID ACCEPTED
MOVEMENTS TO NARROW THE SCOPE OF
CITATIONS THAT COULD JEOPARDIZE
HEALTH SAFETY AND LIFE. FINALLY
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS BUDGET
INCLUDED FIFTY MILLION FOR
SIMILAR PROGRAMS TO ASSIST
RESIDENTS AND IT SEEMS TO MAKE
SENSE TO ALSO PUT A SUBSTANCE OF
AB. TWENTY ZERO ZERO TWO INTO
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL TO EXPEDITE
HELP TO KEEP RESIDENTS IN THEIR
HOMES. WITH ME TODAY TESTIFYING
SUPPORT OF AB TWO ZERO ZERO TWO.
CHRIS WAS GOSSIPY LEVINE YES
OKAY SORRY WITH WITH WESTERN
MANUFACTURING HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION AND SHE
SAID I KURT REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA MOBILE PARK ALLIANCE
. RIGHT AND THIS IS MAY PROCEED
TWO MINUTES EACH THANK YOU HAVE
A NUMBER GIVEN THE OUR WILL KEEP
IT SHORT- GOOD AFTERNOON MR VICE
CHAIR HAS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON CHRIS WYSOCKI WITH
WESTERN MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION. AND
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR INTRODUCING
AB TWO THOUSAND TWO. RESIDENTS
DESERVE TO LIVE IN THIS
COMMUNITY WHEREVER EVERY
RESIDENT ABIDES BY THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY RULES AND THE RULES
OF THE PARK. THAT WAY EVERYONE
IS ASSURED SAFE COMMUNITIES AND
THAT ARE FREE FROM HAZARDS.
FORTUNATELY A LOT OF RESIDENTS
AREN'T BEING ADDRESSED FOR
NUMBER OF REASONS INCLUDING TWO.
AND INCLUDING NOT BEING ABLE TO
AFFORD THE REPAIRS. THIS BILL IS
MEANT TO ADDRESS THIS BY
CREATING A PROGRAM ADMINISTERED
BY HCD TO ALLOW RESIDENTS TO
ACCESS FUNDS TO FIX HEALTH AND
SAFETY ISSUES. IN ORDER TO AVOID
POSSIBLE INFECTION DUE TO NON
COMPLIANCE IN AND SAFE HAZARDOUS
CONDITIONS. THIS BILL CREATES
THE MOBILE HEAD MOBILE HOME
REPAIR GRANTS FUND AND WILL
ENABLE OUR RESIDENTS TO ACCESS
THESE FUNDS. THAT RESIDENTS CAN
AFFORD TO FIX WITH THE STATE
SURPLUS THAT WE HAVE FOCUSING A
MINIMAL AMOUNT COULD GO A LONG
WAY TOWARDS HELPING RESIDENTS
KEEP ROOFS OVER THEIR HEADS. IN
ADDITION IS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SAID THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET HAS FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO DEAL WITH A SIMILAR PROBLEM.
BUT IT'S ONLY LIMITED TO
RESIDENT OWN PARKS AND NOT ALL
PARKS. MIGHT BE A GOOD IDEA TO
HAVE THE LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL
OR PARTS OF IT INSERTED INTO THE
BUDGET IN ORDER TO EXPEDITE THE
PROCESS WE ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR HARD WORK ON THIS
ISSUE. AND THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS TO PROVIDE A
FRAMEWORK FOR FURTHER DISCUSSION
TO IMPROVE HOUSING FOR MOBILE
HOME PARK RESIDENTS. AND TO
PREVENT AN OWNER FROM HAVING
THEIR PERMIT TO OPERATE BE
SUSPENDED FOR RESIDENT ELATION.
BEGAN WE SHOULD THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
CRISIS AND KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR
HOMES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS JASON I
COULD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS ALLIANCE I WILL REPEAT MR
WHY SAKI'S TESTIMONY BUT BUT
JUST A COUPLE OF QUICK POINTS IS
HE SAID THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING
A GOOD BILL. RIGHT NOW WHEN A
RESIDENT HAS A VIOLATION AND
CAN'T FIX IT. THE ONLY
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM THAT THAT
THAT A STATE. OR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY HAS IS ON THE
PARK. AND THE PARK OWNER- BY
REMOVING THAT YOU KNOW WE ARE
BUILDING SOME ROOM. WHERE TO
PARK HONOR HAVING TO MOVE
DIRECTLY TO ADDICTION.
ADDICTIONS ARE GOOD FOR
RESIDENTS OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE NOT
GOOD FOR THE COMMUNITY. AND
THEY'RE NOT WANTED OR GOOD FOR
THE PARK OWNER. SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE WE ARE VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF ON BEHALF OF
THE MOBILE HOME PARK OWNERS
ALLIANCE. OF AB TWO THOUSAND TWO
. GREAT YOU SO MUCH. SO AT THIS
TIME WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
ROOM THERE IS ANYBODY WHO
WISHES TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL YOU CAN COME UP TO
THE MIKE- WOULD YOU STATE YOUR
NAME. THE ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT AND THAT YOU SUPPORT
THE BILL. ANYBODY IN THE ROOM.
THEY'RE BEING NINE WE'RE GONNA
GO TO THE LINES DATING TEACH
AT&T OPERATOR YOU THERE. I AM
MISTER CHAIR FOR THOSE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. NO ONE IS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
ALL RIGHT WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE ROOM AND- ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. AND WISH TO SPEAK TO HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE. NO OKAY SO
DOESN'T APPEAR WE HAVE ANY SPEAK
OF JUST DEL BRING IT BACK IN A
MINUTE OF ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINES THAT- WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. MISTER EIGHTEEN D.
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD PUT THAT
OUT. IF ANYONE WANTS TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THERE IS NO
ONE VERY WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DAIS MISTER KALRA I BELIEVE
YOU HAD A COMMENT. THANK YOU-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I KNOW I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD- I BELIEVE IT
IS STILL THE CASE A SAN JOSE HAS
MORE. HOMES IN THE CITY IN THE
STATE AND I'VE GOT A LOT OF
MOBILE EMISSION FRANKLY WITH
ORGANIZATIONAL REBUILDING
TOGETHER WHENEVER THEY HAVE
THESE. COME TOGETHER VOLUNTEER
TO FIX UP HOMES. NINETY FIVE
SENATORS TO A MOBILE HOME PARK
BECAUSE OF ONE AND A LOT OF THE
MOBILE HOMES. IN DISREPAIR LOT
ELDERLY RESIDENTS AND I CALL
MOBILE HOMES ESPECIALLY IN AREAS
LIKE SELLING. THE BACK TO
AFFORDABLE OUSING BECAUSE-
CONSIDERING HOW MUCH HAPPENED
AROUND THE MOBILE HOMES AND THE
DEVELOPMENTS COME UP. OF THE
REALITIES THAT MANY THAT LIVE IN
MOBILE HOMES WOULD BE ABLE TO
AFFORD TO LIVE. IN THE AREA
WITHOUT THEM- INSIDE AND I AGREE
WITH AND I LIKE TO UNDERLYING-
THIS IS A BILL I DO THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW THE- IF THERE IS A-
ISSUE WITH THE PARTICULAR HOME
TO. KIND OF. HOLD THE ENTIRE
MOBILE HOME PARK YOU KNOW AT AT
HARM BECAUSE OF IT. I GET THAT
THE ONLY THING I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE JUST TO PUT IT OUT THERE-
IS AND I THINK THAT THE- THE
NEXT BILL THAT IS A RELEASE IN A
PRESENT MAYBE. THE SPONSORS YOU
DON'T LIKE IT BUT I THINK THAT
ACTUALLY DOES HELP. TO GO SOME.
INTERNS THAT COMMUNICATION BUT-
THE ONLY THE ONE THE ONE THING I
MEAN I DO LIKE TO FIND. THERE'S
NO DOUBT THAT WE DO NEED MORE
RESOURCES TO FIX UP SOME OF
THESE ALMOST MOBILE HOMES- IS
THAT WHAT I DON'T WANT TO SEE
HAPPEN BECAUSE WE DO SEE THIS
HAPPENS SOMETIMES. IS IT IS WHEN
THEIR ISSUES IN A MOBILE HOME
PARK THAT AREN'T RESOLVED.
QUICKLY AND IN THIS CASE MAYBE
THERE'S AN ISSUE. THAT OUR
PARTICULAR RESIDENT HAS IS NOT
RESOLVED QUICKLY. BUT NOW
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT THAT OUTSIDE
PRESSURE ON THE MOBILE HOME PARK
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO. LOSE
THEIR PERMIT OPERATE THERE'S
LESS OF AN URGENCY FOR THEM TOMAKE SURE THAT INDIVIDUAL.
RESOLVES IT. AS THAT'S WHERE YOU
KNOW I THINK THAT. AS LONG AS WE
CAN THAT IS JUST RECOGNIZE THAT
TO MAKE SURE THAT. AND I KNOW
MOBILE HOME PARKS IN GENERAL ARE
GOING TO WANT TO HAVE. THE
RESIDENTS UPKEEP WELL TO THE
BEST THAT THEY CAN IN THIS CASE
HAVE SOME RESOURCES TO HELP
THEM. IF NECESSARY BUT THERE MAY
BE SITUATIONS WHERE. A
PARTICULAR RESIDENT MAY HAVE
ISSUES AND NOW BECAUSE THERE'S
NOT THAT EXTRA PRESSURE. OF THE
PARK LOSING LOSING ITS PERMIT.
THERE MAY BE LESS OF A- URGENT
FOR THE PARK TO RESOLVE THAT
ISSUE. AND THEN THEY CAN CAUSE
BLIGHT ON THE- NEIGHBORING
PROBLEMS THAT MAKE SENSE.
GALLIENUS JUST CLICK EVEN IN
MIND AND MAY SURE THAT THERE'S A
IF MAY BE THERE'S TRUMP- SOME.
THAT CAN BE A THERE TO. MAKE
CLEAR THAT THE OVERALL OF IS NOT
TO. ALLOW A LOT KEEP THINGS
REPAIRED A QUITE OPPOSITE THE
ACTUAL FIND MORE. A BACK TO WAYS. TO RESOLVE ISSUES. I WOULD
AGREE WITH IT. I MEAN JUST
BECAUSE- I PUT MYSELF. I THINK
IN THAT AS YOU SAID EARLIER. IT
THERE'S A LOT OF SENIORS RIGHT-
ELDERLY FOLKS. AND SOMETIMES.
YOU KNOW THEY DON'T MOVE AS FAST
AS WE DO RIGHT SO YOU GOT TO
THINK. HOW THEY THINK SOMETIMES
AND IT MAY TAKE A LITTLE MORE
TIME. SO I GREATER. DEPTH
ANYBODY ELSE. I GET A MOTION AND
A SECOND. OUR MOTION BY KALRA
SECOND BY GABRIEL MISTER FIELDS-
DO I YOU CAN CLOSE. WE ASK
PRIVATE. GREAT THINGS AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR. ALLOWING
ME TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON THE
BUILDINGS. MOTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS WICKS. SEYARTO
HI. I CARILLO. APRIL APRIL I
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY HIGHLY AYE
QUIRK-SILVA WARD WARD I CITY.
FIVE I'M SORRY THE BEST WYS I
DO PASSED THE A AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS. A THAT BILL
PASSES. FIVE FIVE ZERO. ALL
RIGHT NEXT UP. WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVY. YOUR BILL AB. TWO
ZERO THREE ONE. THANK YOU- CHAIR
AND MEMBERS FIRST I WANT TO SAY
I'LL BE ACCEPTING COMMITTEE WAS
AMENDMENTS AND I APPRECIATE
COMMITTEES HARD WORK ON THIS
BILL. THE MEMBERS CLARIFIED THAT
PARK MANAGEMENT MUST OFFER IN
PERSON AND PHONE MEETINGS WITH
HOMEOWNERS AND THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES AND IF
MANAGEMENT ALLOWS INTERNET BASED
OPTIONS THEY MUST WRITE A LIST
OF AVAILABLE PLATFORMS UPON
REQUEST. IN ADDITION TO THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ANALYSIS
HELLO ALL THE ALSO ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS REMOVE SUBDIVISION D.
FROM THE BILL- THE PROVISION
WOULD REQUIRE PARK MANAGEMENT TO
PROVIDE A GOOD FAITH RESPONSE TO
HOMEOWNERS. AND THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES IN WRITING
WITHIN TEN DAYS AFTER. THAT
PROVISION WOULD. AB TWENTY
THIRTY ONE WILL ENSURE THAT
RESIDENTS CAN BRING IT
REPRESENTATIVES MEETINGS WITH
PARK MANAGEMENT. CURRENTLY PARK
MANAGEMENT HAS. BEEN
INTERPRETING STATUTES AMEND THAT
THEY CAN ONLY ALLOW RESIDENT OR
THEIR REPRESENTATIVES TO MEET
WITH PARK MANAGEMENT NOT BOTH
THOSE SAME TIME. THIS RESIDENTS
BUILDS IN WASTED TIME AND IN
EFFECTIVE MEETINGS WHEN RESIDENT
NEEDS THE HELP OF AN INTERPRETER
OR SPECIALIZED KNOWLEDGE OF AN
ADVOCATE. TO NAVIGATE COMPLEX
INTERNAL. AB TWENTY THIRTY ONE
WILL CLARIFY THE BOTH RESIDENTS
AND THEIR REPRESENTATIVES
CURRENT WITH PARK MANAGEMENT.
ABOUT SPECIFIED ISSUES SUCH AS
MAINTENANCE STANDARDS OR
RESIDENT CONCERNS RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE. AND WITH ME
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT BOTH ON
THE PHONE WILL BE MARTHA
O'CONNELL JUST MORE REGIONAL
MANAGER AND PERCENT IN HIS LEGAL
COUNSEL FOR GS AND WELL. THE YOU
DO WE HAVE MISS MAKAN. ARE MISS
O'CONNELL ON LINE. HERE OKAY
MA'AM GO AHEAD WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MARK
O'CONNELL ON BEHALF OF THE
GOLDEN STATE MANUFACTURED
HOMEOWNERS THREE GSM A WELL IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. I AM A
SENIOR LIVING IN A MOBILE HOME
PARK IN ST FE. AT THE- WELL
REGIONAL MANAGER I AM
CONSISTENTLY WORKING TO HELP
SOLVE PROBLEMS AT MY PARK AND
SURROUNDING PARKS. AB TWENTY
THIRTY ONE PROPILOT PROPOSES TO
AMEND THE MOBILE HOME RESIDENCY
LAW TO PROMOTE IMPROVED
COMMUNICATION. AND PROBLEM
SOLVING BETWEEN MOBILE HOME
HOMEOWNERS AND MOBILE HOME PARK
MANAGEMENT. MANY PARK OWNERS
AREN'T CIVIL CODE SEVEN NINE
EIGHT POINT FIVE THREE TWO
LITERALLY ALLOWING EITHER A
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS FOR THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES TO MEET WITH
PARK MANAGEMENT BUT NOT BOTH.
THIS IS WHAT I WAS MEANT TO
CREATE A VEHICLE FOR RESOLVING
GRIEVANCES WHEN PARK MANAGEMENT
READS THE LAW TO LITERALLY IT
EXCLUDES INDIVIDUALS FROM THE
MEETING. WHETHER IT BE A
TRANSLATOR OR AN ADVOCATE WITH
SPECIALIZED KNOWLEDGE WHO CAN
HELP OF RESIDENTS NAVIGATE AND
EXPLAIN THEIR ISSUE. WHEN PEOPLE
SEEK REDRESS THEY HAVE THE RIGHT. TO DO SO ALONE. BUT SHOULD
THEY NEED A FIFTH. STATE LAWS.
OF THE ALLOW THEM UTILIZE THIS.
OF AND BE JOINED BY QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS OR REPRESENTATIVES
FOR THE STATE OF RESOLVING
PROBLEMS. THIS BILL PROPOSES TO
ALIGN ITSELF WITH THOSE CURRENT
CALIFORNIA GOVERNANCE VALUES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
. THANK YOU AND DO WE HAVE
BROUGH STANTON ON THE LINE. YES
THANK YOU RICHARD SHERMAN BRIDGE
STANTON ON BEHALF OF GSM A WELL
ALSO IN SUPPORT I'M BASICALLY
HERE JUST ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS-
IT WOULD JUST REITERATE WHAT THE
SUB CONNELL JUST TESTIFIED TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY WE'RE GONNA BRING
IT BACK TO THE ROOM ANYBODY WHO
SUPPORTS THE LEGISLATION IS NOW
IS THE TIME TO COME UP TO THE
MIKE. AND EXPRESS THAT. AND IT'S
A REALLY SCRAMBLING TO THE MIKE
SO WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO THE
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR IS THERE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE TO WHO
WISHES TO EXPRESS SUPPORT. FOR
THIS MEASURE. YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. NO ONE IS SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK OKAY HELLO
AND WE DOES NOT APPEAR WE HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES I'M
SORRY KIND OF PASSED OVER THAT-
WHO DO HAVE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. COME ON IN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES MY APOLOGIES RIGHT.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CHASE AND I COULD ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MOBILE
HOME PARK OWNERS ALLIANCE CPA
DOES HAPPEN OPPOSE POSITION ON
THE BILL BUT WANT TO START BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THE COMMITMENTS
THAT THE AUTHOR MADE TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS TODAY OR RATHER THE
AND THEN THE CITY DID TAKE TODAY
AND ESPECIALLY THE EFFORTS OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT WENT INTO THAT- THE REMOVAL
OF SUB D. FROM THE BILL
ADDRESSES THE LARGEST CONCERN
THAT SEEM PA HAD WITH THE BILL.
WE ARE NOT IN A POSITION TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION TODAY
SIMPLY BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS REMAINING AND WE DO
NEED TO TALK TO OUR CLIENT ABOUT
THEIR PERSPECTIVE ON THE BILL
WITH THE AMENDMENTS BUT AGAIN
JUST WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT
HAS BEEN CHANGED- AND WILL BE
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND
OF COURSE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL THE IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU. NEXT THANK
YOU MR VICE CHAIR CHRIS WYSOCKI-
WITH WESTERN MANUFACTURED.
HOUSING COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION
AND WE WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT WE MET
WITH- WE THINK. THIS THIS BILL
AND REMOVING THE TEN DAY. ASSESS
IS VERY IMPORTANT AND IT'S A
GOOD FIRST STEP BUT IT'S ONLY
ONE OF A NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT
WE HAVE WITH THE BILL SO WE
RESPECTFULLY MY STILL REMAIN
OPPOSED TO IT- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE- BELIEVE IS THAT. THIS
BILL IS SEEMS TO BE A SOLUTION
IN SEARCH OF A PROBLEM IN MANY
WAYS. IN THAT IT REALLY SEEMS TO
ENCOURAGE THE- INTERACTION
BETWEEN LAWYERS AND- AND THE-
PARK OWNERS THAT SPECIALIZE IN
MOBILE HOME PARK LAWSUITS- SO WE
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT.
THERE'S A VALUE IN FACE TO FACE
DISCUSSIONS AND WHAT WE
APPRECIATE TELECONFERENCING AND
VIDEO CONFERENCING. WE'RE NOT
CONVINCED THAT THE EXISTING M.
R. L. CAN ALREADY ACCOMMODATE
THAT- WHY DOESN'T THE CURRENT
LAW WORK. WHERE BOTH PARTIES CAN
ALREADY CONSENT TO IT THERE
HASN'T BEEN ANY EXAMPLES ABOUT-
OTHER THAN GENERIC EXAMPLES.
THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT TO US
ABOUT WHY THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY
NEEDED. SO WHY FORCE THIS BILL-
ON A SUBSET OF INDUSTRIES THAT
ARE JUST MOBILE HOME PARK OWNERS
- WHEN I HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
WHY NOT ALL LATE LAWYERS IN
MEDIATION ISSUES ONE OF THE
LEGISLATURE ITSELF. YESTERDAY
ALONE THERE WERE TEN HEARINGS IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND ONLY THREE
PROVIDE A CELL PHONE ACCESS.
WITH THE SEVERE LACK OF HOUSING
IN THE STATE. WE JUST DON'T
BELIEVE THIS LEGISLATION
CONTRIBUTES TO THE CREATION OF
MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR FAMILIES
TO LIVE IN MOBILE HOME PARKS. IN
FURTHER WMA MEMBERS WORK CLOSELY
WITH OUR RESIDENTS ON A REGULAR
BASIS WE'RE A PARK MANAGERS LIVE
RIGHT NEXT TO THE RESIDENTS WHO
ARE THEMSELVES- RESIDENTS. THE
BILL SEEMS TO BE A SOLUTION IN
SEARCH OF A PROBLEM AGAIN. AND
IT ALSO BELIEVE WE BELIEVE THAT
IT CREATES A FALSE NARRATIVE
THAT PARK OWNERS AND RESIDENTS
HAVE AN ADVERSARIAL
RELATIONSHIP. AND THAT'S A
NATION NOTION THAT WE FIRMLY
REJECT SO FOR THESE REASONS AND
OTHERS- WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES- AND THEN. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- IS THERE ANYBODY
IN THAT ROOM THAT WISHES TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
COME UP TO THE MIKE CAN DO SO.
IF NOT EIGHTEEN D. OPERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN LINE FOR
ANYBODY- IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR KNOWING THE SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK ALL RIGHT
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE DÍAS
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MISTER KALRA GO HEAD. I
THINK THANK YOU THAT IS AS I
MENTIONED DURING THE LAST- BILL-
I DO THINK THIS IS ACTUALLY A
GOOD. PARTNER GO TO SOME EXTENT
HAVING. DONE EXTENSIVELY- WITH
MOBILE HOMES IN MY- IN MY CITY I
OFTENTIMES WITH THE THAT THERE
IS CONFLICT THAT ARISES AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S- AN
IMBALANCE OF POWER WITH THE
MOBILE HOMEOWNER IN THE-RESIDENCE- THAT OFTENTIMES MOST
COMPANIES CAN BE RESOLVED IF
THERE'S THAT BALANCE OF POWER
AND COMMUNICATION- PARTICULARLY.
WITH THE PRIOR BILL GOING
FORWARD I THINK THERE'S A
PRIVATE FIVE NUMBER TWO AND IF
THERE ARE ISSUES. REGARDING
MAINTENANCE- WEATHER'S
MAINTENANCE AN ISSUE OF THE
ACTUAL RESIDENT R OF THE PARK
THAT COULD BE RESOLVED IN A IN
A- IN IN A WAY THAT OTHERWISE
MAYBE COULDN'T. AND OBVIOUSLY
THE INTERPRETATION AND OTHER-
ESPECIALLY IN PLACES LIKE SAN
JOSE WE HAVE MOBILE HOME PARKS
THAT ARE ALMOST ENTIRELY A
VIETNAMESE OR SPANISH SPEAKING
RESIDENTS. AND OF HAVING THAT
INTERPRETATION- IT'S A IT IS A
CRITICAL IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE FULLY INFORMED OF
THEIR RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES. AS WELL. THANK
YOU. I AM BE ELSE MISS WARD READ
. THANK YOU. THIS I HAVE A LIGHT
ON THE- OKAY- NO THANK YOU FOR
THE BUILDING FOR THE CHANCE TO
SPEAK- BEFORE GIMME A LITTLE BIT
THIS TO. AND I'M ALSO JUST TRAIN
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPROVEMENT HERE- GIVEN WHAT THE
EXISTING LAW CURRENTLY REQUIRES
WITH THIRTY DAYS NOTICE AND I
KNOW THERE'S SOME EXPANSION OF-
I GUESS TOPICAL MATTERS THAT YOU
KNOW WOULD BE ADDRESSED NOT TAT
CAN I CAN BE HELPFUL- DOES PULL
DOWN THEN TO JUST- A REQUIREMENT
TO. ENSURE THAT OWNERS ARE ABLE
TO MEET SIMULTANEOUSLY WITH A
REPRESENTATIVE. YES BUT ALSO IF
YOUR FIRST QUESTION ABOUT WHAT
COULD BE THE BENEFIT OF IT- ASK
IF ANY OF MY SPONSORS FROM GSM
OR TESTIMONY FROM GSM ALL WON AT
LEAST TODAY HOW HE WOULD
BENEFICIAL IN A KIND OF
INTERPERSONAL CONTEXT YEAH IT
THERE ARE YOU KNOW- JUST KNOWN-
EXPERIENCE IS- REAL WORLD-
EXPERIENCES OF MARTHA BURSE IF
YOUR SONG YOU WANNA. SHOW AN
EXAMPLE OR TELLING EXAMPLE
HOUSLEY BENEFICIAL. BOB THIS IS
MARCEL. I CAN TELL YOU THAT IN
THE IN THE SITUATIONS FOR THE
PARK OWNERS TAKE THE POSITION.
THAT THEY WILL NOT TALK TO ME AS
THE ADVOCATE AND THE
REPRESENTATIVE. IT'S COMPLETELY
UNWORKABLE IT'S EVEN SO BAD THAT
IF I SEND AN EMAIL ON BEHALF OF
THE RESIDENT TO THE PARK OWNER.
THEY WILL CUT THE RESIDENTS OUT
OF THE LOOP THE PRESIDENT
DOESN'T GET THE EMAIL. THAT ALSO
WORKS THE OPPOSITE WAY IF THE
RESIDENT WRITES AN EMAIL AND
COPIED ME THE PARK OWNER WILL
COP WILL CUT ME OUT OF THE LOOP
IT'S COMPLETELY UNWORKABLE. AND
THEY WILL SAY WELL MARTHA WILL
EITHER TALK TO YOU WITHOUT THE
RESIDENT ARE WILL TALK TO THE
RESIDENTS WITHOUT YOU. SO I SEE
THIS IS A REALLY POSITIVE THING
TO SOLVE PROBLEMS IN THE PARK
THAT AND THERE ARE PARKS THAT
LET BOTH THE RESIDENTS. AND THE
RAP I TO THE MEETINGS WE WORK
THINGS. AND IT HAVE TO ASK AND
BY THE WAY I HAVE NEVER HAD A
SINGLE CASE. AND I'VE HANDLED
HUNDREDS OF THEM WERE IN
ATTORNEY HAS COME INTO THE TO
THE MEETINGS. IT'S JUST IT'S
JUST ME AS A NON LEGAL UNPAID
ADVOCATE. SO I HOPE THAT ANSWERS
YOUR YOUR QUESTION- IT DOES- I
MEAN IF IT'S SOMETHING IF IT'S
COMMUNICATION BY EMAIL THAT CAN
ALWAYS BE FORTY ANNOYING BUT I
CAN ALWAYS BE FORWARDED THE
IMPORTANT POINT I THINK IS THAT.
ANY AN OWNER AND THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES ARE ON THE SAME
PAGE AGAIN IN THE SAME SENSE OF
INFORMATION THEY CAN DECIDE. HOW
TO PROCEED- THREE DISAGREEMENTS
HOPEFULLY TOGETHER- IN HI.
CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE TO. AND SEE
THE LAW TIGHTENS THE THAT THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED THAT THEY
WOULD BE A TO PARTICIPATE. IN
SUCH MEETINGS TOGETHER- YOU'LL
BE BEYOND THAT IS THERE ANYTHING
WITH THE SCOPE OF THE BILL AND
THEN I'M SORRY I'M I'M STILL
FUNDAMENTALLY NOT UNDERSTANDING
WHY THAT'S- WHAT THAT'S A
DISAGREEABLE THINGS. WELL IF
CHRIS WAS SECOND FROM WMA THE
EXISTING AMARILLO ALREADY DEALS
WITH MOST OF THIS ALL RIGHT. SO-THAT'S WHY WE JUST WE FAIL TO
UNDERSTAND WHY THE BILL IS EVEN
NECESSARY. YEAH AND I WOULD JUST
ADD ASSEMBLY MEMBER I MEAN THAT
WE DO I THINK HAVE A LITTLE BIT
OF A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION. IN
TERMS OF THE VALUE AND PURPOSE
OF THE EXISTING LAW VERSUS WHAT
IS BEING AMENDED HERE TODAY- YOU
KNOW AND AGAIN AGAIN I'LL
REITERATE WHERE I STARTED WHICH
IS WE DO APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN TODAY
BUT- THE- THE EXISTING LAW. AS
PARK OWNERS IS THAT WE REPRESENT
VIEW IT. IS ABOUT HAVING
CONSTRUCTIVE CONVERSATION AND-
IN A NON LITIGIOUS ENVIRONMENT
AND OF COURSE WE JUST HEARD FROM
AN ADVOCATE BUT THE OTHER PEOPLE
WHO WILL WE ARE EXPANDING THIS
TO IN THE BILL. OUR ATTORNEYS
WHO REPRESENT INDIVIDUAL
RESIDENTS EXISTING LAW IS QUITE
CLEAR THAT REPRESENTATIVES OF
GROUPS OF RESIDENTS. PARK OWNERS
MUST MEET WITH BUT NOT
REPRESENTATIVES IN INDIVIDUAL
RESIDENTS. THIS IS NOT A LEGAL
PROCEEDING IT'S SIMPLY A MEET
AND CONSULT THE IDEA IS TO HAVE
CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE BETWEEN
THE RESIDENT. THE PARK OWNER IT
DOESN'T CHANGE ANY OF THE
RESIDENTS LEGAL REMEDIES AFTER
THE FACT. AND SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW THERE IS A
RISK THAT THE DISCUSSION BECOMES
MORE LITIGIOUS IT IF A PARK
OWNERS COMPELLED TO MEET. WITH A
RESIDENT AND THE RESIDENTS. I
MEAN FOR AS AT THE ALLOWED INTO
THIS BILL SIMPLY THE RESIDENTS
ATTORNEY AS A DESIGNATED
REPRESENTATIVE. THEY ARE LIKELY
OF COURSE TO BRING IN THEIR OWN
COUNSEL AND AGAIN WE BELIEVE
THAT THE CONVERSATION WILL BE
MUCH MORE LITIGIOUS AND THE RISK
OF LITIGATION IS MUCH HIGHER IN
THE RIGHT. FRAME LIKE HAVING
TONE OF CONVERSATION THAT- HI-
SO I'LL- BE. THE COURTESY TO.
THE- THING THAT WORRIED ME TO AS
A IMMEDIATE SORRY BUT THE LAW
BUT ALSO AND- REAR BY THIS YOU
KNOW- IN IN ALL FAIRNESS- YOU
YOU KNOW IS THERE OR SHOULD
THERE BE NO A LIMIT TO REQUEST
SAID IF SOMEBODY IS- WANTS TO
YOU KNOW HOW HAS IT HAS A
GRIEVANCE AND YOU KNOW THEY WANT
TO FILE A CLAIM THAT MST BE
RESPONDED TO AND THEN NEXT WEEK
THEY FILED A CLAIM IN THE WEEK
AFTER THAT THE FOLLOWING OTHER
CLAIM IS THERE. YOU KNOW- YOU
KNOW LIKE I SAID SORT OF A FAIR
WAY OF- MAKING SHORT AND SHIP
THAT THAT WE ARE- NOT BEING
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF THE
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS UNDER
THIS BILL- THAT THAT PRESENT YOU
KNOW JUST A YOU KNOW A FURTHER
ON HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS THINGS
TO THINK THROUGH I'M GLAD TO SEE
THAT YOU'RE ALREADY WORKING WITH
THEM ON SOME OF THEIR- ISSUES
AND WANT TO TAKE AMENDMENTS- AND
YOU KNOW LIKE ANYTHING WE DO
HERE IS WANT TO MAKE SURE THIS
IS- YOU KNOW SOMETHING IS GOING
TO. IMPLEMENT CORRECTLY AND BE
PROVEN FOR ALL PARTIES SELL ALL
BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT TODAY AND
WATCHES. GOING FORWARD. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE THEM. AND WE'VE XIN.
SO IF MISTER KALRA AND SET. MISC
WITH THAT I HAVE IS FOR THE
MOVING OUT OF COMMITTEE AND GO
AHEAD AND TAKE ALL. I WAS SORRY
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE THEIR THEIR
FAVORITE IS. MY I A PRE THE-
FROM THE OPPOSITION AND IT IS
WITHIN MY PORTFOLIO WORK TO
EXPAND ACCESS IS PRINCIPLES
LANDING GROUND ACT FORWARDING
ALL SORTS OF REFORMS MAKE SURE.
EVERYTHING'S ACCESSIBLE TO
PEOPLE ON THIS REALLY IS THE
SAME PART OF IT IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT SIMULTANEOUSLY MOBILE HOME
PARK RESIDENTS AND THEIR
ADVOCATES THE REPRESENT OF
WHOEVER THE HIGH AND CAN. CAN
ALSO BE THE MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNER- BY NATURE OF THESE FOLKS
WHO ARE IT'S USUALLY LOWER
INCOME OR OLDER YOU KNOW NOT
LOOKING FOR LITIGATION THE
LOOKING FOR SOLUTIONS ISSUE AND
I TRULY BELIEVE THAT WHEN THEY
GET SOMEONE ELSE INVOLVED IT'S
WHEN THEY FEEL LIKE THEY NEED
SOMEONE ELSE TO HELP BALANCE OUT
THE EQUATION OF THE POWER
BALANCE. SO THAT'S REALLY WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT NOT SEEKING
OUT MORE PROBLEMS BUT REALLY
MISSING SOLUTIONS FOR FOLKS. IS
PART IN ERIC AND I'LL CALL
PUBLIC IF YOU WORK ON THIS BILL
AND- ASK DR. THANK YOU. THE
MOTION. TO PAY. IN THE- WEEKS I
WEEKS I SAY ARE. YOUR TO KNOW.
COULD CARILLO I. GAVE GABRIEL I
CALL. COLOR HI KILEY. KILEY NO
QUIRK-SILVA. WARD WART I. THANK
YOU TO. THAT BILLS FIVE TO TWO
ITS OUT BUT WE BELIEVE IT OPEN.
FOR OTHER FOLKS TO ADD ON
ANYTHING WITH THAT NEXT WE'RE-
GOING TO SEE- HERE MR GABRIEL'S-
EIGHTY NINETEEN NINETY ONE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE COURTESY OF
ALLOWING ME TO GO AND WANT TO
THANK OUR MAJORITY LEADER FOR
THE CURRENCY WE HAVE A- WITNESS
WHO NEEDS TO RUN TO THE AIRPORT-
WANTED TO START OFF BY. ASKING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
THANK YOU COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR THOUGHTFUL ASSISTANCE ON
THIS BILL I'M PIECE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB NINETEEN NINETY ONE-
AND ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
TENANTS RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS FOR
WORK OF MY STAFF TO SHARPEN THE
LANGUAGE AND LOOKING FOR TO
CONTINUE TO. WORK WITH THEM ON
THE BILL TO MAKESURE THAT WE
ARE NOT UNDERMINING ANY
PROTECTIONS CURRENTLY THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICIPATE IN SHELTER PROGRAMS
AND RESIDE TEMPORARILY IN HOTELS
MOTELS OR OTHER SITES. MANY
HOTELS AND MOTELS ARE FORCED TO
pREMOVE PEOPLE FROM ROOMS EVERY
FOUR WEEKS TO AVOID POTENTIALLY
CREATING A LANDLORD TENANT
RELATIONSHIP. THE SHUFFLING
PROCESS BY UNIT OWNERS IS
PARTICULARLY DISRUPTIVE TO
FAMILIES IN THESE PROGRAMS WHO
MUST FIND NEW HOUSING EVERY
THIRTY DAYS. THESE PRACTICES
ALSO NECESSARILY CONSUME
RESOURCES A PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATORS WHO MUST SEARCH
FOR OTHER HOUSING. IN OTHER
CASES MOTELS AND HOTELS DO NOT
WANT TO PARTICIPATE IN SHELTER
PROGRAMS OUT OF CONCERN THEY
WILL STAB US LANDLORD TENANT
RELATIONSHIPS LIMIT SENSIBILITY
OF AVAILABLE PROPERTIES FOR USE
IN OKLAHOMA SERVICES. AB
NINETEEN NINETY ONE CRATES
PROTECTION FOR VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND PROVIDES
LANDLORD TENANT CRAPPIE FOR
THOSE PROGRAMS. THIS BILL WOULD
PER YOU KNOW OWNERS FROM
IMPLEMENTING TERMINATION
POLICIES THAT SPECIFICALLY
TARGET SHELTER PARTICIPANTS THIS
BILL ESTABLISHES A GRIEVANCE
PROCESS. AND ENSURES THAT VERY
AFFORDABLE INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT
TERMINATED FOR PROGRAMS
ARBITRARILY SET. AND ALSO
ENSURES THAT HOTELS AND MOTELS
COUNTRY OUR OWN HOUSE WITH
RESPECT AND DIGNITY. WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN PERSON IS
CHRIS FREE THE CHIEF PROGRAMS
OFFICER LA FAMILY HOUSING A CO
SPONSOR AND ON THE PHONE IS
DONNA TANG FROM LHASA THANK YOU
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU AND YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH TWENTY INDIA. THE
MORNING OR AFTERNOON THIS POINT-
BY CHAIR WICKS AN HONORABLE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRIS FREED
AND- AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER- GABRIEL
SAID I AM THE CHIEF PROGRAM
OFFICER FOR ELLIE FAMILY HOUSING
ONE OF THE LARGEST HOMELESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND AFFORDABLE
IN SUPPORT OF. A HOUSING
DEVELOPERS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. I HAVE A SPENT NEARLY
TWENTY TWO YEARS LEADING ELLIE
FAMILY HOUSING SERVICE PROVISION
WHICH COVERS EVERYTHING FROM
STREET ENGAGEMENT TO HOUSING
NAVIGATION. AND WHICH LAST YEAR
SUPPORTED NEARLY TWELVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE ARE IN THE SAN FERNANDO
AND SANTA CLARITA VALLEY.
ADDITIONALLY I SERVE AS THE
CHAIR. OF THE LOS ANGELES AB
CONTINUUM OF CARE- BOARD. AND
ALSO IS A MEMBER OF THE CS
POLICY COUNCIL. AT HOME THIS IS
NOT JUST MY LIFE'S WORK I IT'S
ALSO DEEPLY PERSONAL FOR ME AS I
SPENT NEARLY EIGHT YEARS OF MY
YOUTH. I'M IN A HOUSING
INSTABILITY SITUATION. I'M AND
SO I AM PROBABLY BEFORE YOU. CAN
STRONG IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
NINETY ONE LEGISLATION THAT I
AND SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE-
AND HAVE LONG I. FOR BECAUSE OF
THE BUT- CURRENT I AM YOU.
AMBIGUITY IN STATE LAW MOTEL AND
HOTEL OPERATORS A PARTICIPATING
SHELTER IN TERM HOUSING PROGRAMS
OFTEN WORKED A TO SHUFFLING
FAMILIES ROOM TO ROOM EVERY FOUR
WEEKS- AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STATED- TO AVOID TRIGGERING
STATE TENANCY LAWS. WHICH
FURTHER REALLY. JUST TO SPEAK TO
THE PARTICIPANTS THAT WE SERVE
IT REALLY EXACERBATES THE KIDS
BECAUSE THEY'RE BEING MOVED FROM
SCHOOL TO SCHOOL TO SCHOOL EVERY
TWENTY EIGHT DAYS I'M AND IT
COULD IT INCREASES THEIR LEVEL
OF TRAUMA. IN SOME CASES MOTEL
AND HOTEL OPERATORS REFUSED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THESE PROGRAMS
FOR FEAR OF THIS ABBY GIVE AND
GIVE. AND YOU IDIOT I'VE BEEN UP
SINCE THREE THIRTY THIS MORNING
SO I APOLOGIZE I FEEL YEAH YEAH
- AND A AND A AND THEY'RE BY
LIMITING THE OPTIONS WE HAVE.
FOR UTILIZATION OF PARTICULAR
HOTELS BECAUSE IF THEY SAY NO
THEN WE'RE FORCED TO USE ONLY A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF MOTELS AND
THEREBY LEAVING SOME PEOPLE ON
THE STREET. FURTHERMORE THERE
ARE NEW UNIFORM POLICIES FOR
EXITING PARTICIPANTS FROM
PROGRAMS CREATING INCONSISTENT
SERVICE PROVISION ACROSS BOTH.
LOCAL AND BY THE JURISDICTION
AND THE STATE THAT ULTIMATELY-
HARMS FRONTLINE STAFF AND THE
PARTICIPANTS BECAUSE THERE'S NO
CLARITY. IN A AB NINETEEN NINETY
ONE INTRODUCED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GABRIEL PROVIDES DESPERATELY
NEEDED CLARITY TO ADD TO STATE
LAW AND IN A WAY THAT BENEFITS
PARTICIPANTS PROVIDERS AND
OPERATORS. AB NINETEEN NINETY
ONE ENSURES THAT THOSE ACCESS
SEEN IN TERM HOUSING AND SHELTER
PROGRAMS ARE PROTECTED FROM
UNNECESSARY RESTRICTIONS AND
FEES IMPOSED BY MOTEL OPERATORS
WHITE THE SAME TIME. BEEN MADE
FULLY AWARE OF PROGRAM
GUIDELINES AND RIVAS PROCESSES.
THE PASSAGE OF THIS BILL IS
SMALL BUT CRITICAL STEP TOWARD
CREATING A MORE COHERENT
EQUITABLE AND TRANSPARENT
FRAMEWORK OF STATE RIGHT SERVICE
PROVISION I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE FOR NINETEEN. EVER
AB NINETEEN NINETY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I HAVE
TROUBLE WITH THAT WERE TOO DON'T
WORRY- AND WE CAN WE ALSO- SHIFT
NOW YEARS TO THE- OPERATOR THERE
SO. DIALING IN RIGHT THIS YEAR A
WITNESSES RACK RIGHT HOW TO
SWITCH UP WE HAVE DONE A TANK.
R. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE OUR- MY
NAME IS DONNA THING AND I'M- I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE DATE
OF BIRTH- CARRINGTON MEMBER MY
NAME IS ALEC THE THOUGHT BEING
ON THE DIRECT GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR THE ANGELES HOME SERVICES
THE PHONE. I HERE TO SPEAK A
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF AB AND
NINETY NINETY ONE. WHERE THE
MAIN IN MINUTES OF SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS BEEN WALKING GOING FROM
THE PERFECT. I Y. TO KNOW WHY I
THE LACK OF I WANT YOU KNOW. AB
NINETY NINETY ONE IS WILLING FOR
US. WE ABOUT THE LEVEL THOUSAND
INTO HOUSING. ANY GIVE NIGHT.
THIS INCLUDE CONGER STOP. I WELL
AS NON FROM BY. ENCOURAGE LIKE
PROJECT LOON. BOB HERTZBERG
PUBLIC OWN PRIVATE. BY THE CRIME
AND. AND VOUCHERS THAT ROOM FOR
FAMILIES THANK HOMELESSNESS
RIGHT NOW WE'RE FINDING A FIVE
HUNDRED FAMILY STAY IN MOTEL
ROOMS. THE MOVIE TOWARD USING
COM RIGHT IN THE POSITIVE ABOUT
. HOWEVER AND OTHER NON OPTION
IF YOU A SENSE PRIDE IN BE
AGENCY- BOYFRIEND- HELLO JOURNEY
INTO HOUSING. BUT WHAT PERCENT
ARE OF COMPANIES OF AND IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE INTERTRUST
COMMITTEE ABOUT. BECAUSE OF THE
AMBIGUITY IN STATE LAW TENANTS
IN SOME ARE CUR. WE MOWED HOLDEN
HOTELS SB IN GARDEN LIKE MOST
HOW ABOUT YOUR PROGRAM SHUFFLING
PEOPLE ROOMS ARE TO OTHER. OUT
OF CO. ABOUT THE- PROBE WILL
GAME RIGHT THAT'S. THE CASE
MANAGER SPEND VALUABLE TIME
RESOURCE NEEDED TO THAT THE
IMPACT OF THE- MONTHLY CYCLE I
WANT WILL WANT KIDS. TO FOCUS
FIGHTING A PERMANENT HOUSING FOR
THE FAMILY AT HOME. ADDITIONALLY
THERE ARE NO CLEAR OF UP
CONFUSION FROM KEEP FROM CHILD
PROGRAM. WHICH CAN BE TO
COMPLETE BURKE AND-
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM.
NOT GOING PROTECT ARE ENTITLED
TO SOME SHOTS PROGRAM BOTH. AGE
HOW MUCH. KERR POKOK AND
PROGRAMS SO PEOPLE OUT ON THE
STREET ARBITRARY.
I WANT TO NOTE THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING TO GET FEEDBACK
COMPONENTS RIGHT SCRIPT SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT INADVERTENTLY
CREATING LOOPHOLES INTENSELY
BLOCK. CONVERSATIONS HAVE MADE
THE BILL STRONGER AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
CONTINUING THIS WORK. WHAT
OTHER- POP WITH PARTNERS TO
RESOLVE OUTSTANDING QUESTION
THANK YOU ARE COMING FROM THE
TIME AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR
I DON'T. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
INDEED HAVE A FOLK IN THE ROOM
LIKE SIX FOR SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON COUNTER MEMBERS UNTIL
LAWLER. WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION- ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
AT DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
THE INNER CITY LAW CENTER AND
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. WE HAD A LOT OF
CONCERNS WITH THE INTRODUCED
VERSION OF THE BILL. REALLY
PLEASE WITH THE DILIGENT WORK
THAT THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND THE
SPONSORS HAVE DONE WITH US TO
BRING US TO A NEUTRAL POSITION
ON THE BILL AND ARE VERY HOPEFUL
THAT ONCE WE WERE ABLE TO
RESOLVE A COUPLE OF. REMAINING
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT WITH ALL
TO COME IN AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM. OPERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES WOULD WISH TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINETEEN NINETY ONE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION PLEASE. THANK YOU MANAGER IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. WE HAVE AT LEAST
ONE PERSON IS SIGNALED THEY WISH
TO SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLACE.
I AM A MANAGER WE DO APOLOGIZE
FOR THE DELAY. WHEN YOU GO TO
LINE TWO TWENTY SIX. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS THE EXTENT OF
ALL WITH PATH PEOPLE ASSISTING
THE HOMELESS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. GREAT OKAY- LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO ANY- PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANYONE
IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION. WITH
NO OPPOSITION FILE RING ABOUT
HERE TO. DIESS ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE QUESTIONS. I
THANK GOD FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
WE RUN INTO THIS SITUATION A LOT
AND SALAS ACHES WE'VE DONE A LOT
OF WORK IN TRYING TO. CONVERT A
LOT OF OUR MOTELS AND HOTELS IN
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING ORSHORT
TERM HOUSING AND OTHER
ESPECIALLY SOME OF OUR ELDERLY
AND DISABLED PEOPLE THAT ARE
THAT ARE HOMELESS- IT'S NOT AS
SIMPLE AS SAYING OKAY WE HAVE TO
THREE WEEKS GO FIND SOME OTHER
SITUATION WOULD HAVE BEEN SO I
APPRECIATE THAT THIS- DON'T
THANK YOU. IF YOU. OKAY AND WITH
EMOTION. WE CAN. WE DO A SECOND
GREAT. CLOSE YEAH- IT JUST WANNA
PICK UP ON WHAT. THE WITNESS
SAID YOU KNOW WHEN WE ARE
LOOKING TO TRANSITION PEOPLE OUT
OF HOMELESSNESS WERE LOOKING FOR
STABILITY AND THE OPPOSITE OF
THAT IS MOVING THEM AROUND EVERY
FEW WEEKS AND SO WITH THAT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU AND JUST
APPRECIATE A GOOD WORK IN THE
SPACE AND THE TESTIMONY AS WELL.
AND HAVE YOU SUPPORT THE BILL
OUT OF COMMITTEE SAID. MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMIT
IN APPROACH. WICKS HI THERE I.
CAREER I GABRIEL HI. GABRIEL I
KALRA. COLOR I'D KILEY.
QUIRK-SILVA WARD WHAT I EIGHT
FOUR FIVE SIX THAT BILLS SIX TWO
ZERO IT IS OUT BUT LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN WITH THAT. HI THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. AND WE
HAVE OUR MAJORITY LEADER IF
YOU'D LIKE TO STEP UP TO THE
MIKE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I PRESENT TO YOU AB
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA HOMELESSNESS
ASSISTANCE ACT THIS BILL WILL
HELP ON HOUSE TO CALIFORNIANS
MEETS THE HIGH COSTS OF HOUSING
BY PROVIDING RENTAL SUBSIDIES TO
QUICKLY MOVED MOVE THEM OFF THE
STREET AND INTO HOUSING. IN
RECENT YEARS THE GOVERNOR AND
STATE LEGISLATURE HAVE TAKEN
TREMENDOUS STEPS TO COMBAT THE
ONGOING HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
WHICH HAS ONLY WORSENED OVER
NINETEEN AND EMIC DESPITE THESE
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS THE IMPACTS
OF THIS CRISIS HAS LAST LEFT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
ON THE STREETS MOST OF WHOM ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR. DATA FROM THE
NATIONAL LOW INCOME HOUSING
COALITION SHOWS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S SEVERE LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DRIVES OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS WHERE A
PERSON WOULD HAVE TO MAKE THIRTY
ONE DOLLARS AN HOUR. TO AFFORD A
ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT. RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT DIRECT RENTAL
SUBSIDIES ARE ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE INTERVENTIONS FOR
REDUCING HOMELESSNESS AND
SEVERAL STATES HAVE IMPLEMENTED
THE SUBSIDY SUBSIDIES. AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTEEN WILL PUT THIS
RESEARCH INTO ACTION BY
PROVIDING DIRECT RENTAL
ASSISTANCE TO PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
GRANTS TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AND SERVICE PROVIDERS TO CONNECT
PEOPLE TO HOUSING AND RENTAL
ASSISTANCE. THIS BILL IS ALIGNED
WITH THE ONE TIME FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT TO BE SPENT
OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS WHICH
COULD PROVIDE HOUSING FOR AN
ESTIMATED FIFTY THOUSAND ON
HOUSE CALIFORNIANS IN YEAR ONE.
AND BY THE END OF FIVE YEARS
TENS OF THOUSANDS MORE. FURTHER
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTEEN ENSURES
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND ENABLES
FUTURE PLANNING FOR RICK BY
REQUIRING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
REPORT ON HOW THE SUCCESS OF
THESE HOW. SUCCESSFUL THESE
FUNDS HAVE BEEN IN REDUCING
HOMELESSNESS YOUR TESTIFIED
SUPPORT ARE BIG BIG BILL PICKLE
WITH BRILLIANT CORNERS WITH
MINISTERS LOS ANGELES FLEXIBLE
HOUSING SUBSIDY POOL AND SIMPLY
BECAUSE STEEL WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS INTO CUSTODY ON A POLICY
ADVOCATE WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY. OUR
ORGANIZATION ADVOCATES ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
POVERTY THROUGH THE LENS OF
ECONOMIC AND RACIAL JUSTICE AND
WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTEEN. AT
PRESENT CALIFORNIA'S
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
DECADES IN THE MAKING ON ANY
GIVEN NIGHT THERE ARE UPWARDS OF
A HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND ON HOW
CALIFORNIANS SLEEPING ON THE
STREETS OR IN THEIR CARS. AN
UNCONSCIONABLE NUMBER. COUPLED
WITH A STATEWIDE SHORTAGE OF ONE
POINT TWO MILLION AFFORDABLE
HOMES AND ONLY ONE SHELTER BED
FOR EVERY THREE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THE
STATE'S HUMANITARIAN CRISIS HAS
HIT A FEVER PITCH. WIDELY SEEN
AS A STATEWIDE CRISIS AFFECTING
ALL CALIFORNIANS THE CRISIS
ACUTELY IMPACTS BLACK INDIGENOUS
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
NOTABLY BLACK PEOPLE REPRESENT
ONLY SIX POINT 5% OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION BUT ACCOUNT FOR
NEARLY 40% OF CALIFORNIANS ON
HOUSE. BY PARKER ALSO MOST
LIKELY TO BE LOW WAGE WORKERS.
MORE LIKELY TO BE RENT BURDENED
AND MORE LIKELY TO CONTRACT AND
DIE FROM COVERED NINETEEN AND
CLEARLY THE SHOWS THAT THE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
IN THE STATE IS ALSO A RACE AND
EQUITY CRISIS. EVERY PERSON TO
DESERVES TO LIVE WITH DIGNITY
AND HAVE THEIR BASIC NEEDS AND
NEEDS MATT AND OUR CURRENT
SOCIAL SAFETY NET IS
INSUFFICIENT GIVEN THE STATE'S
UNCONSCIONABLE AND ACCELERATING
WEALTH INEQUALITY AND STAGNANT
WAGES. AS THE MAJORITY LEADER
RIGHTLY NOTED YOU HAVE TO MAKE
OVER THIRTY EIGHT DOLLARS AN
HOUR- TO ESSENTIALLY EXIST HERE.
THIS MISMATCH BETWEEN INCOME AND
HOUSING IS FUELING THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTEEN ESTABLISHES THE
HOUSE CALIFORNIA CHALLENGE
PROGRAM WHICH WILL HELP ON HOW
CALIFORNIANS WITH THE HIGH COST
OF HOUSING. AND PROVIDE RENTAL
SUBSIDIES TO QUICKLY MOVE THEM
OFF THE STREETS. AB TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AUTHORIZES CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
TO ESTABLISH THE PROGRAM PROVIDE
GRANTS TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AND SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
CONNECT PEOPLE TOOK HOUSING AND
RENTAL ASSISTANCE. FURTHER AB
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY INTEREST
ACCOUNTABILITY BY REQUIRING
VARIOUS REPORTS ON PROGRAM
OUTCOMES. FLEXIBLE HOUSING
SEVENTIES SUBSIDIES ARE PROVEN
EQUITABLE TOOL TO REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS. AND HOUSING
SECURITY IMPROVES PEOPLE'S
HEALTH AND WELLBEING EMPOWERS
INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE A GREATER
ARRAY OF CHOICES FOCUS ON
PERSONAL GROWTH PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE AND BE THE EST VERSIONS
OF THEMSELVES AT WORK AT HOME
AND IN THEIR COMMUNITY. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE ONE TIME
FIVE BILLION INVESTMENT TO BE
SPENT OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTEEN WILL
BOOST THOUSANDS OUT OF THE
SHADOWS AND INTO HOUSING WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND I KNOW
WE HAVE OUR SECOND WITNESS
JOINING BY PHONE- BILL PICKLE
ARE YOU THERE. OPERATOR CAN YOU
SEE IF. BILL PICARD HELLO HI WE
CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MY NAME IS
OLYMPIC- I'M THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER UP IN CORNERS WE ARE A
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING NONPROFIT WE
OPERATE STATEWIDE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. INCLUDING LOS
ANGELES SAN FRANCISCO AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTIES- WE EXPRESS OUR
STRONG AS POSSIBLE SUPPORT FOR
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTEEN AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RANTS WITH ABLATION THE
HOUSE CALIFORNIA CHALLENGE
PROGRAMS ASSEMBLY BUT- STILL
PRESENT AND HISTORIC OPPORTUNITY
TO RAPIDLY SCALE HOUSING
PLACEMENTS AND GET PEOPLE
INDOORS INTO THEIR OWN APARTMENT
HOMES BY CREATING A FLEXIBLE.
STATEWIDE RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. WE KNOW THAT IT'S WORKS
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY FLEXIBLE
HOUSING SEVENTY GOAL ENABLE
BRILLIANT CORNERS AND ARE MANY
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE PARTNERS THE
HOUSE NEARLY TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
IN A FEW YEARS EARNING NATIONAL
BEST PRACTICE RECOGNITION.
FLEXIBLE HAS NOW BEEN CREATED IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTIES AS WELL AND IN SOME OF
THE MORE RURAL AREAS OF THE
STATE AS WELL. HOW DO WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE ACTUALLY QUALITY
BIG UNITS AVAILABLE IN
CALIFORNIA IS NOTORIOUSLY TIGHT
RENTAL HOUSING MARKETS. WE NOT-
BECAUSE WHEN THEY'RE ARMED WITH
FLEXIBLE RENTAL SUBSIDIES OUR
LANDLORD ENGAGEMENT TEAMS
ACTUALLY SECURE LEGAL CONTROL.
OF RENTAL UNITS EVERY SINGLE DAY
CREATING A POOR INVENTORY ON THE
PART IN HOMES AND THEN OUR
TENANCY SUPPORT STAFF CAN MATCH
CLIENTS WITH THE UNIT THAT'S
RIGHT FOR THEM. ONE OPERATIONAL
PEOPLE CAN TRANSITION FROM
HOMELESSNESS TO PERMANENT
HOUSING IN A MATTER OF WEEKS
BECAUSE NO ONE IS SENT OFF TO
NAVIGATE CALIFORNIA'S FIERCELY
COMPETITIVE HOUSING MARKETS ON
THEIR OWN. AS RAPID SCALABLE
ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
PRIVATE APARTMENT INVENTORY
WARNED AND NAS. THE PLEXTOR
MODEL ALSO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW HOUSING
PROJECTS GIVING DEVELOPERS THE
RENTAL INCOME THEY NEED TO
DEDICATE UNITS TO EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS AND TO BRING
POLITICS ONLINE FASTER. WE
CREATED THOUSANDS OF UNITS ITS
WAY THROUGH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FLEXIBLE HOUSING SUBSIDY
PAUL. AND LASTLY THE POLITICAL
MODEL PROVIDED DOCUMENTED
MULTIPLE SYSTEM COST SAVINGS
INVESTING IN FLEXIBLE RANDY
RENTAL SUBSIDIES AND TENANCY
SUPPORT. COSTS LESS. THAN WHAT
WE WOULD HAVE SPENT ON
HEALTHCARE. AND EMERGENCY
INTERVENTIONS. SO ACROSS
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE RELIEF AND
LONG TERM ANSWER FOR OUR ON
HOUSE NEIGHBORS WE SIMPLY CANNOT
AFFORD TO MISS THIS OPPORTUNITY
FOR TRANSFORMATIVE STATEWIDE
IMPACT AND WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND I'LL BRING IT BACK
HERE TO THE ROOM ANYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE LIKE TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTEEN HI MARCUS ALL THE ON
BEHALF OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING HOUSING CALIFORNIA IS A
PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. ON
OUR BEHALF FOR THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. OPERATOR CAN NEVER OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES ANYONE IN THE
PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR AB. TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTEEN. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE
PERSON WHO SIGNALED THEY WISH TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT.
GOING TO GO TO LINE. TWO TWENTY
NINE. HI DONNA JEAN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
HOMELESS SERVICES THE THIRTY OF. EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
WHEN UP TO SIGNAL THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO THE ROOM ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANYONE
IN THE ROOM LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVENO
POSITION FILE WILL BRING IT BACK
HERE TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR. RIGHT
DO WE HAVE A MOTION. AND A
SECOND GREAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. FOR RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS SO THAT WE CAN GET
OUR OWN HOUSE STAR HOMELESS INTO
RENTAL PROPERTIES I AM HONORED
TO GIVE YOU MY AYE VOTE ENDS I'M
HAPPY TO SEE HOPE FOR THIS BILL
BUT I'VE COMMITTEE TODAY. AND
APPRECIATE YOUR GOOD WORK IN THE
SPACE THANK YOU. MOTION IS TO
PASS OUT TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS WEEKS
FIVE WEEKS ICE HERE TO. SAY
AREN'T YOU KNOW CARILLO CARILLO
I GABRIEL GABRIEL I KALRA. COLOR
AYE KILEY QUIRK-SILVA WARD. WHAT
I. FOUR ONE FIVE TO ONE THAT
BILLS OUT AND LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO ADD ON AND
I ALSO WANT TO MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT AT AB TWENTY SEVEN
TEN ITEM FELL TO NUMBER TWENTY
HAS BEEN PULLED. WE'LL BE
HEARING THAT TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'VE NEVER. SEEN AND
WE'RE GONNA JUST DO A QUICK AT
ON WE HAVE SOME FOLKS HERE FOR
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN- THAT'S A
BILL AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY
SEVEN- ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL.
WHAT ARE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THINGS- SIMILAR
GABRIEL'S IN NIGHT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOARD. IN MY WARD IS IN A
HIGH SEVEN THREE SIX OKAY THAT
IS SIX ONE THAT THAT BILLS THAT
WILL STILL KEEP IT OPEN AND WE
CAN GO BACK NOW TO I BELIEVE I
MISSED BONTA- PRESENTING. ON AB
TWENTY THREE NINETEEN.
THE SEASON AGAIN. THANK YOU
CHAIRED MEMBERS FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS BILL AND THE DEDICATED WORK
OF YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF AB
TWENTY THREE NINETEEN IS A
DISTRICT BILL SEEKING A SIMPLE
FIX WITH A COMPLICATED WITHIN A
COMPLICATED ISSUE AREA THE
SURPLUS LAND ACT IN NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN THE ALAMEDA NAVAL
STATION AC AIR STATION WAS
CLOSED AS PART OF THE BASE
REALIGNMENT AND CLOSURE PROCESS
IN THE FOLLOWING YEARS BLAND NOW
KNOWN AS ALAMEDA POINT WAS
CONVEYED TO THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
IN ACCORDANCE ITH THE FEDERALLY
APPROVED. FOR USE PLANS.
ADDITIONALLY THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
ENTERED INTO A LIKE LEGAL
SETTLEMENTS IN TWO THOUSAND ONE
TO DEDICATE TWENTY FIVE PERCENT.
OF THE HOUSING ON ALAMEDA POINT
AS PERMANENTLY AFFORDABLE TO
VERY LOW LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES. UNFORTUNATELY WHILE
THE DEVELOPMENT AT ALAMEDA POINT
HAS OVERCOME LITIGATION AND A
LOCAL BALLOT MEASURE. THE LATEST
ROADBLOCK WAS THE WELL
INTENTIONED AMENDMENTS TO THE
SURPLUS LAND ACT IN AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX OF TWENTY NINETEEN.
APPLYING THE SURPLUS LAND ACT
ALAMEDA POINT HAS CAUSED FURTHER
DELAYS TO PLANNED DEVELOPMENTS.
AND HAS CREATED UNCERTAINTY WITH
REGARDS TO BUILDING LEASED OUT
FOR. COMMERCIAL ENTERPRISES AB
TWENTY THREE NINETEEN WOULD
PROVIDE A VERY NARROW EXEMPTION
TO THE SURPLUS LAND ACT FOR
ALAMEDA POINT. AND IN DOING SO
PROVIDE CLARITY IN A PATH
FORWARD FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT FOR THE
CITY OF ALAMEDA. THANK YOU AND
AS WITNESSES WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE LISA MAXWELL FROM THE
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT DIRECTOR
WITH THE COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
DIRECTOR FOR THE CITY OF
ALAMEDA. AND A BIG WHO IS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ALAMEDA
POINT COLLABORATIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. THE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY THREE NINETEEN
TODAY MY NAME IS LISA MAXWELL
AND I'M THE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT DIRECTOR FOR THE
CITY OF ALAMEDA. ALAMEDA IS A
SMALL ISLAND COMMUNITY IN SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY HOME TILL IN THE
NAVAL AIR STATION UNTIL NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN. WE REFER TO IT AS
ALAMEDA POINT THAT THE CLOSURE
OF THE NAVAL AIR STATION-
NEGOTIATIONS WERE ENTERED INTO
WITH THE NAVY AND THEY- BASE
REUSE PLAN WAS CREATED- BUT
STILL IS IN EFFECT TODAY AND WE
STILL OPERATE ACCORDING TO IT-
THE BASE THREE YEARS PLAN
REQUIRES ALAMEDA. TO BE A MIXED
DEVELOPMENT PROPERTY THAT
INCLUDES HOUSING. COMMERCIAL
USES TO SPUR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OPEN SPACE AND WE'VE
BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY TO
IMPLEMENT THIS PLAN FOR THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS. AS NOTED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE SENATE
SURPLUS LANDS ACT WAS AMENDED
AND UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
THIS AMENDMENT WAS THAT FORMER
MILITARY BASES LIKE ALAMEDA
POINT. ARE MADE SUBJECT TO THE
SURPLUS LANDS ACT THIS REQUIRES
THE CITY TO PUT EACH PARCEL AT
ALAMEDA POINT THROUGH A TIME
CONSUMING SURPLUS PROCESS BEFORE
DEVELOPMENT CAN CONTINUE. THIS
MONEY CAN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES MATERIAL TO THE
CITY BECAUSE THE LAND THAT WAS
TRANSFERRED FROM THE CITY TO THE
NAVY IS NOT SURPLUS LAND FOR
WHICH THE CITY HAS NO USE. AND
SAID THE ALAMEDA POINT LAND IS
ALREADY SUBJECT TO A LEGALLY
BINDING AGREEMENT THAT WAS PUT
IN PLACE WITH THE NAVY IN TWO
THOUSAND. AND PLAN FOR
COMMERCIAL DEVELOPMENT- IN
CONNECTION WITH THE BASE REDUCE
PLANT. REVENUES THAT ARE
GENERATED BY SALES A LEAKY
LEASING AT ALAMEDA POINT ALLOW
FOR CONTINUED DEVELOPMENT THEY
AMENDMENT HAS DRAMATICALLY
STALLED SALES AND LEASING
LEASING ACTIVITIES. IN FACT
SINCE THE AMENDMENT OF THE
SURPLUS LAND SECOND DURING TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. NO BUILDINGS AT
ALAMEDA POINT WERE SOLD AND
LEASING ACTIVITY WAS VERY
MINIMAL. IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT ALL HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
AND ALAMEDA POINT MUST INCLUDE A
TOTAL OF 25% AFFORDABLE UNITS.
THIS REQUIREMENT HAS BEEN IT
HERE TO CONSISTENTLY SINCE
DEVELOPMENT BANK BEGAN. THE
TESTIMONY OF DOUG BIGGS WITH THE
ELEMENT APPOINT COLLABORATIVE
WILL PROVIDE JUST AN EXAMPLE OF
THE NEGATIVE IMPACT. THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE CHANGE HAS ON THE
HOUSING NEEDS OF RESIDENTS AND
SECURELY MOST VULNERABLE REST.
AB TWO THREE DOT ONE NINETEEN
CREATES A VERY NARROW EXEMPTION
ON THE SURPLUS LANDS ACT TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES SOLELY FOR
THE CITY OF ALAMEDA. THIS THIS
EXEMPTION IS NECESSARY SO
DEVELOPMENT ALAMEDA POINT CAN
CONTINUE UNHAMPERED AND WITHOUT
FURTHER DELAY. AS NOTED THE
CITY'S CONTRACTUALLY OBLIGATED
DID HEAR THE BASS YOU REUSE PLAN
WITH THE NAVY AND PURSUE
DEVELOPMENT ALAMEDA POINT
WITHOUT THIS NEAR EXEMPTION THE
CITY MUST CHOOSE BETWEEN
VIOLATING ITS CONTRACT WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR VIOLATING
STATE LAW. NEITHER OF WHICH IS A
VERY APPEALING OPTION FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
A VOTE ON AB TWENTY THREE NINE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND YOU CAN
BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR
WIXEN MEMBERS MY NAME'S DOUG BIG
SOME EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ALAMEDA POINT COLLABORATIVE
SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF AB TWENTY
THREE NINETEEN. A. B. C. WAS
CREATED OUT OF THE CLOSURE OF
THE NAVAL AIR STATION IN THE MID
NINETIES THE FEDERAL PROCESS WE
WENT THROUGH AT THAT TIME
CAREFULLY EVALUATED THE HOUSING
AND SERVICE NEEDS. OF OUR OWN
HOUSE NEIGHBORS FROM THAT
PROCESS ABC AT OUR PARTNERS
BUILDING FUTURES AND OPERATION
DIGNITY. CREATED AN AMAZING
COMMUNITY AT ALAMEDA POINT FOR
FAMILIES SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND VETERANS ALL
HOMELESS AT THE TIME OF MOVING
IN. WE SERVE FIVE. SCHOOLS
INCLUDING ALMOST TWO HUNDRED
CHILDREN FROM THROUGHOUT ALAMEDA
COUNTY WITH SAFE HOUSING SUPPORT
SERVICES CHILDREN AND YOUTH
PROGRAMS A WORKFORCE
OPPORTUNITIES. WE CREATED OUR
COMMUNITY UP OLD NAVY A HOUSING
FACILITIES BUT IT'S TIME TO
REBUILD POWER OUTAGES WATER AND
SEWAGE MAIN FAILURES. ARE ALL
TOO COMMON IN ALAMEDA POINT. THE
COLLABORATIVE HAS PARTNERED WITH
THE CITY IN A MARKET RATE
DEVELOPER ON OUR REBUILD EFFORT.
MARGARITAVILLE OPERABLE
CONSTRUCT INFRASTRUCTURE ON A
PARTIAL ON WHICH THE
COLLABORATIVE WILL BUILD NEW
HOUSING UNITS IN SERVICE PAM
FACILITIES. TO REPLACE THE
EXISTING PROPERTIES AND ADD AN
ADDITIONAL NINETY UNITS OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS. GIVEN THE
HOMELESS CRISIS WE FACE THE
COLLABORATIVE HENLEY INTERESTED
IN SEEING THE BASE REUSE PLAN
FOR ALAMEDA POINT. PROCEED
ACCORDING TO ITS ORIGINAL
TIMELINE. THE SLA AMENDMENTS OF
DAHLE EGGMAN SIMPLY. OF THE
PLAN- DUE TO THE QUALITY OF THAT
THE- COULD OFFER. WE HOUSING
SUPPORT IS IMPACTED. EXEMPT
ALAMEDA POINT FROM THE SLA WE
ALREADY HAVE A RIGOROUS AND
EFFECTIVE FEDERAL PROCESS IN
PLACE THAT SUCCESSFULLY ENSURES
THE LONG TERM PLANNING AND RE
USE THE BASE PROPERTIES MEETS
LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. AND
HOMELESS ACCOMMODATION NEEDS FOR
THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE SWIFT ENACTMENT OF
AB TWENTY THREE NINETEEN TO
ACCEPT ALAMEDA POINT FROM THE
SLA THERE PERSONALLY I'D LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA. FOR
TACKLING THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE IN
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
ANY OTHER FOLKS IN THE AUDIENCE
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT.
OPERATOR WILL TAKE IT TO THE
PHONE LINES- SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY THREE NINETEEN. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
TWENTY THREE NINETEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO ONE HAS SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU WILL
NOW SEE THIRTY WITNESSES PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THAT
WANT TO COME FORWARD. GO OVER
THERE ORIA WHERE WE WANT. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR WICKS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S ANDREAS CLOVER SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IN AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON AB TWENTY
THREE NINETEEN. WE APPRECIATE
THE ENGAGEMENT OF THE AUTHOR AND
HER STAFF TO HELP ENSURE THAT AB
TWENTY THREE NINETEEN WILL BE
AMENDED TO HAVE THE SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE PROTECTIONS
THAT MANY OTHER HOUSING BILLS
HAVE BEEN SIGNED INTO LAW OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL SEVERAL YEARS
HAVE INCLUDED. THE PROJECTS AND
JOBS CREATED BY THIS AB TWENTY
THREE NINETEEN WILL PROVIDE
THOUSANDS OF HOURS OF WORK FOR
APPRENTICES. AND JOURNEYMEN AND
WOMEN THAT LIVE IN THE EAST BAY
AND WHO ARE GRADUATES OF STATE
APPROVED APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
. IT WILL ALLOW THEM CLOSE TO
WHERE THEY LIVE INSTEAD OF
COMMUTING LONG DISTANCES TO
PROJECTS OUTSIDE OF THE AREA
SAVING GAS MONEY AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY TIME THEY COULD NOW
SPEND WITH THEIR FAMILIES. WE
WANT TO REMAIN ENGAGED ON THIS
BILL AND AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AS A
PROJECTS CONTEMPLATED BY AB
TWENTY THREE NINETEEN BEGIN TO
MOVE FORWARD. WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SOMETHING
GREAT FOR THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
THE PEOPLE WHO WORK AND LIVE ON
THE PROPERTY AND FOR THE MEN AND
WOMEN OF THE BUILDING TRADES. IF
AMENDED TO INCLUDE SKILLED IN
TRADE WORKFORCE PROTECTIONS. FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
REMAIN AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL- FOLKS ONE
EXPRESS OPPOSITION. VENTURA
MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE WE
HAD WITH THE AUTHOR AND HER
STAFF AND REMAIN AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND-
OPERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES ANYONE WISH TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION TO. A. B. TWENTY
THREE NINETEEN. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. BUT I'M SURE NO
ONE IS SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK OKAY WE'LL TAKE IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE.
AUSTIN'S. PLEASE BONTA THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS LEGISLATION
FORWARD I THINK IT POINTS OUT
THAT WAY AS WELL INTENDED AS
MANY OF OUR BILLS ARE SOMETIMES
ARE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AND
THOSE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
NEED TO BE DEALT WITH- WITHOUT
DAMAGING THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF
THE LAND OF THE- THEY- MEASURE
OR THAT THE ACT AND THIS IS WHAT
THIS DOES IS VERY NARROW- THERE
ARE MANY CITIES THEY'RE IN THE
SAME SITUATION AS ALAMEDA
ALAMEDA- THAT ARE DEALING WITH
DIFFERENT VERSIONS OF THIS TYPE
OF ISSUE. AND SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY
BECAUSE THIS IMPORTANT PROJECT
FOR ALAMEDA. AND IT'S BEEN ON
THE BOOKS FOR A LONG TIME. AND
THEY NEED TO MOVE THEIR PROJECT
FORWARD AND- SO- APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING ATTENTION TO IT. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CASTING A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SAID HER ANYONE
ELSE. AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND WHICH HAS CLOSE MISS
BONTA. THANK YOU MISTER SEYARTO
I THINK YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS AT
THIS IS A- PART OF OUR CITY THAT
HAS BEEN. LONG IN NEED OF
ATTENTION AND- PRESERVATION AND
PRODUCTION AND DEVELOPMENT.
ALLEN'S I KNOW THAT THE CITY OF
ALAMEDA AND THE PEOPLE OF
ALAMEDA AND THE WORKERS OF
ALAMEDA. ARE COUNTING ON YOU TO
BE ABLE TO MOVE THIS FORWARD
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
RIVAL. THANK YOU JUST TO CLOSE-
APPRECIATE YOUR ADVOCACY ON THIS
BILL MISS BONTA IT'S AN
IMPORTANT BILL ALSO BECAUSE I'M
YOUR NEIGHBOR AND I THINK OUR
WHOLE REGION WILL BENEFIT FROM
IT NOT JUST YOUR DISTRICT SO
I'M- VERY THANKFUL AND ALSO I
KNOW THAT YOU ARE. NOTHING IF
NOT TOTALLY COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH LABOR TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ANSWERED AT THE PROVISIONS AS
THE BILL MOVES FOR AND I'M
REALLY HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD STAY. MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS WEEKS. WEEKS I'D
SAY OCTOBER. HI CARILLO. I
GABRIEL. GABRIEL I KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY QUIRK-SILVA PORT PORT
I. THE BILL SIX ZERO IT'S OUT OF
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
FOLKS OUT ON. OKAY WE NOW HAVE.
MISTER YEAH MISTER. WHAT WHY
DON'T WE GO WITH MISTER STATO.
MISTER VICE CHAIR'S GONNA.
PRESENT. MEMBERS WILL BE ABLE TO
DO THAT YOUR. VERY TIMELY IN THE
ORDER- ON WHEELCHAIR I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT
. AB SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT SEEKS
TO INCENTIVIZE CITIES TO MEET
CERTAIN HOSING GOALS BY
REWARDING THEM WITH MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN THEIR CITY
PLANNING WHEN THEY MEET THESE
HOUSING GOALS THIS BERYL BILL
NARROWLY TARGETS LAND THAT WOULD
NOT BE BENEFICIAL FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT AND PROVIDES A
CARROT FOR CITIES WHO MEET THEIR
ANNUAL. OUR HAVE MET THEIR
ANNUAL HOUSING NEEDS. OUR
NUMBERS AND INCLUDING LOW INCOME
HOUSING. WHILE LARGE CITIES WITH
NEARLY FULLY DEVELOPED ARE THAT
ARE NEARLY FULLY DEVELOP
STRUGGLE TO PROVIDE MORE HOUSING
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE STATE
NEEDS MASTER PLAN CITIES HAVE
CAREFULLY MAPPED OUT THERE
HOUSING AND BUSINESS AREAS. THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW IN VERY RARE IN
PRESCRIPTIVE CASES A CITY TO USE
THIS LAND FOR OTHER PURPOSES
THAT OTHERWISE WOULD NOT BE
HELPFUL OR USEFUL. SO I WANTED
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT IN
PLAIN ENGLISH WHAT THIS BILL WHY
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY AS THE
SURPLUS LAND ACT YOU KNOW- HAS
PUT CERTAIN RESTRICTIONS ON LAND
THAT CITIES HAVE. MAY BE HELD
FOR A WHILE- THAT CITIES MAY USE
FOR- DOING A LAND LEASE- THAT IS
NOT RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT. AND
SO WHAT THIS ALLOWS THEM TO DO
IF THEY ARE MEETING THEIR
HOUSING NEEDS. IS TO DEVELOP
THOSE. THOSE ARE TO ALLOW THOSE
DIVINE TO GO FORWARD BECAUSE
THIS LAND. WOULD NOT ORDINARILY
BE- IT'S NOT GOING TO GET
DEVELOPED IF THE CITY IS HOLDING
IT AND IT'S AN SAY CIVIC CENTER
AREA AND THE PLAN FOR THE CITY
WAS TO HOLD THIS AND USE THE
LAND LEASE TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR OFFICE AND WHICH
PROVIDES JOBS AND IT PROVIDES
JOBS FOR BOTH WHEN THE
CONSTRUCTION HAPPENS AND ALSO
AFTERWARDS AND IT PROVIDES
SUPPORT OF JOBS. AND SERVICES
FOR THEIR SURROUNDING AREAS
WHICH HAVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THEM- THE- THIS TYPE OF LAND AND
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS SO
NARROWLY WRITTEN. THIS TYPE OF
LAND WOULD NOT BE USED. IT WOULD
NOT BE OFFERED IT WOULD NEVER BE
OFFERED UP BECAUSE THE CITY'S
CAN'T AFFORD TO HAVE THAT LAND
TURNED INTO SOMETHING THAT.
ABSOLUTELY OBLITERATES THEY'RE
PLANNING FOR A DOWNTOWN CIVIC
CENTER TYPE SPACE. AND THIS
WOULD NORMALLY I WOULD SAY WOULD
I WOULD NORMALLY MAKE THIS A
DISTRICT BILL IF I COULD BECAUSE
I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH ONE OF
THE CITIES THAT. ARE BROUGHT
THIS FORWARD AND I'M FAMILIAR
WITH IT BECAUSE- TWENTY YEARS
AGO- I WAS INVOLVED IN THE
PLANNING FOR THIS COMMUNITY.
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO AND THIS
WAS PART OF THAT PLAN WAS
INSTEAD OF BURDENING THE
TAXPAYERS BY TAKING OUT BONDS IN
BUILDING THESE ADDITIONAL OFFICE
SPACE. THE LUCK OF THE LAND FOR
THE CIVIC CENTER WOULD HOUSE THE
POLICE STATION LIBRARY SENIOR
CITIZEN CENTER CITY HALL AND
THEN THE LAND LEASES WOULD BE
ABLE TO HELP PAY FOR THE BONDS
FOR THOSE OTHERS. AND IN THE
MEANWHILE THIS AREA IS OUR OUR-
GUITAR JONES FOR. HIGHER DENSITY
DEVELOPMENT. WHEN WE SPOKE WITH
OTHER CITIES ABOUT THIS THEY
WERE HAVING THE SAME TYPES OF
ISSUES. SO WE REALLY NARROWLY
CRAFTED THIS. SO THAT IT WOULD
ONLY BE ABLE TO BE ACCESSED. AND
USED IF CITIES WERE MEETING
THEIR HOUSING NEEDS AND ALSO
WHICH INCLUDE THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ELEMENT. IN THIS
PARTICULAR INSTANCE THERE'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING RIGHT ACROSS
THE STREET AND THERE'S MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHICH I
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER- JUST DOWN
AROUND THE BLOCK FROM HERE. THIS
CIVIC CENTER WAS MEANT TO DO
THAT IN OTHER CITIES THAT ARE
DEVELOPING LIKE OUR CITY HAS
BEEN IN MARIETTA. ARE HAVING THE
SAME ISSUES. SO WE CAN NARROWLY
CRAFTED BILL THAT HELPS THEM GET
PAST THAT HURDLE. WE CAN GET
THOSE LANDS USE USABLE FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES SO THAT THE EXIST-
THE BUILDING OF THE OTHER- THE
REST OF THE HOUSING PART IS
SUPPORTED BY THAT THAT VERY
DEVELOPMENT. SO THAT'S WHY I
BROUGHT THIS BILL- READING THE
BILL LANGUAGE IT'S VERY
CONVOLUTED IT'S VERY HARD TO
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE- WE HAD TO
CHANGE IT INTO. YOU KNOW BILL
LANGUAGE I GUESS. AND BUT WHAT
IT DOES IS JUST ALLOW CITIES. TO
HAVE THAT SMALL EXEMPTION IN
VERY PARTICULAR CASES. JUST LIKE
THE PREVIOUS ONE WE JUST HAD IT
WAS A PARTICULAR CASE THAT
THAT'S HOW YOU SOLVE THE
PROBLEM. AND SO WITH THAT. I DO
HAVE ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE
CALIFORNIA CITIES ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR. JASON RYAN WHO'S GOING
TO TESTIFY HELLO MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS SAID JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES A GIVEN LATE
HOUR OF GRIEF. WE BELIEVE THIS
BILL MAKES A LOT OF SENSE I
THINK THE ONE THING THAT WE NEED
TO KEEP IN MIND IS THAT. IT IS
NEARLY TAYLOR LIKE THE AUTHOR
HAS MENTIONED- IT IT'S ONLY
GOING TO PROVIDE THE FEXIBILITY
TO JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE
MEETING OR EXCEEDING THEIR
PROGRESS TOWARDS ARENA ON THE
GOALS OF THE STATE HAS GIVEN US
A CITY'S GONNA HAVE TO BE VERY
VERY AGGRESSIVE NOT ONLY. IN
REMOVING BARRIERS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL BUT THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO
ACTIVELY SEEK ALL SORTS OF
FUNDING IN ORDER TO GET THOSE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS BUILT.
HISTORY SHOWN- THAT NOT VERY
MANY JURISDICTIONS EVEN THROUGH
THE BEST INTENT. CAN HAVE
PROGRESS AT ALL INCOME LEVELS-
WE BELIEVE THIS IS AN
APPROPRIATE INCENTIVE BASED
PROGRAM A TO GET CITIES TO DO
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER AS
POSSIBLE TO GET AFFORDABLE
UNITS- CONSTRUCTING THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND IF THEY DO
THEY'RE GONNA GET VERY VERY
MODEST FLEXIBILITY ON THE
SURPLUS LANDS ACT. WITH THAT WE
ASK YOUR ABOUT. THANK YOU TO
HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM HAD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR- FOR AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT. GO TO THE
PHONE LINES OPERATOR SUPPORT FOR
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE
PERSON WHO SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. JUST A MOMENT.
GOING TO GO TO LINE. TWO THIRTY.
GET ACTING CHAIR MEMBERS THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE WE LOCK A
FELLOW REPRESENTING FIFTEEN
MARIETTA AND WE REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT ON AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
EIGHT AND APPRECIATE OUR STOCK
NUMBER FOR BRING THIS ITEM
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. GREAT WILL BRING
IT BACK HERE- TO HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S EVAN
T. AS IN ON THE POLICY DIRECTOR
WITH THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OR IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IN PICTURES AND AROUND SEVEN
HUNDRED OR SO FOR THE HOUSING
BUILDERS ADVOCATES AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS. AND RESPECTFUL POSITION
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT WE
APPRECIATE EFFORTS TO CREATE
INCENTIVES FOR MEETING ARENA
REQUIREMENTS. CREATING
EXEMPTIONS IN THE SURPLUS LAND
ACT. IS UNDER MY IS VERY SENATE
PARTS TO ME ARE FOR THE HOUSE
GOALS. THE STATE SURPLUS LAND
ACT AS A LANDMARK FIFTY ALONG
THAT OF THE LAST FEW YEARS
LEGISLATURE STRENGTH STRENGTH-
TO ENSURE THAT WERE ABLE TO ME
ARE AFFORDABLE HOUSING GOALS.
AND RECOGNIZING THAT THAT LAND
PRICES ARE AT A PREMIUM AND THAT
IN THIS ENVIRONMENT
JURISDICTIONS HAVE A REALLY BIG
ROLE TO PLAY. AND WE APPRECIATE
THEM AS GOOD PARTNERS IN MAKING
THE MOST USE OF THESE RESOURCES
FOR HOUSING SOLUTIONS. THE
BILL'S REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
EXEMPTION HAVE A COUPLE OF
CONSTRAINT PRECEDENCE FOR US.
WHILE THE BILL DOES FOCUS ON
LAND THAT'S ZONED TO THIRTY
RESIDENTIAL UNITS. AND THIS MAY
NOT SMUGGLERS OF. DISTILLED OF
LUCK BETTER ACTIVE INTEREST
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
INCLUDINGSOME OF OUR MEMBERS OF
OUR MEMBERS AND OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE AS WELL. A COMMUNITY
LAND TRUST AND I DON'T DO WE
SHOULD BE TAKEN OFF THE TABLE
ADDITIONALLY THE DENSITY
MISSILES THE LEGISLATURE PROVEN
LAST FEW YEARS THEY ALLOW US TO
ADD MORE UNITS THESE PARCELS
WHERE THEY WORK- BEYOND THE
THIRTY UNITS AND HE'S PROCESS
COULD HOUSE DOZENS OF LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND WE CAN'T REALLY
AFFORD TO LET THEM SLIP BY
DURING THE HOUSING CRISIS. AND
LASTLY THE BILL SPECIFIES ANY
LOCALITY THAT'S MADE ANNUAL
PROGRESS TOWARDS ARENAS. I
PASSED. AWAY FOR. SO AND
APPRECIATE THE- NEED TO PROGRESS
ON THESE. BOLTS REWARDING THEM
FOR FONG TATE HOUSING LAW BY
EXENDIN EXEMPTING THEM FROM
OTHER STATE HOUSING LAWS. IS NOT
A WORTHWHILE POLICY TRADE OFF.
WE NEED ALL THE TOOLS AND
RESOURCES AT OUR DISPOSAL FOR TO
MAKE A DENT IN THE HOUSING
CRISIS NOT JUST IN THIS CYCLE
BUT IN FUTURE CYCLES AS WELL WE
WANT TO SHOW YOU HOW THESE
POLICIES AVAILABLE FOR US TO
CONSIDER. AND IF IT DOESN'T WORK
THEY'LL BE PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WORKS BEST THERE- WE THINK
THERE ARE OTHER BETTER KINDS OF
INCENTIVES WE CAN SUPPORT
WHETHER THAT BE INCREASED
FUNDING FOR CITIES OR STATE
GRANTS. AND AS WE FACE A STARK
HOUSING CRISIS AND WE HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF A MILLION PLUS
AFFORDABLE HOMES THAT WE NEED TO
CREATE- WE NEED TO PROTECT AND
STRENGTHEN THE SLA. AND ARCADE
EXEMPTIONS TO APPRECIATE
CONSIDERATION TODAY I APPRECIATE
THE INTENT OF THE AUTHOR- BUT
FOR THOSE REASONS WE ASK HEARING
OF IT TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER FOLKS IN THE ROOM
WHAT WISH EXPRESSED OPPOSITION
TO A. B. SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
BRIAN AUGUSTA ME OFF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION THE PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW PROJECT FOR THE
REASONS STATED VERY AND PAGE WE
ARE ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
. SYNDICATES THE ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ALONG POVERTY IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY AND PH THANK YOU.
MARCUS ALL THE ON BEHALF OF CASH
HOUSING CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY IT WILL BRING
IT BACK HERE TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COLLEAGUES.
WITH THE MOTION FOR A SECOND.
SECOND I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
SECOND CAN'T I'LL GIVE YOU A
COURTESY SECOND THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE- BUT I WILL-
EXPRESSED I FEEL I'VE SHARE THE
CONCERNS THAT THE OPPOSITION IS
REYES AND I WELL I APPRECIATE
YOU TRYING TO BE CREATIVE AROUND
OTHER WAYS WE CAN PROVIDE
INCENTIVES. YOU KNOW I'M- I'M
JUST A LITTLE CONCERNED THAT
IT'S SORT OF REWARDING THE- CAN
I CLOSE YES WHAT DO YOU CLOSER
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT MR.
SO THIS BILL IS NEARLY TERROR
AND TAILORED ON PURPOSE IT'S
BECAUSE IT IS NARROWLY TAILORED
SO THIS THAT COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE LANDS THAT FALL INTO THESE
PARTICULAR CASE TYPE OF
SITUATIONS WILL BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD ON USING THOSE PLANS
THEY WILL NEVER BE OFFERED UP
FOR AWHILE HOUSING THE CITY
COMMUNITIES WILL WIND UP HAVING
TO SIT ON THOSE LANDS UNTIL THEY
CAN AFFORD TO BE THE DEVELOPER
THAT BUILDS ALL OF THE-
ANCILLARY OFFICE BUILDINGS AND
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE GOING INTO
A FOR A PROJECT LIKE THAT- AND-
SO. YOU KNOW I RESPECT THE
OPPOSITION'S. CONCERNS THAT IT'S
GOING TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
LAND THAT THEY HAVE AVAILABLE
BUT IN AREAS OUT IN- VIA IN MY
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE A LOT OF
LAND AVAILABLE AND IT'S- A LOT
OF THAT LAND. IS ZONED FOR THEM
TO BE ABLE TO BUILD. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AFFORDABLE HOUSING ISN'T
NECESSARILY BEING HELD UP. BY
NOT HAVING THE LAND IT'S BEING
HELD UP BY A PROCESS AND WE
TALKED ABOUT THAT THIS MORNING.
SO I UNDERSTAND THEIR CONCERNS
THIS IS NOT A AN ATTACK ON THE
ACT. IT IS SIMPLY TRYING TO TAKE
CARE OF SOME OF THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES SO THAT EVERYBODY
BENEFITS INCLUDING THE PEOPLE
WHO WIND UP LIVING IN THE
ADJACENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS THAT ARE AROUND. AREAS
LIKE THIS SO WITH THAT I DO ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE I APPRECIATE THE
COURTESY SECOND AND-THE- THE
MOTION BY- MY COLLEAGUE. AND I
JUST ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS AND
SPECIAL CONSIDERATION FOR THIS
BILL. THANK YOU FOR AND BRING
THE BEFORE LIKE I SAID I
APPRECIATE THE CREATIVITY BUT I
SHARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF
THE OPPOSITION IS RAISING THE
ARTICULATED THEM WHILE. I'M
DOING A NON RECOMMENDATION ON
THIS- THE BILL BUT WITH THAT YOU
CAN TAKE REAL. MOTION IS TO PASS
WICKS NO SIX NO SEYARTO. YES YOU
ARE YES- CARILLO. CARILLO NO.
GABRIEL GABRIEL NO COLOR. COLOR
NO KILEY. KALI II. QUIRK-SILVA
WARD. WART NO. TWO THIRTY FOUR
FIVE TWO- ICE A FIVE NO DENTIST
TO FIVE- THAT BILL IS- BELIEVE
OPEN. BUT IS FILLED CORRECT YEP
OKAY MOVE ON TO MR WARNER NO MR
MARTUCCI YOU'RE HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH VENTURE AND
I'VE HAD A LONG DAY- FIRST OF
ALL OF FOR THE RECORD I AM
ACCEPTING ALL COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS- SO THIS BILL HAS
GONE FROM. MY INITIAL INTENT TO
HAVE A MUCH MORE MEANINGFUL
BILL- YOU YOU AND I HAD
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT MY DESIRE TO
RAISE THE ISSUE TO. CREATE A
RIGHT TO HOUSING OR SHELTER- TO
IN ORDER TO PRIORITIZE. THE
BUILDING OF SHELTER THE GET
PEOPLE ON HOUSE PEOPLE OFF OUR
STREETS- RATHER THAN SPENDING.
THREE TO FIVE YEARS AND SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO.
BUILD A PERMANENT HOUSING- BUT
AFTER. THE FIRST CUT FROM MR
STONE IN THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
AND NOW WITH THIS COMMITTEE. I
AM LEFT- WITH. THE BILL WHERE
SOME MAY ASK WHERE'S THE BEEF OR
WORSE THE VEGETABLES. BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I HAVE
NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER MERRETT SU CHI. DO WE
HAVE WE HAVE NO NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NO I'M TO
HAVE ANY- FOLKS HERE IN THE ROOM
THAT WE WISH TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
. OKAY OPERATOR GO TO THE PHONE
LINES PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANY SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY FIVE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. NO ONE IS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
OKAY. WE'LL BRING IT BACKHERE
ANY WITNESSES PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. OKAY AND ANYONE
IN THE ROOM AND OPPOSITION. I
THINK WE HAVE NO POSITIONS I
ALSO BRING IT BACK HERE WE'VE
GOT A MOTION A SECOND. IT'S
ALMOST THREE O'CLOCK TEAM. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OKAY- APPRECIATE MR MERCER G.
YOUR CARE PLEASE CLOSE IF YOU'D
LIKE I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE- ON A MORE
MEANINGFUL BILL YES AND I KNOW
YOU AND I HAVE HAD MANY THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND I LOOK FOR TO
THAT WORK AS WELL WITH THAT I'M
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE. MOTION
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS. WICKS I WEEKS
I'D SAY ARGUE. BY SATELLITE
CARILLO. I GABRIEL. GABRIEL I
COLOR KALRA AYE KILEY.
QUIRK-SILVA. HI QUIRK-SILVA HAI
WARD FORD I THAT BILL FIVE SIX
SEVEN IS OUT SEVEN TO ONE WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN THOUGH FOR
REMAINING COLLEAGUES IN WITH
THAT LAST BUT NOT LEAST OUR VERY
OWN MISTER WARD PRESENTING- AB.
SEVENTEEN NINETY EIGHT SEVEN.
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN. THE BORDER
NEAR. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS- AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE ECB TO ADOPT
THE FOLLOWING POLICIES FOR
SPECIFIC HOMELESSNESS GRANT
FUNDS ONE IN ME PUBLISHED A
NOTICE OF FUNDING AND PROVIDE
TIMELINES FOR APPLICATIONS AND
FUNDS TO IT MAY ISSUE FUNDS TO
GRANT RECIPIENT'S UPFRONT RATHER
THAN THE CURRENT REMEMBER THAT
PROCESS THREE IT MAY PROVIDE
APPLICANTS WITH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WHEN THERE IS A
TECHNICAL ERROR DISCOVERED
DURING THE REVIEW PROCESS AND
FOR SHALL ESTABLISH A TRACKING
SYSTEM FOR ALL PROGRAMS
ESTABLISHED UNDER THIS PART. IN
MINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
THIS BILL PROVIDES THE CITY WITH
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION IN
AUTHORITY TO PROVIDE TIMELINES
OF PREDICTABILITY TO THE GRANT
FUNDING PROCESS IS REALLY SOURCE
TO OUR OWN LOCAL EXPERIENCE WITH
CONTINUES OF CARE OF WHICH I WAS
RECENTLY THE CHAIR OF THE
REGIONAL TASK FORCE ON THE
HOMELESS IN SAN DIEGO THESE COME
FROM EXPERIENCES OF JUST- RED
TAPE- AND- BUREAUCRACY THAT
NEEDS LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION AND
AUTHORIZATION WE KNOW IT'LL GET
MONIES DOWN FASTER WHERE THE
WORK IS DONE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO PRESENT MY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THE EXTENT OF ALL. THE PUBLIC
POLICY MANAGER FOR PATH. IF YOU
DON'T. I BELIEVE IS ON THE LINE-
I BELIEVE IS ON. HAND I WOULD BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS YOU'LL BE ACCEPTING
HIM IT'S GREAT AND I BELIEVE- WE
HAVE A WITNESS ON THE PHONE
OPERATOR. RIGHT. THANKS AND HAVE
BEEN WITH THEM. IT WHO IS THE
WITNESS ZEKE. SAN OF ALL WITH-
THE BILL WITH PATH. ARE YOU
THERE. I'M SURE ANY- WHEN THE
LINE FOR THE- IF THIS PERSON'S
MIND DIAL BEEN SEPARATELY. FROM
THE SPEAKER LINE JUST A MOMENT
PLAYS. RICHER SUPPORT ON
PREVIOUS BILLS HE'S AROUND. THE
MOMENT. M. PARDON ME IS THIS MR
SEND THE BALL. YEAH SPEAKING.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SORRY
ABOUT THAT GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE THANK YOU SHARE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT BILL-
THIS IS A SET OF ALL ON THE
FOOTBALL TEAM MANAGER FOR PATH
PEOPLE ASSISTING THE HOMELESS WE
ARE ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
NONPROFIT HOMELESS SERVICE
PROVIDERS OPERATING IN MORE THAN
A HUNDRED FIFTY CITIES AROSS
THE STATE. IN ADDITION TO
PROVIDING SERVICES LIKE OUR
REGION CASE MANAGEMENT WE ALSO
DIRECTLY CONFRONT THE ROOT
CAUSES OF HOMELESSNESS THROUGH
OUR FOR THE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
ARM PATH TO DENTURES SO WE NOTED
THE JOURNEY OUT OF HOMELESSNESS
DOESN'T TAKE A DAY CREATING AND
DELIVERING THE ADEQUATE HOUSING
AND SERVICES TO GET SOMEONE
HOUSE TAKES TIME AND COMMITMENT
WHICH REQUIRES THAT SERVICE
PROVIDERS BE ABLE TO RELY ON
CONSISTENT AND PREDICTABLE
FUNDING. EVEN WITH THE HELPING
FUNDS CURRENTLY. ON THE HOUSE
YOU COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT FLEXIBILITY CAN TURN
WHAT SHOULD BE A MACHINE WITH
ALL INSPIRE INTO A WHOLE THING
AND STUTTERING PROCESS SO PROUD
MAKE THAT USE MANY OF THE GRANT.
SEEN BY HCD INCLUDING THE FOR.
FEDERAL READ AND POST. TELL
MERGING DELUSIONAL GRANT TO
DEVELOP THE BLOCK GRANT DOLLARS
. MANY OF OUR SIR. AS CONTRA
THROUGH A LOCAL SCO C. LEAD PIKE
STREET OUTREACH. OUT NAVIGATION
ON SUCH SERVICE. UP ONE IN. AND
MORE. APPLE TIME. TRACKING FOR
THOSE. WOULD HELP BOTH PROVIDERS
LIKE US INTEREST YOU SEE
PARTNERS PREPARE THE NECESSARY
STAFF RESOURCES. TO MAKE THE
BEST USE OF AVAILABLE FUNDS WE
ALSO APPLY DIRECTLY TO THE HOME
INVESTMENT PARTNERSHIP AND
NATIONAL HOUSING TRUST FUND
DOLLARS TO BUILD NEW AFFORDABLE
PERMITS FOR HOUSING. BUILDING
HOUSING IT'S COMPLICATED AND THE
DETAILS MATTER SO IT'S OBVIOUSLY
IMPORTANT THE H. C. DOES THE DUE
DILIGENCE IN CHECKING FOR
MISSING INFORMATION OR TECHNICAL
ERRORS ON. BUT UNDER THE CURRENT
STRUCTURE. H. C. AUTHORIZED AT
WHAT APPLICANTS LIKE APPLE ANY
OF OUR PARTNERS KNOW OF ERRORS
OR HOW TO FIX THEM UNTIL THE
APPLICATIONS ALREADY REJECTED.
AS A WASTE OF EVERYONE'S TIME
AND MONEY AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT AUTHORIZES HCD PROVIDED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE DURING THE
APPLICATION REVIEW PROCESS.
COMMONSENSE FIX ALREADY
PRACTICED BY OTHER DEPARTMENTS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD SAID THIS
IS THE WAY TO MAKE THE BEST
POSSIBLE USE THE MONEY TO WE
ARE. UNVEILED I KNOW SOMETHING
THAT OF US ARE. IN SO. WE
HAPPILY SUPPORT AND- REQUEST AND
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY WITH IN THE ROOM TWO X.
SUPPORT. OKAY ON THE PHONE
OPERATOR A SUPPORT FOR AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY EIGHT. NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT IT. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN TERROR AT THIS TIME. NO ONE
IS SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK OKAY WILL BRING ABOUT HERE
TO THE ROOM ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES INOPPOSITION. OKAY WE
WILL BRING IT TO THE ROOM ANYONE
WISH TO. EXPRESS OPPOSITION THE
ROOM. OKAY OPERATOR OF WE HAVE
NO POSITIONS FILE I BELIEVE SO
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
DYESS. ANY QUESTIONS FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES. FORTY FIVE MINUTE
DEBATE ANYONE NO OKAY. OKAY DO
WE HAVE A MOTION. YET THE SECOND
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE IN
A FULL DAY I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST HER AYE VOTE LEAVE I'M
HAPPY TO GIVE IT TO YOU AND
HOPEFULLY WE'LL SEE THIS BILL
THROUGH AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP. MOTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS WHO WAKES HI I
SEE ARGUE. I CARILLO. I APRIL
APRIL I KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY.
QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA I WARNED
I WORK I SUBTILIS OUT THANK YOU
FOR THE LAST BILL WE WILL ADD ON
FOR FOLKS WHO'VE MISSED VOTES.
RIGHT SIX ARE HEARING TEAM- IF
FOR ANY MEMBER YEP LET'S GET
THIS THING DONE YEAH- THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- QUIRK-SILVA THERE IS
ITEM NUMBER TEN THAT'S I. AND
THAT WILL BE. EIGHT ZERO ZERO-
ITEM NUMBER Q. A. B. TWENTY-
ELEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. QUIRK-SILVA I
712-111-2011 TWENTY ELEVEN NOW
YEAH. I AM NUMBER TWO THIRTIES
A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR SEVEN
MEMBER CARILLO. A. B. SIXTEEN
FIFTY FOUR- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT DAVIS HI. THAT IS OUT
EIGHT ZERO. A ITEM NUMBER THREE
I THINK WE ARE COMPLETE NUMBER
OF FOR US AB FIVE SIXTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL. I. SEVEN ZERO- NUMBER- FIVE IS
COMPLETE- NUMBER SIX A. B.
SEVENTEEN ARE. FOUR EIGHT EIGHT-
AS A MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA. WARNING. CERVANTES TWO FIVE- I AM
NUMBER SEVEN AB NINETEEN THIRTY
THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD. I.
EIGHT TWO ZERO- NUMBER EIGHT AB
TWENTY NINETY SEVEN IS A MEMBER-
CARILLO. ASSEMBLY. SIX TWO ONE.
KESSLER COMPLETE THEIR- YEAH I'M
SORRY JUST ELEVEN OF THEM ALL
THE FINAL VOTE IS- SIX TO ONE
WITH ONE- MEMBER NOT MORNING.
NUMBER NINE IS COMPLETE CAN-
NUMBER ELEVEN A. B. NINETEEN
NINETY ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY
. ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA I. SEVEN TWO ZERO. I
AM NUMBER TWELVE TWO OF TWO ZERO
ZERO TWO SEVEN MEMBER WICKS HI
HI A CARILLO- KOREA I
QUIRK-SILVA. QUIRK-SILVA I.
EIGHT EIGHT ZERO- NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB TWO ZERO THREE ONE
US A MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA. FOR
INCREASES OF FIVE- TO WITH ONE
MEMBER NONVOTING- NUMBER
FOURTEEN- AB TWENTY TWO ELEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL. I'M
SORRY NUMBER. FOURTEEN TWENTY
TWO ELEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THANKS BILL. TAKING. OKAY-
SEPTEMBER GABRIEL. AT ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN YES TWENTY THREE
ELEVEN. GABRIEL I ASSEMBLY
REWARD. OR I THAT IS OUT EIGHT
ZERO- S. AT NUMBER FIFTEEN AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY SEVEN IS
COMPLETE A SIX TO ONE WITH ONE
MEMBER NONVOTING. OUR NUMBER
SIXTEEN AB TWENTY THREE
NINETEEN- KILEY. QUIRK-SILVA
THIS NUMBER SIX ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE NINETEEN. I
THERE IS SEVEN TWO ZERO-
SEVENTEEN IS A CONSENT ITEM-
NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL. WART I. SEVEN TWO ONE.
NINETEEN WARNING WAS FULL TWENTY
ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY- IS
THE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY FIVE THAT'S
HOW SEVEN TWO ZERO. AND I AM.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA.
QUIRK-SILVA I WILL BE SIX TWO
ONE AND JUST TO CLARIFY- FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY EIGHT FAILED TO FIVE WITH
ONE MEMBER NOT VOTING I BELIEVE-
CORRECT YEAH OKAY. ALL RIGHT
MEETING ADJOURNED JAMES.